hello I'm back hello I'm back guys probably oh my god okay
it really sucks whenever if I crash in the middle of it cuz
then like um it messes with like a lot of shit we're back no
they have two files of the shit that fucking damn it
I know I can't no I have two Twitch VODs now God fucking god
damn it I didn't want to have two VODs oh man no the worst
part is that it messes with my okay here's a little behind
the scenes insider thing it messes with like average stream
CCV for Twitch because like it lowers my average CCV on my
Twitch side so then like it fucks with my entire average too
because like for those who don't know I've talked about this
before but sponsors are based off of your based off of your
average CC like how much you're getting paid is based off of
your average CCV overall for a month can you invite your
teammates here for the show match I don't think I have any
of you guys um so then like the fact that i have a 40 minute
stream i have a random ass 40 minute stream and it lowers my
average ccv by a lot with the crash my uid i can't nuke it
because it's still there even if you nuke it the the data
still exists
Oh, that's a bill.
God damn it.
All right.
Yeah, when you sent me yours the other day, Craig, I thought
that was your Steam ID.
I ran.
I added some random dude on Steam.
But you get two Twitch streams.
I don't know who it was, but.
At least you guys get two streams.
Does he flats out of them?
Yeah.
All right.
It's fine.
I just have to stream a bit longer today.
And we had two games.
So now, yeah, we just had streaming.
a little longer today yeah god i hate it when that happens
that's it i'm doing borderless i don't fucking care i don't
know why it does that i it's so fucking weird um like it
like it doesn't it's like a risk it happens like once every
like like maybe once a month i think uh it's because like my
monitor, my monitor is 500 hertz, but my other two monitors,
one is 60 hertz, one is 500 hertz, the one is 200, 244
hertz, and the other one is, uh, 60 hertz.
Um, because of that, um, I play the game on 500 hertz on my
main monitor, and, uh, and when I alt tab on full screen,
Two monitors have to adjust to it as well.
Uh, because I'm going back to...
Yeah, so it's like...
It's so weird.
It's so fucking weird.
I can't...
Yeah.
I can't have...
Because I can't set it all in the same hurts.
That's the thing.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
We're on this team.
I was like, that's my team.
We're...
We're this team.
But yeah, no.
It's too much.
You're supposed to not set your monitor.
Uh...
you're not supposed to set your other two monitors to like
the same like five like it doesn't even go to 500 hertz
anyway but it's apparently not good for your pc if you have
all of them at 500 hertz no the lowest one cat yeah i yeah
so it's not apparently i was told it's not even good to have
all of them set at like a high hurt like um set to the same
apparently from what i've heard I hate it when that happens
Especially if I'm on It's okay if I'm YouTube But when it's
on Twitch
God damn it It's bad when it happens on Twitch
Uh Juju thank you for the Twitch Prime Thank you I would
like really love to but I'm currently on like Oh yeah I
think He's just not transferred over yet.
A stun lock?
Yeah, I don't know how, but they're giving me 100 lattice,
and they've done it like a million times.
All right, I'm out.
Oh, I wish that was.
Oh, no.
I would hate when someone just started giving me tons of
lattice for free.
I don't know.
I don't think you understand.
Seriously, what did I say?
What did I say?
Also, I don't know if Sound Guy is alive, right?
Oh, my God, so many voices.
Don't do that.
Oh, my God, there's too many voices.
Don't do it with the cranky.
Don't do that.
There's too many voices in my head right now.
I'm way too tired for this shit.
I'm way too fucking tired right now to hear all these voices
in my head.
Nuclear.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you.
I can't believe a quick play game took me down.
I knew I should.
Why did I play that quick play game?
God damn it.
I can't believe it.
The quick game, quick play game took me out.
Why did I play it?
Goddamn quick play.
So who's playing Deadpool?
Yeah, what is our team comp?
I don't really know what we're playing here.
I can do it if we need to.
I play a lot of them, but it's up to you.
If someone wants to play them, you can take them.
Isn't Tank Deadpool the best Deadpool version?
I think so.
Yeah, no, no.
I'm not trolling.
Trust me, did God's work on tank.
Yeah, yeah, no, he's fucking insane on Deadpool.
I don't even know what comps work with a solo Deadpool
because both teams have only one tank.
Oh, I can play tank too.
It's fine.
Oh, yeah, we didn't.
Are we going to 2-1-3 because we also have three support
players?
They also have three support players.
I would like to play tank if possible, you know.
You get tanked then.
I'll play the pierce.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god, we don't have to play triple support.
Where?
I don't know if that...
Oh my god.
We don't have to play triple support, guys.
It's a dream come true.
A 2-2-2?
What is...
In this...
In this day of age?
I'm so fucking... I'm so out of it.
My body does not know today is a stream day.
My body.
My body does not know.
I slept so much.
I think I slept too much.
Toki, please.
It doesn't know.
Who are they missing?
I think that was in Kingsman, though.
Kingsman, yeah.
I think he's stuck in a rank game, I'm pretty sure.
Bro.
I'm pulling up the stream.
Queuing a rank game before it's crazy.
Yeah, yeah, he is in a rank game.
It is, it is like one minute left, though.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
I assume he was playing rank games.
He's like, I literally, like, looked at it before about it.
my stream started and saw that Kingsman was playing Rink.
Yeah, yeah.
Flesh, can you invite me again?
It served lots of...
Good thing tomorrow is no stream day.
No stream day tomorrow.
Thank God.
Oh, two Doki streams back to back.
Yep.
And it's all rivals.
Yay!
I'm still...
I'm actually low-key.
I'm like, God, fucking it damn it because like here's like a
little behind the scenes uh because like um my twitch
streams are like spontaneous on how i feel um i like uh so
it's more so because like you know i i put like i put like
random stuff on twitch but my average was lowered a little
bit for uh for uh last month because of that because i like
i said it's like all over it's just random depends on like
whatever i'm streaming and no i i like i was a little
irritated i was like god damn it why did my pc crash there
uh so like the early access for the deadpool rivals thing i
was paid uh less uh because a lot of companies are very
strict on like average ccv uh so i was paid let like less
than what i was usually paid for for when i get sponsored to
do early access so i was like okay i can't i can't around
yeah i was like okay okay i gotta i gotta stream a little
longer on twitch yeah i'm brain off i'm gonna miss it okay
game's over he's coming yeah he's coming that's that was
like a little i was like god damn it
12 hour marathon
We're off-stream Marvel, all on-stream.
All right, wait, whoa, slow down there, buddy.
Slow down there.
I still need me time, guys.
I still need me.
Yeah, it's messing with my Fortnite pay, guys.
I don't worry.
Don't worry.
The Marvel Rival Sponsor money goes directly into my
Fortnite skins.
And then, guys, you don't understand.
It affects my Fortnite skin money.
But Toki, think about the Fortnite skins.
I know, that's why I'm so mad.
I'm like, my Fortnite, my V-Bucks pay!
I guess it counteracts.
I need to be able to buy Stitch on Fortnite.
My Fortnite pay.
I actually don't even know.
Okay, guys, how's the audio of everyone?
I'm also, like, super checked out at the moment.
I...
Sound guy out here?
I don't know.
I'm not sure.
I wonder if you do two streams.
Oh, I guess it doesn't count.
I was like, thank you.
You do two streams.
Does it count?
Does it combine into it?
who knows
oh we're just waiting right now at this moment we're just
waiting alright you guys here hello yes sir yep we're here
I'll just tell them we're ready oh that's if we want bands
oh oh wow no bands Let's just rip it.
Let's just go.
The day's shine.
Show them a real show.
It's a show match, right?
We gotta give them a real show.
Yeah, do no bans.
Yeah, yeah.
And then day can play Spider-Man all he wants.
All right.
No bans.
Oh, wait.
I was gonna say and this day can play spider-man Wait, all
right, if we wait a minute Hi, wait a minute they what are
we're discussing the band style because this is for fun They
said as long as day doesn't play spider-man.
They don't want bands.
Wait if our one trick can't play their his one trick Then
their one trick can't play their one trick.
Oh, I I mean, I you know, you know, Flats, that wasn't a
part of the fine print.
So I think you could play Spider-Man.
I could play Spider-Man, yeah, actually.
As long as you've got a dead, the only rule is there's got
to be a deadpool.
Not true.
All right, if I can't play Spider-Man, Kingsman can't play
magic.
Oh!
You know, you can make that rule.
Yeah, that should be a rule.
If I can't play Spider-Man, they can't have a dive
character.
And we can't have a dive character either.
Yeah, yeah, get that working in the chat.
All right, Kingsman.
Just gentlemen.
Okay, okay, sounds good.
I think that should be fair also, what I put in the chat.
all right oh yeah moxie can't play hawk guy they can't play
hawk guy like that's if you can't play
spidey not okay to that anyway dive for dive
no jeff that's the risk i'm willing to take What did he do?
Alright.
Just play with bad.
That's our bad.
This is like...
The verbal bad pick.
Hey, it's not...
There's no contract.
Technically, we could break it.
Never make a verbal contract, guys.
Alright.
Can we please...
Let us play the game.
chill won't be long wait what else are you waiting for oh i
guess we're casting oh sound guy spotted sound guy so i have
no idea message on discord because i i can't see on twitch
and you can break them huh oh interesting turn down molly
okay off right now all right turning down um i turn it I'll
do it.
Oh, up.
Turning up.
What are we waiting on now?
The band's still?
I think we're waiting on production.
Alright, let's see.
No, I saw the chat sound guy.
Chat was parodying what you said.
No magic or no akai and no spidey or I think guys just
jokes.
I think guys just jokes.
Okay.
You think so?
I think they were dead I think they were dead serious.
all right yeah we just let me okay now i can disassociate
for a second guys i say you play spidey yeah i'm a scammer
you know we can make the deal but i'll still be on
spider-man
that's why you never make a verbal contract it's non-binding
true real you'll need a top-notch team to win this one
guys make sure that contract is signed we didn't sign
nothing
it's actually true verbal contracts um are non-binding only
because nothing is like uh oh they're legally binding yeah
but where's your proof that it's verbal unless it's recorded
i guess what the hell unless it's recorded you have proof
you fucking had a verbal contract It's gonna follow the
leader.
Wait, if anybody on the team played this match?
30 seconds before.
Yeah, it sucks.
Wait, nope!
Oh my god, wait, no fans!
Camp at Loki is open.
End over with Spider-Man.
Spider-Man, you can't even say that with a straight face.
Oh no.
No, me and Moxie, we're going in the ring.
Yeah, we're going in the ring.
Oh no.
Alright, we have, technically We can play Gambeloki if we
want to be extra scummy.
If you insist.
Oh my!
He's dead.
All right.
I think it's...
Yeah, he went magic!
Like, knew it.
It's non-binding.
It's never binding.
He's a...
I gotta look it, I gotta look it.
I need help, yeah.
They're actually running triple.
I fucking knew it when J3 put three supports on both teams.
I knew this was gonna happen.
Yeah, because...
Yeah, because they have three support players.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
No.
He's one.
Nice and nice.
He's still moving.
Very nice.
Someone supports you.
Oh, he knew it.
Maybe having no bans was a bad idea.
Just a maybe.
They say we're freaks.
They're literally running triple.
What do they mean?
That's worse.
You slam.
There is They use lamps.
Yeah, they did.
I can actually I'll alt this next Oh, that's a full spot
You're fine.
You're so healthy But I'm dead.
You know what?
I'm fucking alting this.
Let's go I like this.
I like this all Yeah, yeah, look at that I'll just push the
payload don't worry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah You can be a cute passenger princess
for us.
Mr. Flats?
Yeah, just get Flats.
Get him, get him, get him.
Read the book.
Get the gap.
There, yeah, yeah.
We got it.
Yeah, and we have another Gambit all.
Let's go.
Another Gambit all is crazy.
You know that character's anti-dive, right?
How are you done with Spider-Man?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We'll play anti-dive against Spider-Man.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, come on.
You copy me whenever.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, no!
That's fine.
It's okay.
all there else for that it's okay it's worth it um i don't
know where any of y'all are i'm not gonna lie to you um this
map is like a fever dream yeah i have no idea what's going
on in this map it's just it's i hate this maverick it's so
confusing nice
all right i mean they can't So healthy.
Oh, let's go.
Let's push up.
We have two picks.
I got their cloak up.
Look out.
Look at their...
Nice.
I hear... There's a Deadpool behind us, by the way.
There's a magic in here.
Moxie Mag won.
He's... Oh, never mind.
He was.
It's not coming for me, is he?
You're so okay.
Oh, I'm dead?
I'm almost back.
Oh, you're like, technically you're...
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
You're not even.
I'm out.
I have luck soon.
We can use that.
fantastic all right all right oh my god oh okay do we need
we don't need we can reset we can reset yeah I was gonna say
yep yeah we definitely reset how'd you go how'd you go all
right flash your body yourself we're resetting we're so far
away from you.
I'm okay.
All right.
We're still, I still need a wait.
Okay, you ready?
Three, two, one, go.
Oh, Blaster's so far from me.
Oh, shoot.
There's so far.
Good.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Oh my God.
Oh, you got a day.
Oh, my God.
There's still people behind us.
Oh, I got the point though.
Nice, nice, nice.
Solo cab, solo cab.
They can't get in there in time.
They can't get there in time.
You're good.
Yeah, we're good.
Yeah, we're here.
C9, C9.
Easy bait.
C9.
Look at that.
That's embarrassing.
That's the real show.
Nice.
Very nice.
Oh.
I've never seen third point on this map.
Yeah, you have to like, shit.
You gotta be on like the raft or something.
I don't know.
You gotta be on the raft, right?
Yeah.
Uh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You can, but you don't, you don't push the car if you're in
the middle.
Oh, really?
Yeah, apparently.
Oh.
You can't contest it or push, or like do anything when
you're in the middle, but you can, it looks cool.
Sounds strange as head.
Are you gonna copy me here?
Copy me here?
I'm behind you.
I'm trying to see you.
Yeah, yeah.
There is a...
What am I aiming at?
Magic's so low.
You know Lambs?
He's going up.
Wait, look at Moga.
Look at Moga.
He's running it down.
Go, go, go!
Dead.
Wait, wait.
Kill Chloe.
Oh, I'm dead.
Whoa, Moxie really wants to kill us.
I got him.
Three on.
Nice.
Is the blue light?
What's on?
Is it this?
This deserves.
Yeah.
See, the blue light is what's on.
Oh.
All right.
careful for moxie's hot guys oh shit yeah it is i always i'm
backing up fully
i'm fully out oh yeah no no don't worry goodbye lulu yeah we
i knew that moment we were it was no point fighting there
was no point fighting that
I think Hawkeye's left side.
I kind of want to go see what's up there anyways.
Oh, nice.
Alright, we didn't go in.
So where's that gonna happen to us?
Top right is the magic.
Luna is one, got Luna.
Wait, get bogey, get bogey.
He's anti?
He's what?
Wait, that portal's bad.
Let's get three on.
That portal's bad.
I can't.
He's in the floaty flats.
He's in the floaty.
Oh, does anyone have portal?
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, no, but sorry.
We don't need portal.
We're not that sweaty, guys.
Like a testing guy.
Yeah.
That's why I thought we did fantastic.
Yeah, I think we did.
pretty well i mean i think we did actually so good like
majority of them are on their mains and we're just having
fun except why is nobody else pumped up like me like what's
going on this was amazing we're going bucking we're going
bucking against uh shameless yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
anti-dive is a bit shameless but it's okay
No, it's okay.
I mean, they did go triple support.
That's right.
They did.
They did go triple support, guys.
Like, we had to go Loki.
Loki Gambit.
Yeah, they deserve the Loki Gambit when they start off
triple support.
I mean, we got third point.
I did see it was gonna happen.
They have three support players.
We technically do two.
Nine miles away?
What the fuck is this?
It's a bit of a walk.
Yeah, it's an arms race.
I had a feeling.
I was like, if there's no bends, if they fuck, I've had a
feeling or go triple support.
Loki Gamb is the only way we can gather it.
Like here.
There's...
Yeah, just here.
How about a boost guy up in the air, Flats?
Oh, that's awkward.
That's pretty.
You might need, uh...
There is any magic right here to right behind us.
I got him.
Oh, we don't really have frontline right now.
I'm good.
Oh, he's one though, he's one I got.
You might need a shield.
Yeah.
You could pull that out too if you guys are inclined.
Let me know.
I think we got it.
I think we're fine.
We got a cragio.
I need a...
Oh, I got a fight.
I got you.
He's one.
Oh, I can't do anything about it.
There is a dead pool behind us.
all
right hey there is a hot guy also killing all of us we might
need a shield tank
just a maybe
you're the lucky i'm dead i'm still in gambit's chance i
don't think so it's very far but we could try i'm back
faster my own i'm coming i'm coming i can't see you i can't
build some portals because we're always like uh right you
know i was it was a it was a touch attempt that's what that
was i'm dead it's very difficult to build some portals
because the hot guy is just like destroying the front line
oh yeah the hot guy's a little scary i shall help with this
oh can i pull it to the right
what's this room
I have all here.
Yeah, you ready?
Yeah, yeah.
All right, go.
Dead,
but I traded their support.
All right.
Oh, my.
The Hawkeye ult.
Oh, my goodness.
Wait, does anyone play mag?
Regis.
Well, I can, but I'm kind of the Deadpool guy.
That's it.
We have to have a Deadpool guy.
I'll go back.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I Think We might actually okay, I was gonna say.
Yeah Outside I type those two
Outside of the magic Jeez my head I am ready to put on a
show All right
Look at that real Luna, real Luna.
Yeah, I got me nice.
Point, point, point, point, point, point, point.
No, mine.
I think, oh, I think we actually have to go...
Where am I?
Gambit low key for this.
Oh.
Hey, nobody stealing gambits.
I went from four deaths to 10 in the span of two minutes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now that we have mag, it should be easier.
Because we have a front line where...
That's how I'll be sometimes.
Yeah.
It's just hot guy things that you have to have.
Can we combo here?
Oh.
Whenever you're ready.
Do we have runs?
Do we ever adventure?
You can use it, whatever.
whatever yeah I'm all I'm all here I'm all here yeah yeah
break the windows yeah break the windows at you I'm just
getting my head taken off outside them outside
There's been a lot of pressure on their backline here.
Yeah.
I'm putting a lot of pressure on our spawn room right now.
I got dead poodles so I'm going to die on point.
Yeah.
We have it.
I'm not there, though.
That's fine.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
Yet to use it now.
I inside I inside the hot guy he's one I'm one little one
little one I'm
I don't we don't have another support else though okay
that's okay that's okay we have dragon deal all right when
all right
they're flanking around right
they're on left they're on left That's you.
In a long day, a little tired.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
All right.
Sometimes that happens.
One thing I'm hoping it's good.
It's good.
I would.
Oh, my God.
That's a huge old.
I'm dead, too.
I was, we were so close up.
You guys saw, you guys saw.
Use it.
stall as much as you can we have cloak out here if you can
uh alt it as an alt it's living good he's living good i hear
a whole thing how about you use your cloak out use your
cloak out nice stay on the raft do not get off the raft i'm
sorry i'm staying and then i have i have it's a pool party
got you i'll let the wait wait i have a hot guy up I'm
upping this I'm upping this this magic's up my ass we can
kill her we can kill her magic's dead taking a photo
No We have low-key alt soon careful
Can't see you all right can I build out try and build out.
I'll just keep you up I'm gonna go I think we should do
gambit first.
I think we should do gambit first.
Yeah, we don't all right I'll get it.
I'll get that.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I'm up.
I'm going to get Porter.
You guys should win, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We win this.
We win this fight.
I got it.
Nice.
Um, we're ready to put on a show.
Um, it's not looking too good for me.
It's fine.
We're at 80.
I could not tell you what is happening at this point.
Good heals.
Mal's good, Mal's good, Mal's good.
Mal's so good.
Nice, nice, nice.
I killed you, I killed you, I killed you!
We almost have Cloco here.
Yeah.
New burger, burger, burger, burger, burger.
Yay!
Let's go!
Oh my yes!
All we needed was triple support.
I fucking love triple support.
He can never escape.
Oh, back in one second.
Well, you can tell them if they ask us.
Are you ready?
I'll be here.
What?
God, I was so fucking locked in.
I was like, I was so, oh my God.
It's too early for this.
That's all I'm going to say.
It's too fucking early for this.
It's, yeah.
Oh,
it's too early.
And true.
That's why I think maybe we should bring Bans back.
Oh, my God.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Maybe we do Bans.
I think they pick MAP.
Yeah, they pick MAP.
We picked the side.
going full full roll book oh my god i'm so tired i'm so
tired like i don't know who it was they're like trying to
have a conversation i'm like we're gonna get pushed
i'm gonna get pushed
please i'll tell you about my day after the fight is over no
i think it was item malaya or uh or lulu
all right sound guy has some sound for me to just all right
uh malaya needs to be up craiggy up day up okay craiggy up
day up craiggy day up craiggy up malaya up all right oh we
have malaya up a lot okay malaya okay there you go I have to
apply all right that should be good all right we're okay now
I am My brain is rebooting right now Give me a sec I need to
disassociate I feel like that's happening It's like me Every
fucking game Every rival is game Now I'm just like Give me a
sec I got I got disassociated That's way too much Brain
power on a Sunday That's way too much Like I thought this
was gonna be A for fun A show match And then we ended up
playing Triple support
gambit the only reason we won that was because we went low
we have a low-key player and we have a gambit player um but
i the enemy team doesn't have a low key like doesn't have a
gambit player yeah no fun as god intended yeah i just i had
to do triple support last night last night i had to locate
Kevin all we're like at three games man I don't want to get
kicked out
oh find a fourth fun show match everyone they should make
everyone play their off roll
oh my god
no I refuse I'll be on DPS I refuse to be on Tank I've only
I the only tank I know how to play is mag because it's like
baby's first tank like everyone knows how to play mag I
literally bubble bubble shield and then occasionally shoot
jokes on you I don't I'll do it we should have wait have one
game where everyone plays their off-road
there we go yeah hit those supports off of support
your support on deadpool
Dead pool tank.
There you go.
I think everyone playing off-roll would be fun, honestly.
All right.
Are we all here?
Are we ready?
Yeah, we're ready.
Yeah, I'm ready.
I don't know.
Do I read that right?
Are we doing an off-roll game?
I don't know I feel like I'll say that and then they're
they're just gonna break it like last I think it'd be really
fun I think if everyone plays their off roll it'll be a
natural show match I think that's a great idea yeah but like
is Doki bird on spider-man okay okay buddy okay I think I
have zero hours on spider-man uh all right yeah off everyone
on off roll Support, play, a deadpool of take.
All right.
Are we actually all doing off, really?
Let's go.
Are they doing it?
I hope they...
Are we attack or defense?
We're on attack.
I feel like they're definitely not, if I'm honest.
Okay, we can easily swap off.
I like this pick.
Yeah, we can...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
I'll play tank deadpool.
idea how to play oh wait you're gonna play tank okay
actually i'll play dps dead pool hey wait we don't have a
support coming out the comp you're looking real wait we're
running we're missing a a support guys we're missing one
support player can you not go around this way oh i'm
trolling i don't play this map in so long All right.
Okay, they're not doing it.
We go back.
They're not doing it.
We swap.
Oh, wow.
I'm swapping.
Okay.
I knew they weren't.
I knew they were going to break it.
These guys are no fun.
They really want to win.
it someone over here i found him he's anti he's dead maybe
it's you actually there
was a second one all right down you only have one support in
its gambit just so you guys know i just swap oh yeah that is
we have oh my god we were playing the bad map
Moxie gap Moxie gap nice nice.
You're better.
You got gap by a spider-man player
No, but I just find us somewhere.
Yeah, I'll I'm looking They're portaling.
They're portaling
They're on point
I'm dead.
Hand side or hand side.
Can you show up?
That's huge.
It's huge.
Kingman?
Nice.
All right.
Oh my god.
They're running triple with Gambit Loki now.
I'm on Loki.
We can't lose.
Nice.
Yeah, I was going to say you're on Loki.
When did we get two lokies?
They realize.
Oh shit.
Bring it out.
I do not have...
Oh.
I have all here?
Is it worth it?
Fuck it, let's do it.
It's always worth it.
Oh, the supports are so anti.
Yo, Moxie needs to stop getting gapped.
There's a lock-in.
We do have another gamut all soon.
You mean?
Thank you.
I got you.
Oh, he's one.
He's one?
Wait, we can ult this.
Whatever.
You can ult this whenever.
Actually, we can wait for the cloak.
Alright.
They use both support ults.
So they don't have Gambit anymore.
They shouldn't have any Gambit ults.
Oh, hey, how you doing?
Oh, I need that, actually.
Thank you.
Backing out, because he's a Hawkeye ult.
Yeah, oh, I'm just...
Oh, I got him, actually.
Oh, nice.
I have ult soon.
Oh, I'm so dead now, though.
If you can...
Oh, how's your save?
You can live.
And Malaya, something tells me that Kingsman isn't running
the ones.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I ain't old this here.
This isn't Kingsman giving me about the ass.
Are you guys ready?
All right, let's go.
Oh, man.
I hope you win this 1v1 because he's not 1v1ing you.
He's 1v1ing me!
But I don't think he respects your challenge.
I don't think he's respecting the 1v1.
He ran away from you.
dead pulls behind us they're all dead right now
i can't get to you
oh i don't think they're i don't think they're doing any one
is not gonna lie
Almost at my ult.
Yeah, I'm behind you and want to copy.
I'm letting you heal it.
All right, are you an altus?
That's nice.
Oh, I'm dead too.
You have no supports.
Hey, Cloak.
No supports, by the way.
No supports.
Wait, make him win.
Make him win.
Oh, I'm dead.
He in with the arms.
If we live, we have a...
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Loki's coming over now.
Oh, I'm dead.
Can't see you guys yet.
Wait, they copied that boy though.
Yeah, they did pulls one.
Okay, if you can get your all combo with you.
Yeah, I'm trying, I'm trying, I'm trying.
I got it, I got it!
Go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, that's awkward.
Wait, he died, he died!
We win this.
Deadpool Deadpool Deadpool 1-1-1
Oh I have to back away Who do you think he is?
Who do you think he is?
Oh they're fordling?
Can we look low here?
Deadpool 1!
Deadpool 1?
Low key low low low This?
I'm on Strange?
There we go.
Wait, we have Gambitler.
Yay!
I have another low kill soon.
I'll let you heal.
Alright, here we go.
Man, these guys are very sweaty.
No off rolls.
No 1v1s.
It's hot.
It's a real game.
straight demon time the whole time yeah and then the and
then the last guy do a tournament later my brain is gotta do
an actual game it's gonna be best of seven too yeah i'm
gonna go to sleep you gotta copy me whenever you can yeah
you know whenever
Yay!
Hey, there's a...
There's a Kingsman on cart.
Magic guy on the cart.
Yeah, he's gone.
There we go.
So they can't call us sweaty.
We went awful first.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So they can...
Whoa!
Insane!
Huge!
Alright, I have a Deadpool on me.
He's one.
all right
look at me look at me like oh oh no strange nope it's a
pretty far
you can probably TP I can tell it for a minute all right
who's TPing I'm trying I'm still we are stalling the oh
there you go we're TPing you got this you got this we're
TPing oh my god go go go go go go go beautiful TP
just getting absolutely beat all right oh there's Gavin
never folds again hey guys I think I I think I want bring
back bans i think i see i want to first ban gambit real
quick time to switch things up including which side you're
on oh my god not that bad no okay i'm done yeah yeah you're
like no fun is allowed yeah yeah no fun is allowed bro We
don't even win anything I'm doing this for free
I'm doing this for free I swear to god if the other players
in this show magic is getting paid the fucking be here I
swear to fuck you god I'm sweating my ass off for free right
now
J3 was like, do you want to do it?
And I was like, you know what?
Oh, sure.
I'll do it.
I'll join your show match.
I swear to fuck you guys.
If the other guys are getting paid.
Find out in seven seconds.
Are you doing a portal?
I'm not going for the pool yet.
I believe.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Did you get it?
Didn't work.
Oh.
It sounded good.
Do you have one?
I think right.
Oh.
Moxie on Hawk, I guess.
Oh, I'm dead.
Yeah.
I might be a mad situation soon.
And triple support, maybe.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Got no I don't think they I don't think they got the memo.
I don't think they got the memo Wait, wait, wait, wait,
let's get a TP going.
Make them win.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah No TP.
Oh, wait.
Oh, oh, I can't they Oh, none of us went strange I'm dead
just Not always in the right direction You need to stop that
vehicle you stress
All right, here we go.
Rich just keep getting richer.
Some things never change.
He's outside, he's one.
I'm backing up from that.
He's armed.
He's half.
He's low.
He's not half anymore.
I lied.
Yeah, I tell.
I can tell.
No, yeah.
He's getting abused by this.
Is Hawkeye still alive or dead?
I don't know, actually.
I have a dead pool behind me, by the way.
Dead pool behind me, dead behind me, look behind, look
behind, look behind.
Alright, yeah, yeah.
He's what?
He's actually what?
Clats, you good?
Yeah, I turned the corner at like 100 HP to a Hawkeye.
I thought it was over.
I have both here.
Are we all here?
Alright, let's go.
We're only getting the shot.
Go to Hawkeye.
on the back line yeah there's a magic behind us but oh i
quit you got you're in the bubble absolutely and i mean did
you enjoy it welcome to the support life in this meta now
this is the meta
Nice.
No.
I need a little Hughes.
Here.
There you go.
Yeah, but Hawkeye is just staring.
He's right over here.
Hey, uh, Doki, get his meals up here.
Oh, right.
Oh, nice.
Yay.
Bye, Hawkeye.
Hawkeye dead.
Let's go.
I don't think we need to use anything, right?
Okay, we do.
We do.
Copy me.
we definitely need it wait magic one magic one I'm lucky
dead pull low got you dead pull one dead pull one thanks you
pocket each other Hawkeye's looking at us I'm here with you
just the boost all right oh my god I see that emo oh how can
i own cart by the way he's on side he's anti but there's
nothing i can really do right
now yeah it never falls guys i'm running i'm sorry i'm
running oh when's that guy gonna start folding i don't think
they know yeah i don't think they know i'm right behind and
we're gonna whatever ready to go in oh nice nice i got the
bow guy i got the bow guy can we get card can we get card
oh oh that was a waste that was a battle oh nice like bro
look at me look at me look at me uh we yeah we're on there
ain't nobody stealing gambit's chance to win
I can yeah build this
Oh wait I'll wait until we're all here I can't do anything
Oh you guys are all by yourself by the way We can't even
heal you The building just fell on my head You can still go
Alright let's go then
That's a spidey phrase It's oldest time now Don't worry I
just come back fast Back fast and back fast Why is Booger in
our spawn?
He's been doing that the entire time Thanking us.
So technically they don't have a front line if you think
about it.
There's nothing I got.
I got all this fine.
We have the full wave.
I didn't just die on kite.
There ain't nobody stealing Gambit's chance to win.
Oh, we have another Gambit all soon.
Oh, guys.
Oh, close.
Yeah, I'll let you heal.
I'll let you heal.
to try and do damage.
He is low.
He didn't copy me.
He's 94.
I'm trying to stay alive for you.
I can't have it.
Here.
Gambit low.
Gambit's so low.
I'm lucky.
It was so low.
I got all guy.
He's bad.
He got the wrong gambit.
Okay, listen.
I'm going to pull her out.
You got to look at me.
We have no supports.
Sorry, I can stall the point guys.
It's like, my God, I think we actually have to go triple
support.
We have to touch point, touch point, touch point.
Okay, that's all we got.
That's all we got.
Final score.
It's a good game.
Wow.
You need triple support to win against triple.
And also mag because of...
Nox, they give it a rating.
Thank you.
Oh, I have a good stream.
Oh!
I'm just in a show match, by the way.
In a show match.
Okay, okay.
What map are you trying to do?
Stop pushing.
The off.
I don't trust them.
I don't trust.
All of their players are playing their main role.
I no longer.
trust my trust has been broken right they literally went
full they all playing their maze they're all playing their
maze hell's aving you know what we could take it hell's
aving i'm down do it there's no money in this we're just
showing you know what winning is fun you know what i i'll
agree winning winning might be fun
winning is very fun I'm gonna say are I were you ready?
yeah I'm ready yeah I'm good I'm good
it's for the love of the game they're doing it for the love
of the game I don't think they're off rolling bro that game
was supposed to be our off-rode game and they did an
off-rode like we all of us literally went off-rode for it
too because we thought it would be fun and then they went in
with their full fucking mains
no we said this game it's a third match and then we said
this game no we said this game
after in chat but in chat after we're like this game we
offer like during this screen Lynn, I'm not judging I'm
saying we gotta win alright I'll do whatever it takes it's
time even if that's triple support look they didn't respect
us yeah I can play Loki I'm fine with any support oh okay um
maybe you stay on Okay
Or like sewer but no, we got to be medicine Yeah, I actually
like that pick that character's working better better be a
rocket than if it was no is even better What's that This
right here.
Is it Jeff?
Oh, yeah, you got it you think you got it like that Oh,
damn!
Isn't this a good Jeff map?
It is, it is a good Jeff map.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is really a Jeff map.
Alright.
Four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Gambit never folds.
I crossed a galaxy for this.
You gotta be kidding me.
Careful of Hawkeye.
King's man is one.
He's actually one.
King's man is running.
You're in the bubble?
Got you.
Bomb one.
Are you okay?
Moxie has no cooldowns.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Really?
We got a magic in our spawn?
That's nice.
We're even, we're even.
We are missing one support though.
Oh, no.
Oh, I'm feeling.
Looky dead.
Winnable.
It is, but I do have a Deadpool on me, so...
Super winnable.
Me and you, me and you.
Wait, get me one, get me one, get me one, get me one.
They're coming over.
We're all here, we're all here.
Just live.
I almost have a hug.
Hawk guy, Hawk guy, Hawk guy.
He's kite, kite.
Oh my goodness, crazy.
I have also.
Oh, that's my goat right now.
Wait, get a devil, devil, devil, devil, devil, devil, devil.
Friends.
Beautiful.
Yeah, Craig, you always thought you were the better at it,
too.
Always thought that.
Oh, damn.
Yeah, yeah, without you, you wouldn't have got to turn any.
That's true.
Yeah.
I got Jeff all right I'll go first get to me get to me yeah
there's some magic on port but that's okay she's doing
nothing he's doing nothing on you he's just he's just an
accessory he's tickling me and I don't like it we can kill
him actually Oh, never mind Just gone.
Oh shit.
That was a hot guy You didn't copy me copy me copy copy copy
copy copy copy copy
I got Kill the old oh, we did wait, she didn't pop it.
Yeah, yeah
I got Nice.
Yeah, we we popped through all my god.
I'm so sorry.
I was too sorry Oh, that's a embarrassing car.
Uh, Deadpool's in our backline, like near our spawn.
Alright, don't worry.
I hear him flying.
Oh.
Okay, that's okay, that's okay.
Damn it, never falls.
You can eat, yeah, yeah, I was gonna say.
Just eat.
That's good, that's good, that's huge, that's huge.
I'm trying to help you.
I tried to spit him out.
It's alright, it's alright.
Oh, it's...
It's...
Reset time.
It's reset time.
Okay.
Just back up, back up, back up.
I'm so dead.
That was it.
I saw that.
All right.
You spray me?
I need a little bit of heal.
They're all anti-lock to the left.
Careful, Craigie.
Magic behind.
Oh, I didn't realize you were...
We gotta back up.
We lost two.
I have ult soon, though.
Yeah, we can go in the game between.
Yeah.
I can't really peek the...
I'm gonna do it real quick?
I'm gonna get you.
Oh.
the hawk guy careful the hawk guy hawk guy is literally look
oh yeah yeah that's that's why i'm not peeking i have a gap
no no don't don't think don't peek don't peek don't peek
because i got so lulted i'm just gonna back up look at that
look at that i don't know why he's doing that there is a
dead point on our point by the way that we can sort of kill
There you go.
Let's go.
I can go with this.
Are you guys ready?
Can we go?
Just walk.
I dealt that for you.
Oh my gosh.
There you go.
Nice.
Hey, why can't I take a photo?
There's no way.
I'm not peeking this way.
That's it.
I'm going back with my old.
That pool?
That pool, that pool, that pool, that pool, that pool is
one.
He's low, he's low.
Thank you.
Are they porting?
Are they already TPing?
Are they TPing, James?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They got it, they got the TP, they got the TP.
They got the TP.
You didn't eat it, BK.
He got three, he got three, he got three!
Oh!
They killed me.
Do we have TP?
I'm on it.
I think we did.
I can touch.
I can touch for a bit.
I think it might need rocket or club or maybe rocket.
We can win.
We need third portal.
We just can't.
We just can't pick because we don't have a shield.
We just can't peek because we don't have a shield.
We don't technically don't have a shield tank.
Gambit got more than one ace up his sleeve.
Can't win.
That's true.
That best way.
We do have Rocket, though, so it's easier to heal.
I can go Groot.
I hate this.
I hate this because we can't peek.
They can peek.
I think if I just get on him and stick to him, he'll just...
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Just wall him off.
Can't shoot anybody.
That'll work.
Nah, I like the Thorpec.
I like the Thorpec.
It's because of the dance.
Is it?
Is it because of the dance?
This one's the match.
I want to, like, dance, buddy.
I got this, though.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
You got it?
I should have asked for beds.
See, even in the third game, he didn't do off-roll, guys.
He was just getting a lot.
Careful, Hawkeye.
Go on the right side.
We don't really have anything for that.
I'm just going back up.
I'm kiting out.
We have a looking copy.
Yeah, I'm just dead.
We just, we got it too late, though.
Man, I'm still on the point.
They captured the mission area.
We can copy here.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, Loki's not here.
Look, Loki's not here.
I'm coming.
All got close.
I'll go close.
I'm waiting for your Loki.
Thank you so much.
I really appreciate that.
No.
Oh.
Oh, I just got him.
Getting ganked in the back.
I don't...
Oh, it was too far.
It was too far.
He's on stretch.
I also have an alt, too, by the way.
Oh,
I see.
I didn't alt.
Alt and the booger.
I'm alt and the booger.
Nice, nice.
They're TP'd.
I feel like I'm playing an actual tournament right now at
this.
Dude, we win this or no?
Do we win this or no?
Did no one tell you that this is actually tournament part
two?
Yeah, I'm like, I'm...
They actually team beat!
Oh, you look so weird.
Oh, there you go.
It's fine, we all have it, we all- You can use it, we can
use it.
Yeah, I gave it to everyone, I gave it to everyone.
I made sure.
Like, what are these tournaments, fucking strats?
Man, I literally just played Bougar Bash, man.
Oh, how is that?
Oh, we got a third.
And we literally, they did the same fucking strats as this.
Oh.
Oh, look, look, look, look, look, look.
we just we just regroup we regroup and we make we have tp in
click is dead guys we tp we tp for sure right no no no no no
no okay all right i can i i gotta i gotta stay on this okay
for the rules Yeah.
He's dead.
Do we have touch?
I got it.
Okay.
There you go.
Gavin never falls!
We got TP?
I'm spawning.
You have rocks.
Flurry all the as soon as you can.
Keep my flats up.
All right.
Let's go.
Oh no.
Why would anyone want to be?
One of them.
There's a swarm in here.
You still have your real game later, but for real money!
I'm all warmed up now!
Yo, this guy's warm.
Someone swapped a gambit.
Someone who can play gambit.
I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead.
I need help here.
Oh, it's 599.
We have res.
Holy infinite star.
ready for gambit never dies soon there we go I need a gambit
to copy I couldn't I couldn't get it we didn't have to find
a gambit we didn't have a gambit
Yeah, we saw it for a while.
Damn.
Guys, I think we should have had bans, guys.
I think it was a little foolish of us to say no bans.
I'm not going to say it.
I was going to say it.
No honor.
I don't think the vibes were in.
guys i just think we did we didn't have a low key or yeah
like i was the only low key or gambit player well ggs was
fun good luck for the real tournament games all right good
luck with the real turn of ggs bye-bye well i think like our
team was definitely the vibe team because we were play for
fun characters so obviously we gave a lot of like points to
them we gave a lot of like actual we gave them a lot of
space and distance because we're fucking around every time
we start with fucking around and then and then because of
they all were on their main so obviously yeah yeah and we
were we never portaled we never we the fight the first time
we portal oh yeah you got me the first time we portal was
the last the very last game yeah
insane sweat i mean they started out with triple i knew they
were gonna start out with triple support first yeah yeah it
was it is what it is i wanted us to try hard but like
everyone everyone wanted they wanted to have fun they wanted
to play like random characters and uh and then it was like i
don't guys i don't think they're respecting that guys i i
don't think and in our team i think like only me only i knew
loki and gambit because um only i knew loki and gambit
because like um i had to play loki or i have to play gambit
for us there it sucked because i had all like i had no
gambit to copy i was just like where's the gambit like where
is yeah they started by being on spider-man kingsman and
moxie kingsman was on magic we were like we were like all
right kingsman not on magic yeah and then they were on
triple support too we were on dual support and then on the
second game we were like off roll we will do off roll
we were like off roll on second game and then they didn't go
off roll and we went off roll second game and then third
game because you guys said boker thought it was going to be
third game off roll off roll third game so weird so it was
just like it just felt like i just i was just all over the
place my brain is just too tired my brain was way my brain
was way too tired to do triple support
I was like, they're portaling.
I was just like, really?
They're actually fucking portaling.
Like, they're doing tournament strats.
Yeah.
No, that's why I was like, bro, you gotta play triple
support.
They're not gonna respect you, man.
They're not gonna respect the 1v1.
You gotta rip it.
Like, they already broke the rule.
I was like, I swear to God, if anyone was getting paid to be
in the show match, swear to god i i i got here for i was
here i did this for free i i was
like i had
to try my Raid, Malaya, thank you.
Oh my god, I'm tired.
Sunday was...
I think to improve this, if it was done again, if this was
done again, I think they should have more rules for the show
match.
Like, to be more, I guess, more enforcement.
on what it was gonna be.
Yeah, actual silly rules instead of just Deadpool only
because people were not on the same page.
I think like both teams with the players were not on the
same page.
And I felt really bad for Flats.
I felt really bad for Flats only because like he had to do a
real turn.
Like his, you know, he thought it was to be for like for fun
where he gets to relax in between game um where he was gonna
relax in between games but then he had to think and actually
try really hard um in in the show match or we were gonna
just get like absolutely rolled yeah we were gonna get
absolutely rolled all of us did not try like no he's been
he's been on on for like four like what five plus hours yeah
well to be fair i had a feeling it was going to be triple
support because technically both our teams are triple
support we have three support players on both teams So it
was like, it was like an inside job.
I, I, yeah, it was like an inside job because, because both
teams have only like, like technically peer support players.
It's like, so like J3 planted three supports on each team.
Like literally planted three supports on each team.
So it was like, unless like one of the support off rolls,
all the, the three players there, all, play support yeah
yeah yes i'm literally sweating for free and i i don't like
complaining but like i feel bad complaining but i'm so tired
like my team my team's energy was so like i i my team's
energy was so fucking dead like i know you guys noticed it I
don't know if you guys noticed it, but I felt like my entire
team was so fucking dead.
Like, because we had to, my, we had to try so hard.
Yeah.
I had to speed.
I had, oh my god.
Well, it's because, like, Flats.
Well, it was just Flats, but Flats was in, it's still in the
tournament.
Yeah.
i think like if it was a show match it definitely should
have there should have been like funny rules or something
and like because we were not on the same page we were i
thought no bands as in like we get to fuck around we get to
we got we get to fuck around more with like team comps and
stuff more so like oh off-roll stuff blah blah and
everything but play triple and then as i was like guys we
gotta pull up triple support we're never gonna win we're
never gonna win the alt rotation and we didn't have a mag
player our mag player was stuck on Deadpool duty
like flats was our is is the mag player but like cranky
technically could go mag but like he was doing so much on
thor so we literally had no shield tank for a hot guy and
that's just ggs that's why i was like guys can we please
have him back the supports are not having fun yeah because
like the front line doesn't know how not fun we were having
because we literally cannot peek yeah because i was like
guys please i really need a shield tank like the supports
back here are not having fun with the positioning because i
know like i think like malaya and lulu were not used to
playing against a really good hawk at but i'm used to
playing against a really good hot guy and like literally
literally when that's why I was like guys don't peek don't
peek and you can tell and you can tell like I didn't like
you know they were they were like careful like like you know
they didn't have to live through the life I had to live
through so you know what I'm saying they didn't have to live
through the life I had to live through playing against those
types of hot guys um so they're like what do you mean you
know because they assume the hot guy doesn't their shots but
it's moxie so i knew like i'm not fucking peaking that and
they they still have their whimsy and their joy and they
don't know that if they peak uh they were just gonna die
instantly you know i was playing super careful and then like
when i see like um i see like lulu and Milaya's like, guys,
please don't look out and just stay where you are.
We don't have a shield.
I was literally playing the fucking most cautious game ever
because we had no shield.
It was like the scariest shit when you don't have a fucking
shield tank against a fucking Hawkeye.
It was so scary.
To be thinking for the twitch prime thank you think i fell
for it again why does this keep happening i just realized i
fell for it again i just promised this was a fun show match
wait gavin never falls i fell every time
Were they at least having fun try-harding against us?
Who did the enemy team at least?
Because I don't think my team had fun.
I don't think...
Did they have fun winning?
Oh my god.
And then they were like, yeah, you're running Gambit Loki.
You're running triple support!
I hope they have- I hope they had a lot of fun winning.
I'm so tired right now.
There's just no winning.
Like, they're like, yes, we ran Gambit Loki, but we also
went double support.
but because it's triple support is still stronger it's still
worse than gambit loki
yeah yeah but we had they we had like like we also have weak
players too we also have weak players as well and we had to
go against dive we had to go against magic dive as well And
magic dive against weaker players is not it's not fun too
like we have to also because like they have a dive character
We have a dive character, but we went double support Yeah,
we went double support we didn't run triple So it's like we
should have went I I I I should not have said no bands.
I should have said bands
Yeah.
I don't know why.
I thought we could have a fun, I thought we could have fun
ha ha moments.
I really did.
Moments before disaster.
No demands!
There was no honor code.
There really wasn't an honor code at all.
My faith in humanity, I lost my trust.
Oh, I hope people watching had fun watching.
It felt like watching a real game.
Let's lose Celestial 2.
I might as well.
I'm tired.
Let's just go in and lose Celestial 2 while we're at it.
I hope the viewers had fun.
I'm bad in Gambit first no matter what.
I do not want to play Gambit right now.
too tired for Gambit.
I'm way too tired.
Here we go.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Oh my Oh
yeah, the trailer.
I'm banning Gambit.
There's no way.
I swear to God.
I'm so fucking done that I'm banning Gambit.
it first what about the announcement after this game i need
to do a palette cleanser i really need to do a palette
cleanser all
right loki as well i'm already bad yeah but you guys looking
whatever i swear to god no one bans any okay i'm banning
loki i don't care no no lamps nobody's banning i wanted in
the band and it was gambit and after that i was like i don't
care what you do just go wild you know what i want to play
after playing gambit after fucking gambit never falls
all right oh my god oh my god
Yeah, I'm but truly never for it.
Maybe this was an inside job by J3.
Weakened Flats before his final game.
Make him weaker.
It's an...
it's an inside job he planted three supports on both teams
said no bad agreed to no fans and then fucking destroyed
flats mental I swear it's an it's an inside job is it why
would he do that to him why I'm tired after that I did one
game and i'm tired after that one match if we lose as we
know why i'm exhausted after running gavin never falls and
triple support
okay our only tank is a fucking betty you know what this i
just i deserve to lose that game I'll never know what it's
like to have a shield tank.
Many on attack and he's our only tank.
Don't forget that.
Oh, man.
There we go.
I don't think we're gonna...
This does not look winnable.
See, this is the team I had versus the team they had.
This is...
literally what it was like for us.
This is literally what it was like.
Are they gonna be okay?
No.
This is literally, this was, this was literally how the show
match was like, guys.
Literally actually how the show match.
Their team has like a real cap and then And my team is Penny
on attack.
Oh my god.
We're doing it.
Oh.
I deserve that.
Oh my god.
And they wasted Poirot!
Oh.
Let's fucking go.
I deserve this.
It capped the point, though.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god, please let me through.
I'm just a little rodent.
Just a humble little rat.
If it worked, it worked.
Oh, goodbye, Venom.
It's so loud.
We have invis.
This is literally the Wild West right now.
Yeah.
I am good.
Shields up!
What's going on?
Oh.
Is he fine?
He'll be fine.
That is stereo.
That takes care of Namor.
Yeah, solo tank is bulk.
You see, you can never reason with a one trick.
Does this work?
Oh, it does.
There's no reason when it comes to one tricking.
There's only a...
No other character exists for them.
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Where did he come from?
Oh my god, that freak!
Go back to your team!
Oh shit, is that karma?
Oh shit, karma, that's real?
Karma's actually real?
Oh man, I'm just gonna reset.
Fuck that is what I learned.
What are you going to do when we just all run away?
Honestly, what can you do?
Catch it!
Alright, here we go.
I got this.
Okay, I...
I thought there'd be more people up front, but I did not.
I don't know.
I used it for our bucket but I thought there would be more
people up.
I did not realize they backed up that much.
All right, we have Invis up.
No, no, no, no.
We won the fight.
Guys, we...
We won the fight, guys.
Oh, that was a good...
Oh, never mind.
I was gonna say that was a good-ass bubble, but...
They really didn't do anything much from it.
Holy shit.
Don't worry We do have oh nice the neutral fight.
We're winning the neutral fight.
Oh never mind they res they res
I hope our cloak our invents would be okay I actually said
cloak No
Why am I always so greedy it was one i'm always so greedy i
just won that one kill it was just so juicy
that's fine it's gonna be fine hey guys we should win this
neutral but unless you want to win via us all right here you
go oh don't worry he gets res i have all i have all here
ready we're gonna do this together all right there are you
and me you and me the moment you hit that up i'm all with
you you and me okay bro all right i can't help you for it i
i was waiting You use it now.
I said you and me.
And yet he...
I was waiting for that.
Any...
Anything now.
You and me.
Alright, I'll just use them.
I'm just gonna chuck it.
Yeah, no.
But if I chuck it, whatever he's like.
Guys, can we...
Okay.
going up oh my god this is bad I'm on it I'm actually on it
wait why is she on it okay in the end it wasn't you and me
we were not on the same page we were on I'm not on the same
page.
Surprised you had Bucky for so a lot?
Oh, buddy.
I don't think anyone cares no more.
I don't think anyone cares.
She gave up.
No, you know who that mag was?
Our mag was our other support.
That was our mag.
That was our...
Now what do we do?
Guys, if anything, we do not want...
We do not want...
Hey, only I can talk to my stream.
You talk to me.
That's my chat.
Get out of here.
or I block you.
That's right.
That's my chat.
Damn right.
Now also throw the...
No, don't actually throw the game.
Now let me win the game.
But also don't do it because I don't get reported for
colluding.
I don't...
Yeah, yeah.
That's my chat.
Oh yeah, you're stream sniping that's reportable you should
you're supposed to say hi after the game is done
yes do not show the game because i don't want to get in
trouble all right oh yeah we lose you get bad
all right here we go wait our mvp is now not on that is not
good our ace is hard our support now but hey at least we
have oh that's not good it's actually not good we have
anything wait we do we do we're gonna have another thing too
it's okay I wanted to be here oh my god come on i literally
need life just a tiny bit more okay i got it all right no
worries i've got your back yeah i've been never fooled there
we go i can put my res somewhere else too i'll put the res
in where i like to put it Put it here.
This is more safe.
Wait, who made that hole?
Theoretically, it is a more safe hole, but like, it is a
more safe spot, but also who made that hole over there?
All right, so my all my dead soon.
Oh my god, it reconstructed.
There you go.
area i'm gonna let my my invis heal and then maybe i'll let
i'll save her a hell a little bit but i need my invis to get
up all right she should get it here i can start healing now
i can get now it's my turn there's no way to see me up here
right what what what no okay god we won the fight i was It's
just like, I was like, oh, no, they have a Groot on.
Why did you all, they have a Groot on?
Buddy.
Oh no, our Benny.
What are we gonna do?
Oh no, he's looking for it.
They're looking for it.
Oh, good spot.
but you're welcome down to 30 seconds hey guys boy oh boy
why what our penny
the penny ran off the point bro shut the fuck up that our
penny ran off the point
I hope you get our penny player.
I hope you get our penny player next game.
If you're watching, if your stream snip.
I hope you get all my teammates on your team.
Next game.
Curse you.
I fucking curse your game.
That's right.
Disappear.
Hmm.
This is real fire.
Where is my team?
My curse of Doki.
Right here.
Elo curse.
That's right.
I hope you get all the curses.
Our penny.
I swear to God, our penny is.
This guy's fucked up because our penny decided to play for
his life like if our penny didn't play for his life we would
win this hit it again again
again that actually is crazy no way Penny is the sleeper
agent.
There is no way.
What the fuck?
Oh, that is unfortunate.
Well, at least he gets a second chance.
Do we kill the...
The name more, apparently?
That's there as well?
I will be up front.
I personally don't know.
like it when um people chat in the middle of games like that
only because it it's just like you know there's just stream
sniping as the game is going on because that just makes it
more obvious i will say that it's fine if they do it like
after the game but for me it's like bro that's pretty
obvious you're watching this yeah yeah i'll pat you on me
it's just more so of like oh my god the fight was over the
fucking fight was over that's my bad i wasn't paying
attention i wasn't paying that that's on me that's on me
that's on me sorry i didn't even realize That was on me.
That was the one thing I fucking did wrong.
The one thing I did wrong out of the entire game.
That was going to cost us a lot.
It's not like, you know.
My entire team was like fucking around too.
Was like playing the fucking game of their lives here as
well.
Yeah, not shifting it to me when like...
Not shifting it to me after like the entire game.
People were like, people were like fucking going off and
everything.
Well, it's just like, yeah, yeah, not like Penny running,
running off.
Not like Penny running off, like, the point two times in a
row.
And then they're like, oh, Rocket fucked up that up.
And not like we just watch multiple DPS players.
And also we were only taking.
we were only doing that we were frontline only penny tank
but oh i fuck up that else that's because i was talking
about stream etiquette i'm just doing something real quick
that had to
uh uh but it was just more so stream etiquette it's just um
it's it's it's just weird to like like check the stream mid
game and then making it known that you are because it is
technically stream sniping and like it's just a little weird
for me for that for that so it's just more so like i'm okay
if people are doing like after the game is like after the
game is over but sort of like making it known you're like
looking at the stream while the game is like happening at
the same time
me distracted because I was just like yeah like I don't like
obviously people will stream snip but it's like it's a
little it got a little awkward because it was like it got
really awkward yeah but it's through more so like you can
also see like the hero comps you see the hero comps what
we're playing and everything too um since we are running
defense as well so it's like I know like you were not stream
sniping but i was just saying like stream etiquette i would
prefer if like because it is like other people could also
report that as well because it's like considered like
against um it's like sort of like against like like it's
like not like a thing so it's more so like it was like a
general overall you see me in game you do see me game um
just say like you know if you're on the enemy team it's more
so like at the end of the game yeah because other people
could also report as well because I obviously I know like
you don't have any intentions for that but it's just more so
like a general overall thing for everybody because it's
considered like bad etiquette in terms of like when you're
playing a competitive game it's why like Valorant players
right now Valorant players they all put um um it's also like
don't don't valentine players they have to play on streamer
mode now they i mean they have to play it with delay on and
map overlay and everything they a lot of like like
competitive valentine players they play with stream delay on
because even they're like oh i want to like you know pull up
recognize like pull up stream and stuff like that like for
them it's more so like you know they get like super paranoid
and stuff like that um for me yeah i do play this And it is,
like, reportable in Valorant as well.
Type deal.
It is reportable in Valorant.
Yeah.
And also, I have, like, trauma from Apex as well, because I
got StreamSnipe.
I got StreamSnipe a lot for Rankin Apex.
Like, cheaters.
Apparently, if you guys didn't remember, um...
If you guys didn't remember, uh...
When we did our Predigran in Apex, I was told by my friends,
like when the people I was queuing with at that time, and we
kept dying, not like, when we kept getting chased by hacker
squads, we were apparently being streamed tonight by several
hacker squads to prevent us from ranking up.
Because I was streaming those games.
I was apparently being, yeah, they like, afterwards, like,
they had to report to, like, yay about it um and like
obviously they had they got banned after my stream but like
we i was getting the stream sniped non-stop by hacker squads
during apex grinds oh yeah sorry i queued up another one i
want my celestia too back and or i derank yeah there were
like two to three i remember because i was like really
pissed off about it um i was really mad about it because I
was just like, what the fuck?
All right, one more.
One more.
I promise this is one more.
I was throwing off my vibe.
You always, I promise this is one more.
For real.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this.
I don't know, I guess, oh shit, I tapped him.
I didn't realize I was tabbed up.
I don't know what I mean.
I don't want to play.
I don't think it's as horrible.
I agree.
Our pun, I'm sure.
He said Loki.
Um.
Dude, you think Puma tier one's up?
Thank you.
Oh, I'm reporting you for that.
What is that?
But yeah, like, that's why it's like, that's why for me,
it's like, it's just awkward when, like, better and better.
Because if it's on my team, that's fine.
That's fine, like, cause you know, you see what I see.
If you're on my team and you're in my game, you see what I
see.
If you're on the enemy team and you make it known you're
watching the stream, I'm like, that's weird.
That's weird.
Because I know, yeah, in my game, you know, other people
would do, like, oh, man, God, abandoning.
Like, what's the point of having streamer mode?
We should just surrender, bro.
We have this Punisher.
We're not waiting.
The battle starts in five.
Four, three, two, one.
Blood your head's a lot.
I'm bruised.
Angles grounded.
I pushed her down.
Grotted.
All right.
That's right, blood.
Oh, my God.
Hey, guys.
I'm, i would really like it if you all if you can all you
know i mean shoot the walls oh it's all right we don't need
that all right kill this dude i'm body blocking he's
grounded oh my god please there we have to kill okay i was
gonna say i swear to god we don't kill him i need healing i
need healing i need healing who's he who's who's he i this
is the first time i've heard all of your
I need healing who is he I've never met any of you guys
before in my life
I don't know who all you guys are
oh shit that's awkward for him oh fuck I'm so bad Yeah!
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh, goodbye.
Oh, hello!
There we go.
It's too bad.
You got it.
We can pull me off the map, bro.
I don't know about you.
I'm dead, bro.
Bro, he can't pull anybody off.
I just realized he can't pull anyone.
It's okay.
I can get hot ground.
Oh my god.
The moment I used my faith for this.
I Used my faith for this Okay
If you ever want to copy I'm right here if you ever want to
copy I'm right here I've lined it No, oh Oh, it's fine.
We'll be fine, right?
We'll be so fine.
Oh, no.
Not him, though.
Not him.
I'm just healing.
I have to heal you.
I would love to heal you.
Oh, my God.
I would love to.
Oh No There you go Oh, she's coming for me.
Oh my All right Oh, no My god It's fine All right, it's fine
It's not really, but it's not really.
It's not.
It's in,
we get off triple tank and we play things.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I'm not.
All right, we're off triple tank at least.
Yeah, you were.
I was playing mag for you, but it wasn't working when they
swapped.
They went.
All right, here we go.
Oh, fuck.
I'm going to win that.
Oh, hey, nice.
yeah come on yeah double blind whoa he's dead wait how did
he die but how did he die oh wait is he okay he's gonna be
okay right he's gonna
I'm right here.
Whenever you're ready, I'm right here.
Oh, shit.
Okay, let me give you some.
What's up, man?
Oh, God.
I got reloaded.
I got it.
I'm right here.
I'm...
I'm still right here.
If you ever, you know, feel a little quirky.
Okay.
okay it'll be very awkward if I went all did and then he
copied me so let's hope that doesn't happen I only look back
when I have oh guys um what happened no one wanted to go to
my alt my alt was pretty neat i don't know i my alt was
pretty neat i dead ass just got angela solo wait did it
double support up nice i was gonna say like what happened oh
no guys i'm right here i'm right here i'm right here i'm
right here i'm right here this is it this is your moment i
told you i'd be right Right here!
I told you!
Oh, that alt did nothing.
Wait, what's the point of that?
Oh, wait, actually.
I'm dead, bro.
I'm so dead.
There's nobody here.
Wait, what was the point of that?
Oh, shit.
Good luck.
Guys, I'm no longer here.
Wait, nobody.
I'm really confused, buddy.
Not getting healed, bro.
With you.
We're throwing the berries for some reason.
We're just throwing berries.
Ain't that funny?
Okay, I had a...
I don't know.
I think me and him, we're doing the gods work right now.
I'm playing this perfectly.
I think I'm playing this fucking perfectly right now.
I don't know.
Oh, God.
Bro, that torch is, like, very annoying, too.
Oh, I...
Well...
What do you mean?
Me...
me and us, we're doing fine.
Alright, now we back up.
Oh, now we're a bit too deep.
Oh!
Shit!
Okay!
I thought my, you know, my ult was not like that, though.
You know, Arloki fucked up there.
That wasn't on me.
That...
I need you to know that Arloki messed up there, not me.
Arloki did that not me all right look either that not me
though
what do you mean zero why were both of our takes off a site
guys i'm driving the back line i don't know what angela's
doing why are you not stalling i could have i had my old
yeah i don't know you'll
Me though.
I want to see if I can just maximize damage.
If you don't mind.
Mantis, you said?
No, I don't feed it.
Just remember, not me.
I was innocent.
It's winnable.
We just need our tanks to get a grip.
Round two.
Go.
I'm joking.
did nothing right no he really did nothing right i'm gonna
worry let's fuck this i want to tab in and out 30 seconds
before you attack get ready i don't know about triple
support concerning like we won't really have about space
facility with mantis anymore she's not not a dps player the
phoenix is a dps player and she said like her main rule
she's Okay.
All right, I got a list of something.
I was like, keep looking up.
I got a work message to have to look at.
All right, here we go.
Oh my god, I hear a hawk.
I know what that means.
You know what that means.
You know what that means?
I heard a hawk guy.
I got him!
I got him.
I don't know how.
But I got him.
Oh, goodbye, Mag.
You're alone up there.
Holy shit.
I hear a side lock.
out of it.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm being avoidable.
I think that we can't use her still hitting hard.
We can't use her still hitting hard.
We'll never know.
Oh, how did they get to...
I was able to build her.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh.
It's okay.
I have my altitude.
Here we go.
Let's go.
It's my turn.
There we go.
There.
I baited the second up.
You're welcome.
I knew you were going to do that.
Oh, I didn't know about that, though.
Oh my god, come on.
Now see, now we have Luna up.
Oh my god, he was one My letter build up I got bubble just
in case
What where's my orb?
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
We You know, I thought I thought I could live that but
apparently I was wrong Good.
I killed three!
Tomboy rose one thing, what do you blame?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Not me!
Not blame for anything!
There we go.
Not being blamed!
care if i'm worried about pushing the card team i got him i
got him don't worry yay not my fault not my fault
that's why we're falling
jesus christ look it was like me guess you like the diamond
where is that oh is he is he okay the aww I didn't say oh my
god you got solo of this I didn't say what happened who
where's that all from yeah look oh that's awkward
I'm not getting fucking raped I hate this especially since
we're talking Not that good What is this?
Keep fucking wanting to throw this game so bad I think all
I've been doing is this I have not stopped left clicking I
have not stopped left clicking
But when I'm kidding Bro, okay, okay, that's not on me.
That's not on me.
Judge, jury, executioner!
Holy hell, bro.
How can you play fucking games if nobody wants to swap?
Oh, God.
Abba Frost into Angela.
All right, here we go.
Bro, I'm getting fucked on every other tank.
I don't think.
Well, our Wolverine can enable you.
I like I'm getting healed though
Hey, there's no way I'm I'm all I've been doing is Very,
very hard to kill Angela at Wolverine unless you're a god
Yeah, but my character can only fly with the air You're
can't do that the harder time doing that to me I'm breaking
it I'm not oh that's awkward that's that's awkward that's
awkward just have no nobody wants to swap for you going too
hard I mean you could have sucked with DPS with a gun and
enabled or Angela guys are you enjoying weekend queues right
now because I am I love weekend queues guys
I love weekend queues
What the fuck is going on?
At least we're having content right now.
Alright, let's see.
Oh man, 42k healing.
That's a lot of heals.
That's a lot.
It's crazy that the TTV here is like the most...
the loudest the loudest okay D-Cat, where are the heals?
I don't know.
Honestly maybe my team healing wasn't the best though.
I will admit, my team might have been struggling with
healing.
But not me.
No, it's because the other one was the one who played Loki
and then yeah Yeah, he swapped the art.
Now.
Oh, you're in the enemy club.
I hope you get one of my teammates.
I really do hope you get any of my teammates that was in my
team.
All right, now let me post a tweet now.
Anyone?
It was like, gee, geez, I was on the enemy team.
I hope you get any of my teammates.
all right a curse of turkey oh man i feel bad j3 was like
thank you for playing today and so you're in your team today
i hope you had fun oh man i'm not j3 i'm sorry i don't know
you heard if you heard our comms j3 it was not that it was
dead like
I don't think he knew.
I don't think he knew that my team did not enjoy your triple
support at all.
Yeah, unfortunately, my team did not enjoy that cop.
All right.
Let me get that tweet going.
on real quick but but but but but but but
all right i'm making my anniversary tweet right now i
remember what i did for uh for uh uh for last year because i
will make a similar tweet so give me a sir i'm gonna make my
tweet guys i'm gonna do it live tweeting
oh nice voice how many packs do you smoke a day i'm sick
right now i hope that makes you feel better i hope i hope
that makes you feel better
all right let me No, now he has to live with his words.
Now he has to live with it.
That's right.
That's when you realize, whoa.
Sometimes, sometimes people are sick.
That's right.
You shame the sick person right now.
That's like, right.
That's what you get for assuming.
Exactly.
Words have consequences.
Yeah, it's a Darmann moment.
This is a King Darmann.
That's right.
Bam, you got Darmann.
Tokey came out swimming.
Because I have to work on a Sunday.
I was told.
I was told it was a...
And I did it for free.
Don't you see?
This is...
This is unhinged.
No...
What's the word?
No holding back.
Sunday is my rest day.
And now I'm in too deep to stop streaming.
i'm in too deep no holds barred
what was that oh yeah yeah i gotta all right i'm making my
anniversary tweet i need to like find out how did i do this
um all right i'm just trying to find the tweet
what was my my hashtag was dokey day right
Doki there.
Yeah, not a lot.
I woke up coughing, though.
I woke up coughing.
What was...
Is it this?
Is that my hashtag?
Hey, thank you for gifting us up.
To mouse button remove.
Thank you.
Is it this?
Was this my hashtag?
Or was it something else?
No, no, I meant...
No, I meant the first one.
That was the first one, right?
Okay.
I'm fine.
It's not coming up.
Oh, there it is.
Never mind.
I have to capitalize it.
Oh, my God.
It's looking weird.
Okay.
I got it.
Alright.
What did I... How did I do this?
Oh, my God.
Alright.
What if I... Okay.
What was my birthday hashtag?
I just want to make sure my template is the same.
Um...
What was my...
What was my birthday hashtag?
Does anyone remember?
Was it birthday...
Doki...
Bird day.
Alright.
Let me check this hashtag.
I don't want to make it like similar to...
No, that's not it.
Uh, was it actually specifically...
Was that my birthday hashtag?
Okay.
Is the search thing broken?
Oh, I found it.
Jokey Bird Day.
I found it, guys.
Jokey Bird.
Alright.
Let's see.
And then.
2044.
What did I say here?
Alright.
Here we go.
Yeah.
Twitter is.
always been broken it is what it is um all
right all
right here yeah all right let me make my tweet it's tweet
time all right let me see you need to grab my video real
quick you're all doing it live
Live!
All right.
Downloaded the video.
And then...
Okay.
all right time no that's just me coughing my lungs out as
always um
oh where is it where the fuck is it i'm trying to like grab
one of my sponsor tweets because i have oh there you go
there's the clock February 7th February 7th uh is this
February 7th that Saturday Saturday all right February 7th
Saturday donkey day all right wait what Incompatible audio
codec?
What does that mean?
Incompatible audio codec?
Twitter.
What?
What does that mean?
Oh, no!
It won't let me upload on Twitter!
Okay, okay, I'm gonna ask...
Okay, I need to have the video re-exported.
Alright, I'm sending to my manager right now.
Guys, there might be a...
We're gonna figure this out.
I was like, what?
What do you mean incompatible?
Oh.
They are not awake.
My manager was like...
He was like, no, you're editing.
And I'm like, they're not awake.
last night I got I got the video last night and they're not
awake I'm sorry I hate to break it to you but we gotta
figure out how we gotta find someone else to do it
wait actually here I'll send the link to my manager here
here's the actual link this is incompatible
Yeah, but I can't...
Yeah, but we can...
We can ask an editor to re-re-export it properly.
Because I can't big tweet.
I don't know when they wake up.
Wait, can people... It's... Oh, they chat said it's easy
fix.
manager help
manager help get her video
wait a minute who was the person who was the person that
pulled up my stream in that first game sorry I just
remembered you said you had audio muted but you heard what I
mid game when we were on defense you heard me you liar you
fucking liar got you i got red-handed i just realized oh you
said you had me muted
were already positioned on defense and you heard me you saw
our cop wait a minute it only took me an hour to realize the
cop was that brother that is the cookie jar is already gone
it's like bro the cookie jar is gone guys that's the sadness
in that cookie jar he sold the entire cooking chat I just
realized it I I have the 2000 thing of brain I just realized
it thank you for giving a tier 1 sub it didn't lie cuz I
just clicked in my head I was just thinking about it and it
just clicked in my head I was like wait a minute because I
felt bad.
He's like, oh, I didn't mean to stream.
I wasn't stream sniping.
I swear I had the whole thing muted.
I'm like, wait a minute.
You responded to me.
I was like, that's my chat.
You don't get to talk to my chat.
You talk to me.
And then they're like, oh, sorry.
I apologize.
And they're like, sorry.
And I was like, that's right.
And I found out
Wait a minute.
Sorry, I got, we're waiting for...
Chat, can you hear me?
No, wait a minute.
She's so gullible.
I found 20 hours late.
I don't even think they're here anymore.
They're in their fucking next game.
I was in my wager you liar you got your back I finally
figured it out I finally realized
you you said you had me muted mid-game but you responded
back and I realized you lied and we all believed you I fell
for it again and then I realized you said you muted me and
then I remembered you responded to me mid game when I said
you don't get to talk to my chat you talk to me it's just
yes we all as a collective fell for it again we all fell for
it This is the fourth time you fell for it
That is the fourth The fourth time we all fell for it We all
did it
This always happened to me I I Who is this we?
We speak of.
Can't believe we're all so gullible.
All of us.
All 2,133 of us.
Oh my god.
When it happens.
All right.
They're converting it.
They're converting it, guys.
It's happening.
It's happening guys and I'll put the waiting room.
I should actually while I wait.
I should actually make the waiting room wait That's that's
yeah, wait a minute Wait a minute
Oh shit, I for I Don't even have the thumb I forgot to get
the file for the thumbnail
So on top of things I don't care you're so on top of things
I just realized they sent me the they're like here's what it
looks like I was like oh it looks perfect and then they're
like oh yeah what's the email for your invoice and I'll send
you the file and in my head I was like I I got the file now
I'll send you the HD file I told you Sunday is not my day
Sunday Sunday I'm so fried Sunday is not that day all right
here we go oh
my god I got the file
All right, I got the tweet, guys.
I got it.
All right.
I, okay, let me test.
Let me double check.
I think it looks, the quality looks the same.
I'm releasing my file.
All right, there we go.
The files are getting released, guys.
The Doki files.
All right, here goes.
Downloading.
All right.
It should work now.
We might not have a waiting room up because I forgot to...
I forgot to fucking grab the thumbnail.
But we got the trailer, though.
We got...
We got the trailer.
Okay.
All right, you guys ready?
Are you guys excited?
Okay, let me check if the time slots are correct, though.
Uh, yeah, that's the correct time.
Are you guys ready?
Alright.
Wait, incompatible audio codec?
Wait, no, oh no, it's fine.
It's fine.
It was a different one.
Wait, wait, let me...
JK, I baited you guys.
Give me a sec.
Let me refresh this.
I think it was from the old one.
It's from the old file.
I'm just double checking.
i'm double checking if it works okay this time sorry that
was just a bait
all right this time all right it's at 52 percent
what wait a minute um all right i'm worried about tweeting
this i'm worried i'm worried about tweeting this and then
you get no audio so so i do you think it's i'm gonna do you
think it's safe to tweet because that'd be awkward because
um i can't play the video since i can post it
wait all right give me a sec
let me try this out let me download it again maybe i maybe i
downloaded the wrong file i have done that before i'm gonna
i'm downloading all right i'm downloading the third the
third file and then and then let's see i'm uploading i'm
uploading it again.
I'm...
I don't think saving it as a draft does anything.
It still says incompatible audio codec, so I'm...
It says I can post it, but I don't know.
Alright.
It says...
No, it still says incompatible audio codec, and then I
asked...
Oh, he said wait.
I asked my manager.
Can I tweet this?
That's the that's the link he sent me unless he sent me the
wrong link.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna I'm sending okay.
Wait I think click it and see.
He uploads the wrong one I'm gonna slap him oh my god oh my
god he's gonna slap a staff member he uploaded the wrong
file all right we got the wrong dokey files guys we gotta
get grab the other dokey file no way it's his sunday to to
the dungeon he goes
It was like, he uploaded the wrong one.
I'm going to slap him.
All right.
I got the next file.
I got it.
All right.
Here we go.
Okay.
I got.
All right.
Now I got the right file.
This is something you have prepared days instead of live on
a random Sunday.
I was tired last night.
Okay.
I was so tired.
and then on Sunday I would have prepped all of this like
while I'm instead of doing it live I was already so tired
last night and then I would have done it all on Sunday while
I'm not live
I was so tired alright alright we're ready we're ready are
you guys ready yeah yeah so tired you have to doom queue
rivals until exactly nexi exactly i'm glad you understand
thank you for the 150s and thank you for the 150s nexi and
gordon all right all righty all right five four three two
one
Yeah!
Well, you're gonna have to look at the, well, I'm not
showing it on YouTube.
I want you to give me engagement on Twitter.
Like...
Sorry, on Twitch.
But I'm not gonna show it on Twitch.
I want you guys to click on the tweet.
Guys.
Like...
All right, here you go.
My Oshi is engaged.
Guys, I have to still engagement farm.
Like, we have a special.
But wait, there's more.
You just gotta find out on the day.
We have a lot more coming on Doki Day.
There's more than just a new outfit.
There's more to that.
I know a lot of people are going to be very excited about
this particular outfit.
There we go.
See, was the weight worth it, guys?
Was the announcement worth it?
Is it the dog shirts?
Maybe.
maybe I'll fucking get new dog shirts I'm gonna start a dog
shirt company
bump bump all right are you guys excited yes Saturday
Saturday is gonna be dokey day two electric book for uh on
saturday and we're gonna have a lot of stuff planned for
that day more than just uh the new outfit there's other
stuff too so yeah look forward to it that's right remember
tim that's before the super bowl i am your pre was it called
where people like pre-drink during before the super bowl i
was there thank you the 150s they get the pre-game i'm your
pre-game and pre-show pre-game yeah we pre-gaming before the
super bowl thank you thank you i do appreciate that yes
there is a lot of stuff to look forward to on saturday guys
a lot of stuff and then after saturday there's dad's
birthday on the 14th i also have a very special thing
planned for the 14th as well and there's a lot of other
events as well go that's it's gonna be i will say february
is my new hell month i know i said december was my hell
month but um oops uh february is our new hell month now
you'll understand guys you're gonna understand when the
schedule is out but um i accidentally got into another hell
like oops all hell i got into another hell month yeah new
year new hell month i somehow always accidentally get myself
into these types of situations Toki, please, stop.
Anyway, time for another game.
Time for another rivals game.
All right, who are we going?
Let's go.
Now we're so excited.
We're so excited about Saturday.
We're going to take that adrenaline.
Into more Marvel Rivals.
Let's go.
Our second win.
Let's go, guys.
Second win time.
We gotta take this energy somewhere.
Now we have so much energy.
We gotta take it here.
Aren't you all pumped, guys?
We're all so pumped.
We hit our second win.
Someone's average.
It's okay.
See, I know what will cheer you up.
We're gonna have some motivation real quick.
There we go.
Let's get that motivation in, guys.
I don't see you flossing.
Come on.
Where's the energy?
You convinced me.
Come on, guys.
Let's go.
Where's the fucking energy?
I don't see no flossing.
Is this good?
Yes, it will.
It's gonna help me with my 40 minute bot.
I gotta fix that.
Alright.
Bump, bump, bump.
Alright, where are they at anyway in the...
I hope Moxie wins.
He deserves...
Oh, they are!
Wait, they're 3-0ing!
Wait, is that... Oh my god, they just need two more games.
They just need two more.
Nice.
Wait, they have Moofin?
The enemy team?
Oh my gosh.
That's crazy.
Yeah, Flask team is winning.
The enemy, I recognize the enemy team has Moofin.
If you know Overrush, you know who he is.
Alright, here we go.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
See, that showmash warmed him up.
Oh my god, straight up.
Moon Knight Bucky.
You know what this cop needs?
More rocket.
Rocket's now my default because I'm so fucking brain fried
down.
Yeah.
Oh boy, back the ring.
someone say more rank
wait someone has dokey day who the fuck is oh my god oh wait
2017 I like basically kidnapped somebody's hashtag I didn't
even realize this it's okay they don't use it no more I
realized I I like kidnapped someone's hashtag who the fuck
would have dokey day oh my god I swear to god dokey 3 day
sake okay don't don't keep our hashtag now it's okay it's
okay there who is this guy I don't even know who this guy is
I'm sorry it's abandoned now it's abandoned all hands-on
deck it's mine now you don't use it no more oh you know fuck
it Let's go.
Let's go Animal Crossing.
Wait, okay, what else is bad?
Ha!
Okay.
I'll play this.
Now give us that.
Yoink, my hashtag.
Look, it got abandoned.
I have claimed to it now.
I have claimed to it.
They abandoned it.
It's all fair game.
Alright.
the battle starts in five four all right here you go two one
i it's yeah it's like abandon where i'm rescuing i swear to
god i i i did like the fucking most ballsy peak ever that
was crazy on me to do oh my god a black panther
Wait, is that?
Okay, I was gonna say.
I better not be a fucking hot guy, I heard.
Alright, I pulled him a little closer.
And I spot...
Yeah, I spot man, it's fine.
He's fine.
It's okay, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
They don't have a Black Panther anymore.
Everything is okay.
Oh, he's dead.
All right.
There we go.
We got the...
See, everything should be fine.
See, look at that.
As long as nobody is flanking us, we should be good.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, somebody was flanking us.
What?
Oh no, he has a reset.
Oh no, oh no, no!
Behind me because I got so paranoid!
Look behind me because I was like, what the?
There's a bucket.
I got my old.
There's still a chance to stop them.
We're gonna have to touch though.
oh my god okay good luck everybody
hey um is anybody alive no me and you never mind just you
wait we did it jeff Your lord plus plus plus
Your your lord plus plus plus
Bro Man is supposed to be Jeff.
What do you mean you don't have Jeff?
Oh my god, I hate that Hey, I should be fine.
Oh, yeah
oh that's awkward um i need you to know it's just me i have
no idea where our jeff is right all right so i what's my
mood where is my jet wait wait where actually is he
all right i was just like um it's just you and me are jeff
is taking the strange on a fucking adventure right now so
good luck oh no i feel like maybe jeff duos support bro what
the fuck are my cues right now i'm actually cursed sometimes
the cues bless me and sometimes i get it's actually like
like sometimes i am blessed and then sometimes this is this
It's just this.
Okay, we can't even get out of this whole hole here.
Alright.
We don't have anything for this, by the way.
Like, actually, nothing for this.
Yeah, I think we need one of the DPS to go tank.
I can hold frontline here.
Alright, um, I have...
Jeff, you had all to get!
I will say that's crazy that all the terrorists are on my
team including myself I will say I will say it's crazy that
I the terrorists are all it's like
we got a stack we got a stack we got a stack we got a stack
we got a stack we got Get out of here.
We do have one that Jeff, that I hope that we will get
something out of.
What?
That's crazy.
He actually hit the headshot.
Can we get out of Jet Warrior and get another...
Oh my god, I was 1 HP.
I didn't even realize I was 1 HP.
Our Jeff is...
Jeff...
Like, what?
They're like...
Get us out of another life.
You know, like, you can keep us alive, you know?
You don't...
give much heal and you bolted twice and they haven't been
good yeah no we we didn't need that i wasn't gonna kill him
on iron fist because i blocked his team i saved our invoice
question mark yeah that's i mean you only i was gonna kill
that i was gonna put the support out no we're still gonna
kill the strange because that was one old right you bolted
one time the entire time well because i couldn't i will say
she is in the wrong for playing jeff when we are not triple
support and not dive it doesn't matter also the fact that we
were not we do not have enough defensive you cannot defend
that be honest with you we just got out dps 10 to 1 and then
we made we had solo we first a solo tank and then got out
dps i will say that there was no reason to play jeff when we
do not have enough No, I actually have...
That's not it because Jeff definitely does more healing per
second than any other healer on the on the team and they
didn't went off of these defenseables.
They won off of our DPS getting out DPS two to three DPS.
He does have a good point.
He does also have a good point.
Our DPS is pretty ass right now.
Yeah, look at the end.
Watch what the deal is.
And we didn't do it because of defenseables.
I will say he does have a point.
Our DPS also Our entire team's just ass.
We can all be right.
This entire team is just our best.
We can all be right, guys.
It's not one or the other.
We can all be right.
We can all be here making mistakes.
See, two times.
They literally, what's it, two times in the first point?
No, I think you're just saying stuff now.
What?
Yo.
oh okay they really were just pushing too fast
hello it's more so blaming the entire team
like jeff wasn't the right pick but also our team our dps is
pretty ass because we had three dps and one take oh my god i
did that uh i double clicked it accidentally there we go i
got my oh let's push in let's go let's fucking go i got it
so fast oh
i really wanted to kill him i always i always get so cocky i
don't give up so i get so cocky i was Like, I really want to
kill him.
Because nobody else in my team is killing anything.
I'm just like, no one's killing anything.
I want to kill him.
I want to be that killer.
Hello.
Alright.
Yeah, I think it's a team dip, guys.
I really...
Oh!
Why did you...
All right.
What's going on?
I got...
I got left to die.
Leftward dead.
It truly was a leftward dead moment right there.
Why if it was a leftward dead moment?
What the...
Fuck why did he say Chinese dude?
Oh,
I hope we're doing something with that.
We are!
Fuck me, August.
Look at what happened.
You let me to...
Fuck me, August.
Where's the other support?
Just our usual tunnel visions.
Yeah, the wall stopped their emerald, which would have aced
us.
So it was a sacrifice that needed to happen.
I mean, I pulled him back.
I did something for myself, my team.
The final 10 seconds.
Guys, sometimes...
Man, I would...
I don't even know who to avoid.
My entire team was pretty bad.
I support, but who will support me?
Who will support me?
Dude, that's a good idea.
That was just, I was like, I don't, I don't know.
That entire, I want to be out of this entire lobby.
I'm going to go clobber some kids real quick in the
clobbering club.
I literally do cute.
It's all right.
We have Saturday.
We have Saturday, guys.
Just remember, we got Saturday to look forward to.
Like, it's okay.
Just think about Saturday, guys.
Think about how great Saturday's gonna be.
Oh my god, there's the bouncer.
There's natural bouncer.
Alright, here we go.
Man, it's gonna make Saturday feel so good after.
Just remember that.
Saturday's gonna feel so good.
An eternity?
Eternity console?
Oh my god.
I've never seen that before.
I wonder if matchmaking is slow or fast on console.
Oh, I want to challenge you.
I wonder how fast or slow matchmaking is.
Alright, here I'm ready.
oh yeah you know what time it is kids i'm ready yeah but i
meant like hi elo what's matchmaking like what is like the
wait time for hi elo so if i lose this then i it's just how
it is we all it's just sunday
oh wait this is bad for me actually because she's she can
never
mind never mind it always works theoretical matchup versus
ira this is oh shit wait actually what is he gonna do just
punch me is you're
not kidding i wait
he can self-heal too
wait he can self-heal too
wait this match will be forever
oh my god wait arifus is so cheap Wait, I didn't even
realize how cheap I've...
New meta.
Oh my god, I didn't realize I've this was built like that.
I forgot I've just get healed.
It truly was forever.
Oh my god, they have the meta.
They actually have the fucking...
Final round starting now.
You wish you were this cool.
Plushie power!
Alright.
We both have self-healed up.
This is crazy.
This is actually pretty fucked up.
Do you think about it?
He's so smart, too.
Look, he just sells you.
He's like...
You can't handle the Q.
It's just all, like, self-heal.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, what?
What?
I didn't even realize that.
Wait, there's, there's, like, healed?
Oh my god, never had a match.
Fucking, there's time out.
There's, no, it wasn't even stopped healing.
It's, it's like, the heals.
the heals, like, decreased.
She didn't even hit me.
She didn't, I lost, she didn't even hit me, but she can
still get healed by her fucking Invis wall.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
I didn't even realize that existed.
No, she had heals with the Invis wall.
All right.
No, I think that's the side.
That's the side.
I realized what the, that's the side.
This guy's been dueling for so long.
They know the matchup.
They fucking know...
That's the sign.
They fucking know, like, the dual meta.
I was like, I never thought about, like, Iron Fist.
They know the cheese.
No, they weren't silver.
They were, like, unranked.
They've never really played it yet.
Jeez, that's it.
I know the strat now.
I know the strat.
that what an invis i know the matchup now all right so the
strat you know what fuck it so the strat is we do we do loki
and then arm fist or hide in the corner with invis yeah
that's actually crazy i'm figuring out the dual mat meta
every loss is a learning experience It's Loki, Anvis, Invis.
This is the meta.
Oh shit, this is a real guy.
No, they top every loss is a learning experience.
Damage over time is crazy because like, she's could still
heal with her fucking thing.
I wasn't expecting that.
Oh!
Nope, not the right one!
Not the right one, unfortunately.
Not the right one, unfortunately!
Time to vanish!
Not the right one.
Not the right one, unfortunately!
The only issue is I've never played Iron Fist before.
I've never played Saga tries to.
Loki is so broken.
Duel.
It really is.
Oh, he knows.
I think Shark wins this.
I'm pretty sure.
I am pretty sure.
I think Shark wins this.
This dog.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Yeah, this isn't it.
This is a shark angle.
I'm pretty sure, right?
Like we both have infinite heals.
Yeah, and then it's sudden death.
Who has more HP me or him?
Because I don't know.
Oh wait, he does.
Wait, he wins this.
No.
Isn't he?
No, I win it!
2 HP!
We both tried it.
No, it's so broken because I'm still getting healed.
I'm still getting healed while it was...
Like, what's it called?
I'm still getting healed while it was, like, death match.
Yeah.
That shit is so broken.
What the fuck?
It was this guy, right?
I want to see what Bozzy...
He had to fucking stop...
No.
No rematch.
I think I dodged the kill.
I think I dodged it.
That is so...
Oh, man.
No, now there's gonna be dual medas.
Oh, it's just support versus...
It's just support and out of this.
It's like you have to like characters that self-heal and
Arampus was so broken it was crazy I was just like wait a
minute I can't kill him it's like his heels are so my damage
is not enough to kill Arampus
and then Invis and Loki Invis, Loki and Jeff is so strong
yeah oh no I think I think duel is over I think I think oh
no guys as a clobbering club clobbering club might be might
be over oh no flats one good for him good for Moxie you
needed that one final last team was is very strong on paper
and also he didn't have to go through qualifiers as well so
he didn't have to play against uh vickers sorry too soon
dude he could have potentially had a chance to get knocked
out
New suit Bro, I heard he I heard he apparently showed up my
Twitter algorithm That he did a stream recently Um But he
was only playing melee characters And people were like,
that's weird He was like, why are you playing melee, huh?
Are you trying to hide something?
Wait,
I thought it was, uh,
I thought it was, I thought it was, I don't, I'm scared, I'm
scared that they didn't have to go through the qualifiers,
too.
I don't know, I feel like, I feel like cloak right now.
I'm feeling cloaky.
We are hope and fear.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
Jams in your lap, it's fine.
up we fall we climb we fall we climb we're to cycle that's
how they get you today i feel like today might actually not
be a rink day it might not be it but i ain't no quitter
we didn't raise no quitter like the moon we shall rise again
We will rise
Wait, let's see
Pick your hero Or villain, I'm not judging
Alright, here we go Oh shit What happened to our Loki I tap
out For one second And I lost the Loki Loki?
I...
Oh, wait, they found Loki.
That's what happened.
Never mind.
And then you went.
Okay, all right.
Okay, I understand now.
That's what happened.
I get it.
No Loki for me.
Mantis cloak.
All right.
Not a lot of sustainability.
Oh my gosh.
Why?
Why do I...
Is today like...
Let's terrorize Doki Day.
It didn't help that my brain was already fried off the bat.
It really didn't help.
I was not locked in at the start.
No, actually, it didn't help.
I have to start my day off with triple support.
Gambit never folds.
That's...
That was the line.
That's where it didn't help.
I had to go through triple support.
Cabin never foes.
Damn.
Is everybody done?
He's gonna be fine.
I hope so.
Oh, I love dying in front of my healers, man.
You know, I don't know about you.
I've never stopped.
I don't know if he realized we're running a mantis cloak
like you're not getting healed don't you're not getting that
much oh yeah yeah oh man I wonder who's helping you oh my
god wow I wonder who's helping you with that right now I
wonder who's healing you through all that damage damn
Oh my god, what the- Oh my god Does he not realize what cop
we're- This guy is fucking stupid as hell Damn He better be
watching replay Because I have not fucking stopped
Does he not realize what heal cop we're playing?
Oh my god.
Oh man, I'm fucking dead here.
I'm actually dead here.
Oh my god.
Does he love dying in front of his healers still?
I'm back to shed some light.
He has zero kills!
Yep, guys, but we all know it's always the support's fault
that he is not getting enabled right now.
Remember that, guys.
He is not getting enabled to do his job because it's a
support issue.
just remember that just remember it's never a him problem he
got what he did it guys he fucking did it oh man oh is it a
support problem let me use my tire you till on you oh
man just remember it's always a support problem naughty
anything else there we go they're gonna TP oh
oh never mind
He got a fucking Punisher.
He is, come on, he is a valuable.
Oh, now, now look at that.
Yep, there he goes.
Oh, now he's justified now.
Look at that.
Now he's Justified because he has the most kills.
Are you a man or a woman?
I'm assuming you're a man.
Like, how tall are you?
What is wrong with this guy?
Bro, I think he's high.
He's high or he's a little...
A little...
185?
I don't know how to feel about that, man.
It's not crazy, honestly.
I know.
Don't say it.
I didn't say anything.
It's a finish your sentence.
I'm just curious.
I'm letting you guys finish it.
Finish it!
A little silly.
Yeah, a little silly.
This is a group effort.
Finish my sentence.
Look at that.
This is a...
This is a collaborative effort.
Look at that.
Actually.
There you go.
We're fine.
We did it Go Spidey, we on I'm spidey Okay, alright We might
actually die
How many How many How long does it take to kill one third of
them It's a boob We made our boob We did not This is some GM
shit right there the fuck out of you we made a boob i want
to help them i'm gonna let him out
hold on man i'll keep doing it there we go just speed itself
to me this phone oh they're throwing oh yeah
Yippin!
They had the...
They had the worst yellow terrorists!
They're terrorists!
They're more evil than my terrorists!
Let's go!
We take those!
They're worse!
Let's go!
The hell is that balloon I don't know?
What the fuck are you doing?
They both sound the same.
Did you guys notice that?
They both have the same fucking voice.
I literally was like, wait, wait, who, wait, that sounds
just like...
It's just...
Let's game right now.
I just realized they both sounded the same.
Who?
Who is?
Oh my god.
He's streaming.
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
And I'm high on ring.
Thank you.
What?
I throw always at this guy.
Okay.
Yeah.
We should avoid this guy.
all right i don't know who else was who else was okay two
final hits five final hits i don't know maybe this guy i
mean that's pretty bad the 7k damage on mag and strange all
right afford this guy he was on support okay let's just
avoid the entire team all
right no that it could be another cute dodge honestly this
fucking thing was wild might as well might as well
oh god i got the files guys i got the thumbnail all right i
can i can make the waiting room now i'm gonna make the
waiting room I'll be like Waiting room is Alright I'm gonna
make the I gotta hurry Now I can make I'm so productive I'm
so productive guys Look at me go Look at me go Being so
productive Alright I remember what did I I'm gonna do the
thing where they make the waiting room early Okay Uh...
Alright.
Doki Day celebration.
And then we put a 2 in it.
And then...
Second year anniversary.
Alright.
And then...
Download!
What did I download?
All right.
All right, here we go.
Responsible jokie time.
Oh, file is bigger than two megabytes.
Okay, I guess.
Give me a check.
I have to resize it myself, I guess.
I was like, oh, oops.
All right.
I gotta resize the thumbnail.
It's bigger than two megabytes.
That's easy.
It's fast.
I can do this.
All right.
Yo, yo.
Oh, Photoshop is opening.
Alright, resize time.
It's all happening live.
That's when you know.
It's all live.
Alright.
Uh...
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I'm not ready.
I'm still exporting.
stuff.
Give me a sec.
Quick export.
JPEG.
What do you think you want to be today?
Alright.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
This looks like a trip support angle.
Sorry, I had to work behind, work DMs that I had to go
through.
I had to type in some work DMs.
My typing is not that fast.
That's because when I was little, I did those computer
classes.
And also, I wrote a lot of role...
I also did a lot of roleplay in Neopet forums.
I did the Neopets roleplay.
I am Loki, goddess of mischief, and the queen of Asgard.
I typed that shit.
I have to type fast, you know, because you're always waiting
for your...
Can you, Jeff?
You want me to, Jeff?
No.
Me, no, Jeff.
Me, not Jeff, player.
Round one.
I am wily, unreliable, vindictive, and yet, oddly
compelling.
Don't you think?
All right, here we go.
30 seconds before you attack.
I just don't know how to up.
That's my only problem.
I don't know how to Jeff up.
I get very confused and scared.
I get confused and scared.
I can play Jeff, but not when I have to up.
No, you said Loki.
I know it sounds very...
I mean, we have a fucking storm right off the bat, so...
like only one person didn't heal it
oh my god there is a hot shot i didn't even notice are there
see this is what i mean this is what i mean the hot cat ptsd
if i knew i would oh it just came my life didn't matter
anyway get the backland backland i'm embushing the emma my
life did not matter they're tipping guys go back to point go
back to point they're tipping here
oh and they wasted tp i saw a pro player did this and then i
was like i should do that see i learned other saw pro do
this in game and now i'm like whoa that's so smart you're
pro with the hawk guys i mean
thank you i'm scared on emma i'm so scared okay it's uh i'm
on chat i'm on chat
Lock into it.
All right.
I'm on Hawkeye.
Nice.
I'm on Ema.
Bye.
I'm doing stuff.
We still get it.
They have didn't know.
I hear something.
I didn't help.
I didn't help Bucky just solo with it.
Oh, man.
Bucky you okay, buddy?
Okay, you still is running Hawk guys.
I'm waiting for the...
I'm gonna be here.
Can you try to force it, Angela?
I'm very scared.
I think the Hawk guy saved his ult.
That's it.
All right, that's good.
I'm gonna hold up there, not guys.
I'm holding up there, guys.
Oh my god.
I saw the Hawk guy look at me.
I got so scared.
You have no idea.
I...
I actually I saw him.
I saw him look at me I saw it The fucking most intense fear
mask Go back go back go back go back go back We're here.
We're here.
Everybody here.
Let's go.
I saw life Flash before me
That's a lot of damage They have fodder in time yeah you
sure do and i do not want to look at these people
i'm out okay i'm gonna see if i can get off any of these
portals oh let's hope he doesn't die we have to push up
though to help this guy no one out wait am i one shot oh
that's awkward um i saved myself
I panicked, placed my clone there.
I panicked, placed my clone.
I thought I placed it further.
I was like, oh, that's awkward.
That clone should have been a bit closer.
Should have been a bit further away.
Jesus Christ, I don't want to.
I have to use my clone to get...
Oh, man.
never miss standing down everybody choose the opponent oh my
god just really i really just got
to be fair they do have cloak with um with no actual
consequences we can't cloak because they have a I don't want
to cloak in the hot guy.
That's unlucky.
Didn't die here?
All right, we're even, we're even.
Look at Punisher.
Punisher's up.
Watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it, watch it.
No, you get fucking ambitious.
I outnumber you.
We like push up or not.
Come on guys.
Oh my god, we can.
Come on, come on.
We already got it.
Yeah, but we could have another time.
Alright, good old Emma.
Oh my god.
That has to be the fucking ballsiest.
Did you see that?
Invis, she didn't care.
Hello?
Oh!
I'll just stay here, I guess.
Alright.
I'll just stay here.
I'm outing after that.
Alright, 3, 2, 1.
You can use it this way.
Aw, that's unlucky.
I'm on shot.
I'm on the Hawkeye.
It's one shot.
Alright, we got one.
We got one.
That's good.
That's good enough.
Hawkeye is like glitching.
It's behind this wall.
Behind this wall.
Goodbye.
I mean, he doesn't know I'm here.
Oh my, I'm just surprised.
You know what?
I'm surprised I was even able to like grab the copy in
front.
You guys see how many people were in front of me there?
I still managed to grab that copy.
I'm just, I'm proud of that.
I'm actually proud of that.
I, there was no, I was so surprised I was even able to grab
that copy in the end.
Hawkeye's upright.
Yep, yep, yep.
All right.
We're going to be fine.
Not, oh, you're so lucky.
I'm on Punisher.
Because there was no way I should have been able to grab
that.
Come on Emma.
It's a four star one jet in the back.
I'm on not.
Kill him before.
Everybody.
Fucking cares about this.
Yeah.
I'm ulting after this.
Give me up.
Give the Punisher up.
Woo!
We got it.
Yay!
my god made myself back in climb my way back up
i was like whoa i made it not even close not even get to
make my tweet i've got to make my waiting room all right
back to making my waiting room all right changing thumbnail
just force uh thumbnail oh wait did i not save it oh my god
did i forgot to export oh no i didn't i was gonna say that's
awkward i was like all right time to export it all right i'm
done okay let me make sure i got i gotta position myself
before i go back i'm so surprised i was able to grab that
grab that in time i was like did i get her and i was like i
i was so like i did not expect myself to even grab that and
grab the right copies.
I was not expecting that.
I was like, oh my God, I did grab her.
I had to do a double take.
I actually had to do a double take to be like, did I get
her?
I actually hesitated.
Even I was like, what the fuck?
I actually managed to get her?
And that hesitation actually killed my team.
Just because I hesitated, it actually almost killed my team.
I was so shocked.
Careful, careful, careful, come.
All right, I'm not much losing the left eye right now, right
now, right now.
I'm not losing.
They cannot push.
Come on, Mac.
Come on, thing.
Man.
One and share stuff.
Moon and one, shut up top.
Give me up.
Force.
I'm up top.
They have two and high gun.
Two and high gun.
Moon and I want you up top.
All right.
Please.
Don't let the Swap off.
I have the Swap off.
I have to swap off Loki.
It's not worth playing.
It's not worth it.
I have to play at the play like, like, like with my team
because it's like, it's like so dangerous.
If you can get the hook, nice.
Everybody punishers?
That's right.
Yeah.
I'm healing.
Look at me go.
Oh, he swapped.
No, he's still Moon Knight.
All right.
Let's see here.
4FF.
We have six.
Oh my god, we have six oz.
Guys, that's all, that's, guys, wouldn't it be funny if we
all use six oz there?
Why don't you hear something, all right?
Why would that be so sweet?
Oh, there you go.
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on, I'm on you.
Oh, shit.
Sin die, sin die, sin die.
Wait, what the fuck was that up?
Oh, we're not, we're even at the six.
Come on.
Okay Wait, can we get this in this?
Okay, okay, okay, come back come back.
Come back.
Oh my god, get in here.
Get in.
Why are you not Maryland?
Oh my god Oh, this is bad
You did the big eyes
I'm sorry Look at one shot.
Look at one shot.
I need heals.
I'm dead.
Oh my god.
That worked.
I'm so fucking good at this game.
Oh.
We're down to support.
Punisher behind, Punisher behind with the chatty.
Punisher over here behind guys.
He's below, below, below, below.
Below, behind you, behind him.
Okay, that's just karma.
Why did I say anything?
I- We have low kill.
We have low kill coming up.
I'm on thing guys, I'm on thing, I'm on thing.
I'm on thing.
I have many.
Oh my goodness.
That's right.
What you gotta do about that?
I have double throat.
I still am insane at this game.
Oh, shit.
I'll be down to Google now.
You get her.
Nice.
Okay.
That's a concept moral.
I'm sorry.
I don't understand why he still threw the rock at me after
he saw my land.
I still, I don't understand why he's still committed to it.
I was literally the only person with the lap.
I didn't even give lap to anyone else.
I killed me.
A cute game.
Weird ass aider.
Please.
Oh my god.
In the end.
I still won the game.
Yeah.
It still works.
Alright, back to the...
Don't worry, while I make the anniversary room, I'll give
you guys a show.
Alright.
I just gotta get the tags in.
Get the right tags.
Alright, here we go.
I see a Doki Day.
second year anniversary anniversary there we go up but all
of them all right yes monetization uh seventh 5 p.m there
you go all right waiting room is now up guys i repeat the
waiting room is
it's called being the target audience that's what you walk
yourself into also i need to get water i'll be right back
guys i'm
back guys i'm back i need to double check some stuff yes i
made the waiting room let me uh link it real quick oh bump
bump bump bump bump bump bump oh made it just in time all
right here you go there's the waiting room Redokie Day!
Oh shit, I forgot to do thumbnail art design.
But...
Let me grab the Twitter.
I gotta link it properly because I was not paying attention.
There we go.
Nice.
Alright, there we go.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
Alright.
Now I wanna play Rocket.
I literally pulled out, like, the fucking game of the
century on Loki there.
Alright.
Here we go.
It's time.
I deserve I deserve a I think I personally think I deserve a
rocket break.
Oh my god.
It's already clipped.
Guys, I'm retweeting that.
Pick your hero or villain.
I'm not judging.
Who are you calling a raccoon, huh?
My god.
Here we go.
It...
Allura or Prism?
Wait, Prism?
The guy that just won first place?
Okay.
That...
Is it a couch-sharing bend?
This better... Oh, man.
That would be so awkward if this was the Prism in the J3
tournament.
Because apparently...
Apparently, for that tournament, you're not supposed to do
that.
This better not be the Prism from the J3 tournament.
because that's gonna be so awkward.
It's not just one first place.
What happened?
Oh, in the chat, someone was like, oh yeah, which account,
like, who's on this shared account right now?
And then it was like, Allora, Siri, or Prism?
And one of them was like, it's Prism right now.
And then I'm like, wait a minute, Blast had a teammate name
called Prism too.
Oh no!
It's okay, they already won.
They can't get kicked out if they already won the game.
They already won, but they won the tournament.
They already won.
What are they gonna do?
Take his money?
True.
He's like, you know what?
I won.
It's time to share accounts now.
It's...
It's time to share account now.
Obviously, it's a joke.
We don't know for sure if this is the...
A lot of people could be named Prism.
We don't know.
Was Prism their tank player guy?
No, it was TTK.
Their Prism was, like, the DPS player or some shit.
Oh, I should be like, Are you the Prism from the flat state
of it?
And then expose.
New video up!
Got a new video up!
Another video for the J3 tournament.
Put it here just in case.
Alright, that's fine.
Hold on, my...
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, is prison the support?
Yeah, so I was like, I don't know which one it was.
I wasn't familiar.
But also it could be anyone.
There's John Prism and there's Dave Prism.
I don't even know which account it was.
No, it's just don't be stupid if you're publicly sharing
accounts.
Because it's apparently...
That was a...
It's like, well, not apparently it is.
is against TOS, and if you get caught, you actually, like,
as a like, if you are, like, a pro, or, like, trying to be
pro, you are not supposed to share accounts, because it's
against TOS.
Oh, my God, forgot they have...
I'm sorry, I forgot they have Phoenix.
That is my bad.
I legitimately forgot.
I will swap.
I I legitimately forgot that they had wait are they oh wait
this is not i legitimately forgot i was not paying attention
i don't want up the rock i don't want him i had up so oh i
should have pulled him back when he was flying
oh he's fine right
Oh, I'm okay.
I almost got it.
What the fuck?
Yeah, he's got it.
I'm gonna wait.
No,
why you push him towards me?
Oh, you idiot!
Fuck you, donkey bird.
I'm their fucking duo fucking healer with you.
Fuck you, bird.
I know.
Why are they all...
It was me...
It was three of us.
I pushed them.
Who's two of this idiot?
I pushed them two.
No, wait.
There were three of us that could have got hit.
I didn't know you were there.
Agent money, please, swap.
Please.
Just keep playing.
Heal?
Agent money?
You're all...
If he all did without me pushing.
Why?
How are you so unaware?
I went to save my Emma.
Why were you at front line?
Why was he on the front line?
He was in front of them.
That's fucking funny.
Nothing much you can do.
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Bro, they're so angry.
Oh, it's them!
It's this guy!
Fuck that guy.
That's bad.
Yo, five and one, you're not doing anything.
I think you can play heal.
That's probably why you're walking.
No, I would have put that one right on.
No, yeah.
Try it on everything.
I probably don't want to lose it.
Guys, you got it on Phoenix.
Yeah, I'm horrible.
Holy shit.
Everyone's so mad.
This guy last time, last game he was playing infinite.
Phoenix is not the problem.
Oh, look, Phoenix is 1v9 and you're speaking to this guy.
Just so you know.
No, I'm killing everyone, bro.
I'm killing everyone.
I mean, this is good.
You're talking.
Yo, can I get some hope?
Can I get some hope?
I'm in there.
Good boy.
Yo, can't point, can't point, can't point.
I'm talking on.
Oh.
Who is this?
What's going on?
That's crazy.
Oh my god.
That's your fucking father right there.
I'm seeing you do fuck all the name works.
Oh my god.
That's crazy.
I mean, we're fine here.
We just have one.
Boreal, now.
Yeah, guys, we're winning, you know, guys.
All this stuff was people.
How is this working?
That's crazy.
That can't work.
That's insane, bro.
I wonder, bro, you hear how the Punisher guy is now super
quiet after like his team fucking roasted him back?
I think that's fucking hilarious.
I got several supports.
Yeah, you got five deaths per block.
Oh, let's go support.
Ace monkey.
Like you see my final.
Oh my god.
And then he swapped the widow.
I didn't have anything here.
It's okay.
They used literally three ults to kill me.
That's crazy.
And then he went.
The widow maker.
Let's see.
The moment it was like, in any way, winnable.
He was like, oh, I'm not throwing hard enough.
That's all right.
We can just report him.
clip too.
We all know he's a fucking idiot.
Now all of China know what you did.
everyone knows what kind of player you are.
Wait, that fucking guy is in Pislow!
He's in my Pislow!
This guy is like Tarn stuck here.
He's trying to be pro.
And he fucking, that's crazy.
I just realized that guy.
He's in my elo.
Right now, I'm fucking doom keeling No, not this guy there's
the the enemy team.
That's why I think it's fucking hilarious Look at that these
they're so desperate.
That must be queued with Doki, buddy
Oh my god, you must oh my god, he must be so embarrassed
right now He doesn't know he's thinking on stream.
That's actually crazy.
All right, let's- all right, guys.
What do you want to say about this loser, this widow loser?
Say everything you want to say to him.
Say yeah.
VG's funny.
I've got a kill since fucking 1994.
Bro, this- worse than Zaza.
Why am I wasting my shield on this?
I mean, like...
I couldn't do anything about it.
I already used by Infus.
It hit me.
Nice try, Monty.
Maybe hold your fucking alt, Phil.
Next game ball.
Who is he shit-talking?
I don't even understand.
Who is he shit-talking now?
good job bro look who has fucking ace somehow me throwing
and i still have ace how are you still in this e-lo that's
that's so funny i just got out of a show match
all right you out by the way this guy he's in fisher esports
representing a school by the way
yeah yeah isn't that crazy he's yeah
and this is his attitude towards um oh yeah i can report
this is his attitude towards like when female players and
also like like he's representing a school like that is
actually crazy
it's like the fact that he's in this kilo and i'm fucking
around on stream it's fucking hilarious absolute like bum no
fisher esports the thing is he's not on the funny thing is
he's not even on the official team is um is terra's team but
like i don't know why the fuck is he like is he like what an
assistant or like oh yeah oh my god why would you have your
discord linked you're such a losing he's not even the guy
isn't even on his official team he's like like the official
team is literally all pro players too like bro who are you
representing.
All right.
Throwing.
Uh.
All right.
Oh my god.
He could be a water boy.
He could be.
That's so sad.
He's like, proud water boy of the team I'm not even in.
bro he the reason why i know is that he has it everywhere
he's so proud of it he has it all over his social media he's
so fucking proud of it yet he's not even on the fucking team
and his peak is lower than me and i don't even play this
game 24 7 he's in my elo and i play this game on stream and
how many streams do i have of rivals right now that's not
like the that's me grinding rank yeah his peak is lower than
my peak it's not even eternity 100
that's the fucking hilarious part and he wants to be pro
which hero do you think you want to be today bro it's hard i
hope i hope he's reading this chat
sorry you're right you're right that's that's bad on the
water boys you're right guys you're right that looks so bad
on the water boys he's water boys are actually useful his
water boys are actually useful to the team i'm sorry you are
so right guys
we love our water boys
No, I'm sitting on two guys.
Two guys that decided to throw.
Don't mean me to almost bet that.
I could say much more than shit.
That's me holding back.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm actually...
The thing is, I'm actually holding back.
I could be a lot more toxic.
There's like a lot of things I could sick the fact that he
linked like a reputable school esport program on his social
media everywhere and he that's how he represents himself
like it's like how you know when you're at a job interview
like they comb your social media and everything like your
you know your internet history is still there like like
whatever you say and everything if that's how you represent
yourself publicly get hired exactly it's easy just search up
that guy like i'm not gonna say how but it's just that
digital footprint yeah like
with how public he is on everything bro he had it fucking on
his marvel rivals account fucking idiot i didn't say it
because i was like guys don't don't Yeah, don't harass
anyone.
Alright, I can't fucking play Loki.
Don't harass anyone.
I stop myself.
Like, I let my toxicity take me there.
But do not search him up.
Okay, don't harass anyone.
If he wants to harass people, like, your digital footprint
is everywhere, buddy.
Alright, I'm gonna swap.
Or is it on Magno?
so embarrassing so embarrassing for him
okay no need to bring yourself down his love sorry i got
like way into the toxic mindset i got way into it but i will
say his stuff is very public i was just like are you stupid
why would you fucking why would you fucking do all of that
and have like a super, and make that, like, super public.
Is our match?
It's going to be okay.
He is.
He's not going to be okay.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
Man, this is not okay.
Alright.
I just feel bad for Fisher Esport.
Having having someone who who's like that.
Oh, watch this.
My turn.
Oh, what the fuck?
How did our guy die?
What?
Our team died.
Wait, why would you go Loki?
They have Moon Knight.
That was the reason why I went off.
I swapped off of Loki.
They have Moon Knight.
I was like, wait a minute.
Why are you on Loki?
Oh, I couldn't do anything about it.
I got caught.
Oh, my.
That's unlucky.
Our Loki almost had it up, too.
Okay, I'm still...
Okay, I thought I was in the first spot.
All right, here we go.
Yo, Bedford, are you a real person?
I love Weekend.
I fucking love weekend queues, guys.
I have
to be here.
I mean, we're running Hawk and Rogue.
Like, I don't know.
And we have...
Hello.
Wait, what?
Oh my god.
I thought I landed on the up.
Where was the up?
Was I not?
I didn't even get healed from it.
I thought if I landed there, I would be fine, but I guess I
wasn't.
I wasn't.
Oh my god, the blue is so hard to see.
I swear to God.
That blue is so fucking hard to see.
I hate the cloak up sometimes, only because it's like...
I oh my god why are we still on Loki oh my god okay I made
it just in time all
right there we go I I personally hate cloak up because
they're they feel so hard to the sea in general i feel like
cloca could be more easier to look at i'm just gonna die on
point there's no reason but can i actually don't even think
i think we're gonna get rushed at i'm gonna get hella
staggered he's gonna get hella staggered yeah i think like
please holy okay okay okay That scared me.
That scared me.
Oh my god, he finally realized he got swapped to...
Oh.
He finally realized.
I think this might be a weekend queue lobby, guys.
This might be a weekend queue lobby, everybody.
This might be a weekend Q lobby right here.
Wait one minute?
I'm surprised.
I could I would last.
Legitimately thought it would have been four minutes.
All right.
Is everybody okay?
The console is zero.
We have Deadpool and Hulk
I guess not
Guys I think I got my answer I think I got my answer And you
should hang yourself
I'm just like Hey guys we all We all okay here Oh, whoa, I
love we can use truly is thank you J3 for inviting me to the
show match.
Thank you J3.
We got
a shield, Tandy.
The pain before the content.
I don't pay attention to that.
I'm just fucking dead.
I just play Yeah, that show match Set the tone for the
entire day It really did It really did Would be what I
thought I mean, we had some pretty Sick games, I guess
Wait, do we have a Oh, we do I mean, to be fair, we did go
Loki we did like yeah yeah i'm cool with that wait who's
that one guy who's that one guy that still has hope in his
eyes who are you who do you not know what day it is
who's that one guy that still is like guys come on it's it's
possible you guys just aren't trying Yes, I don't think
that's it.
I don't think any amount of trying will help.
I literally think this is trying.
That's the saddest part.
This is them trying.
There you go.
Sorry.
That's actually on me.
I was not paying attention.
I mean, I mean, he should understand why I'm not pocketing.
He should understand.
Oh, true.
It's like the league situation, right?
Where people hold people hostage.
Is that it?
Is that what it is?
Is really the league situation?
Where you get held hostage?
All right, how about that jump pad over there?
Yo, I'm going to do something.
Goodbye.
It's okay.
I got a kill, though.
Wait.
Hey, though.
Oh, it didn't matter.
Hey, I got a support out, Alex.
I got a Groot.
I got a Groot support out and Moon Knight.
Oh, I think that's the equivalent exchange.
I won all the first three.
What a fucking deal W I know right one up for three
Oh Hey, you can't I saw my fault, you know your play moon
that you know how these goes you know how these arms go
Look, it's okay.
It's okay.
But you miss
All right, goodbye No amount of help can save you But at
least I get a health back.
W up.
Thank you.
I do love the weekend.
Guys, this might be the time where this might be the...
This might be the time where this might be the last weekend
queue we've ever got.
What we ever get in general.
it truly might be I don't know how much longer I can survive
weekend queues
I've actually never had because I usually never play on
weekends but it's actually crazy the amount of people that
complain every game it's actually crazy I think like this is
the record This and yesterday is like the record for how
many people have complained almost every day.
It's actually insane.
I do this for you guys so you know to avoid weekend.
I don't care.
You're like, this is the only time I get to play.
It's not worth it.
If this is the only day you get to play Rivals, it's not
worth it.
For your sanity's sake.
Where It's a little PSA And I'm doing it for free Too Oh
yeah, I'm gonna avoid this And this gap I cannot have a
rogue and a hawk on my team I am doing a little PSA A little
PSA for all of you
Not worth it This is your only day for you to actually Play
It's not worth it.
Log off.
Play something else.
Never play.
The
battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
Get that guy off of my fucking body.
Oh.
Oh, this Loki is fucking...
I don't like how you're just sitting in that room by
yourself Makes me a little scared for you.
I don't need to play closer to you Like we gotta play
together buddy you and I Please
Okay I need everybody to like not run away from me Like that
is concerning Like it really is I do not like that Like I
don't know if our fucking Phoenix noticed that I fucking um
There we go fucking welcome I was like I want I guess I'll
lock in a little bit
Jesus why did you fly back in why why did you fly in you're
not invincible in your own They can still shoot back buddy I
was like...
Alright, here.
I wanted to pull them back, but I can't.
I can.
Oh my god, this is very bad for me.
JK!
Oh my god, whenever he fucking comes back, I'm like, please,
you are actually not invincible with this.
There you go.
like i don't know he keeps thinking he's like actually he
can live forever but it's like i buddy you can't buddy like
oh my god buddy
please i can't heal you from here please i actually can't
heal you from here please no he has again
no he got crap there's
everything here
Okay, okay.
We won that?
Okay, alright.
It pays tempo.
We won?
Like, honestly, I'm...
I'm very surprised.
I'm like, whoa!
That's...
Bro, this guy!
This guy's crazy!
Like, he is insane!
And it worked!
And it just...
It just works, it just works, it just works.
It just fucking works.
Not TPing.
I mean, like...
Yeah, they're not TPing, like...
He's just...
He gets validated for that gameplay.
things up, including which side you're on.
You'll need a match team to win this one.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
Bro actually was, yeah.
Bro actually was invincible.
It's crazy.
Oh my god, funny story.
I forgot about the story to tell you guys.
um, after yesterday's stream, I got a spam email from the
old Twitch creative director it but like it was like them
trying to pretend that he would like it was like they're
like your your twitch account has suspicious activity of
botting and um and inaccurate numbers and i was like what
i'm so confused i was like and viewer activity i was like
what but then they sent it to my business email which by the
way it's not the email i use for my twitch and then so So,
and then, and then it was like from, um, what was this name?
Wait, what was this guy's name?
He put it on?
Let me check it real quick.
It's so, by Marcus Graham, who was, who retired in 2022.
He was the old Twitch creative director who retired in 2022,
like, 20.
2022, not suspicious at all.
Like, make sure you use, make sure you use this website to
check out your not body.
Like, I didn't even know what he wanted to do.
Like, the crazy thing is, I couldn't even tell what the
scammer wanted from me.
Like, he's suspicious.
Like, I couldn't tell what the scammer wanted from me.
It was not very like...
There was no fish...
There was no fishing lake.
I think he wanted me to reply back.
I didn't click anything.
I think what he wanted was he wanted me to reply back.
And then like...
And then like then send me a link.
Because there was no link at all.
I was like so fucking confused.
All right, here.
I mean, I'm still alive.
Well, um, I don't know now.
Where's my Loki?
My Loki died.
Oh, it's a Deadpool.
I was like, all right, I'm ready for the copy.
I'm so ready.
I didn't even realize I didn't even have a fucking Loki.
anymore okay now it's definitely loosable now now that I
know what our cop is now is it is loosable I'm looking for
it oh shit I should have went in there I didn't think that
Phoenix was right there
thought you wouldn't see me again all right Coming back.
Are they running?
No.
Yeah, I'm like, now this is loosable.
Because we're running dead pool.
That's support.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Yes.
He fucking knows now.
He's like, wait a minute.
This isn't an easy victory.
Bro, this guy almost caps, bro.
What do you mean?
He's like, wait a minute.
I don't get an easy GG's
Okay, I can't see anything there Let's hope that
I have to use that
All right, hey, there's a phoenix right here.
I hope we kill it.
Oh my god almost Oh my All right, look I I will blame my
loot I will blame my Loki for that.
This might be a Loki.
I will blame my Loki deadpool.
I count it.
Because it was definitely unwearable before he went
deadpool.
Oh, he should not have used that.
Oh.
We copy way to him All right, there we go there we go never
punished and never never punished Never never punished
apparently and he'll never learn his lesson.
I need you guys to know that because of this He'll never
learn his lesson.
He'll be like see it works He's like guys see It worked,
guys.
Upgrade.
Thank you for the 100 videos.
Thank you.
And he'll never learn that Deadpool was maybe not the play.
Alright.
Did you guys see the clip of the Nick A guy?
Is now trying to, as the family-friendly streamer, try to
play Arkery.
So, and it was not going so well.
The one that was like never back down, never what?
That guy.
He's the guy who said never back down, never what?
He's the guy that, and his whole branding is that he'll
never swear.
He'll never swear and, and like say, like, he's just whole,
very family-friendly.
um and he'll like and he when he said he said i think like a
couple of months ago he accidentally said shit in fortnite
and he was like oh my god sorry sorry sorry like and i was
like bro what it's shit is so fucking tame that like i was
like bro that shit is bro that's pussy shit like he said he
like actually actually finally swore for the first time
recently and then he was like to go on to the Ark Raiders
bandwagon.
He tried to go into the Ark Raiders bandwagon and the moment
he got on, the moment he got on, he got slurred at.
Oh my God.
He actually, yeah, he got yeah.
I was like, bro.
Yeah, no, he got, to be fair, I saw the clip.
And to be fair, the first thing he said, like, he said to
this guy, because he got knocked it down, he got down, um,
he got down by the, uh, by this guy, like, he lost the 1v1.
And then I will say it was very cringe, but he was like, um,
he was like, okay, I don't want to say it, but he basically,
I'll say it in the most dead tone, but he said it in the
most cringy ass tone ever yeah he said oh whoa are you going
to res me but he said it in that the cutesy uh the cutesy
cringe way and then the guy instantly slurred at him
it never justified I had to slur at someone, but I was just
like, bro, what did you expect, bro?
Dude, I win game.
Bro, he got slurred and then instantly gunned down.
Oh my god, we have a Black Panther.
He got fucking pop, pop, pop, and then like, and then
fucking...
It fucking got slurred in.
It was crazy.
I was like, bro, does God think he's going to clip farm me?
Bro, he did clip farm.
Bro, that shit got clip far and hard.
He thinks he's going to clip farm.
He did clip farm.
Need to say, it was a growth.
grown-ass man that said it too it doesn't matter what gender
says it it's fucking cringe it is so cringe especially if
you use the voice it doesn't matter you're a grown-ass woman
or a grown-ass man that says it in that particular tone it
is cringe and i if i hear that in my game i will
I will do it.
Like, it will happen.
All right.
Please give an example.
Do not worry.
Bro, you should get rid of your...
Oh, bro didn't know.
You could have got rid of the beacon, bro.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry, I got you.
I got you buddy the hero is here don't worry spider-man
don't worry the hero is here oh whoa whoa the hero is scared
right now it really is it's a little scared he's pushing a
little too close so for my like oh that's a lucky oh I still
hit somebody haha then y'all first look all right bye y'all
never mind i didn't have it oh yeah oh that's unlucky there
you go oh okay that's cool
Oh my god.
Wow!
I hope I'm getting healed.
I am smile.
Oh, not this guy though.
I am.
Wait, oh, I didn't even realize Invis was fucking free.
There's Roger Thomas I can heal, dude.
Are you stupid?
I'm on Rockies.
Oh my god.
You get a weapon.
You get
a weapon.
You get a weapon.
Oh my god.
Where did the ult go?
Oh my god, wait.
Oh no.
Okay, I think I should go ahead.
in viz though i'm gonna go in viz oh my god it's i throw for
fun i thought oh my god my avoids reset itself my avoids
reset itself oh there we go another day another game all
right guys i think it's easier to count how many games was
not was where people did not yell at each other i don't even
know we had one we had one game we had at least one i will
say I'm pretty sure we had we had I didn't even okay
I think we had one game I think it is easier though I think
it is easier to count how many how many games where people
were not mad but
we have Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Here you go.
I have to.
It's just counter.
He's just gonna counter mine.
I'm not even gonna try and go in.
Holy shit.
I mean, you got him.
Oh, and it doesn't matter.
The amount of damage is crazy.
Is it actually one game?
We've had one, guys.
That's great.
It's been one game.
It'll be one game where people did not yell at each other.
Oh, that record is not ideal.
I will admit.
I will admit that one.
I hope we...
Oh my God.
actually hit it.
That's crazy.
One game is actually our record.
Reset the clock.
Yes, out of all the games I've played today, the fact that
one game is the record where where nobody was yelling at
each other.
That, I'm sorry, but that's just sad.
That is...
Oh, please help me.
He's out of that.
That is good.
That makes me a little sad.
That is the case.
sad only only a little sad okay maybe very sad you're right
you're right shouldn't excuse it it is actually incredibly
sad if it's you zero first all right
guys the car is there
The card was on the right.
You'll need a top-notch game to win this one.
The card...
I just...
I'm like...
The card is on...
What card?
They already forgot.
Where it went.
That's it.
That's crazy.
Weekend lobbies, I swear this is like a circus.
Saturday and Sunday are truly circus hours.
The team was so toxic it balanced out.
Oh, dokeybird.
Hey.
Hello.
Look at that.
Look a nice person right now.
I don't.
You don't remember me.
He's like, you don't remember me.
He is sort of right.
He is absolutely right.
Oh, he went diamond mode.
Why did he go diamond mode?
Are you scared or something?
Man, it's like he's scared.
Whoa.
He's like, oh, it's so fucking fast.
I'm still at 65.
Like, what the fuck?
What are you aiming at?
Oh,
it's no longer okay.
I'll fight for my...
There's no longer okay, yeah.
To be fair, it was very hard to build up.
I do have up now.
We can use it aggressively here.
I don't know, actually.
I feel like Moonlight's gonna have all of them get fucked up
in general.
Yep
I fucking knew it I I called it I was like I feel that moon
is just gonna all that I'm gonna get fucked up I knew it I
called it I'm used up again.
What's it the team regroups?
Yeah, I love so bad
Okay, I'm just gonna I'm scared I don't know if everybody
would be okay here.
Alright, I gotta use this.
I could have, I could have fucking brought it closer, but I
was very paranoid.
I mean, I pulled him back.
Oh, he dashed back.
Okay.
I ain't doing...
Oh, it's okay.
I'm my shield.
I don't have my shield no more.
I need them to start yelling at each other again.
Because we started winning when that was going on.
We started winning when...
I will say...
We were winning when they were angry.
at each other and I do would think maybe I think maybe
that's what we need oh shit nice maybe we don't need anger
maybe okay nice I think he pulled it.
I don't know.
I don't think peace and love is it anymore.
I don't think it's a...
I don't think peace and love work, y'all.
The weekends, guys.
I think it's just war.
Oh, we have double shields.
What the fuck is he?
Aww, oh my god.
I lagged a little bit there.
I mean, he used...
I mean, he just used it.
Like, there's no reason, really.
Oh my god.
Oh no, there was no point.
He did!
Oh, he used three odds?
I think white is a very good motivator for sure.
I thought you wouldn't see me again.
i think i think we might need that because that guy he's not
getting yelled at no more so now he's playing for he's
playing black panther
but he was getting yelled at when he was getting yelled at
he wanted to play like are we oh my god we actually
oh i pushed him in to lose.
That's fine.
Oh my god, we could have killed him, we could have killed
him, we could have killed him.
We actually could have killed him.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, we could have killed him!
That's unfortunate.
See guys, we could have.
Like this guy, he's just sending any missiles to anyone that
would listen.
He's just, everybody's a fucking...
Everyone's a casualty.
Oh my god!
Like, nobody is safe!
He flims everybody.
I like how he's 18, 16, and he's like, it's not me.
It can't be me.
It's not me.
I don't know, it's what I
have to be in here because I'm a little
scared.
Bro, Dixie's the main character.
That's crazy.
He was like...
They were like...
Oh my god, I swear to God, these two are a duo.
I swear to God.
But like he said, it's not me.
It's not...
It's not me.
It's 2018.
Why did he blame me and the rocket?
By the way, the rocket...
did go rocket when there's a phoenix so he did he did go
linking your discord to is fucking wild yeah
literally yeah thinking why are they like this insane i like
how it's always like the one the one like support up and
then it's all me it's like they're like one bad support up
and it's all me it's like i expected us to fucking kill from
that because that's what pro players do they use it
aggressively they just they're like literally i got coaching
but trust me to be like when we We got alt forward.
Not use it defensively.
We got aggressively used the suit of.
But it's not.
Yeah, beatbox.
Here's my discord.
Yeah, he literally was like, you got all deeper.
You got all deeper.
That's fucking hilarious.
But it's also the one time I did it too.
It was like the one time.
I don't even know if he was blaming it, though.
He's like, all these random support ults.
I'm like, what do you mean all these?
You mean the one?
All these fucking support ults.
You mean the one support ults?
I threw out.
I was like, bro, you gotta get your eyes checked.
You gotta get those eyes checked, bro.
Maybe look at your...
Clearly, there's something wrong with your ass.
You can't fucking see.
If you can't even see, like, the fucking...
16, 18.
The guy had a negative KDA.
The guy had a negative KDA and was, like, this ain't really
winnable, guys.
No.
Oh, man.
Not my hell up.
Why is it best, no?
No, they banned my hell up.
okay oh my that's so funny someone was like you're the only
that's so funny someone got mad that i was like saying that
man it sucks that the other team was trying so hard um
during the show match they made a tweet about it And then
it's so funny because literally my teammates came to my chat
and was also complaining.
Like, I thought it was looking hilarious.
But my teammates literally came to my chat and was like,
bro, it sucks, man.
What you playing?
It sucks that we had to try so hard.
Hmm, that's a good question there, sir.
That's a good question.
Yes, I do say so myself.
Individably.
I thought it was funny.
I like what I'm seeing.
Who is this, bro?
If you wish.
The name's Shangitsilong.
I don't think they realized that...
I don't think they realized what the meta is and what
people...
During the show match, we're abusing.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
See, I thought you were getting hostile on me.
I tried to...
I tried to win my man back.
Hold on.
You're good?
What's your name?
My name is not Chungus Lover.
But I...
Oh, that's a beautiful name.
That's a beautiful name.
I was like, bro, you...
They cannot see my teammates.
We're not happy, too.
Just wait till you see the stat line after the first few
fights.
Oh, boy.
You won't be...
You won't be loving me anymore.
I hear.
They have an Invis.
Fighting?
Behind.
Oh, that's bottom man.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa.
Nice.
Oh, that's fine.
I had to use...
I had to use that, though.
Oh, here we go.
It's alright.
Just people want to complain or complain.
If they really didn't like me, they're just gonna use
anything they can to let me like...
See!
There it is!
There she is!
Yeah, I decided to actually swap immediately because I like
you guys too much and I would have thrown on that character.
There she is!
Help this guy!
Save him!
Somebody help this guy!
I'm never playing Groot again.
Look at him!
He's weird!
Oh my god, what the fuck is going?
I'm so fucking confused.
I also do not like this map anyway.
I have to use this.
They used too much.
They got my lamps.
But he's one, though.
I'm back.
I just thought it was- I usually don't talk about these type
of tweets, but I thought it was so fucking funny because you
know they're not.
Marvel Rivals viewer It's a big, you know, they don't play
Marvel Rivals, you know, man, I'm breaking WWE forever
raking but they all fussy me loose nice dude
What?!
How?
It wasn't even damage boosted Oh my god That's right What
was that?
It wasn't even damage boosted That's crazy.
Alright.
I got it.
Wait, what is...
I'm gonna have to actually glow cloak actually.
I think I'm gonna have to go cloak.
They're going hard, Dad.
Um, I don't think we did it.
I had to use this.
I had to do this so we can have our little...
Oh, we can die.
Oh, we didn't even get one of them up here.
Wait, we didn't even get one of them.
No, we have...
It's not because we have the...
There you go.
It's not better because, like, the bubble is better to play
around with.
No, you're gonna get rock and I'm...
Oh, I don't want to die the other time, but...
Oh my god, is that golden?
Is that golden?
I'm gonna let him build all.
I'm gonna build...
There you go, whose lives.
See?
It's better.
I mean, I could have used lap.
I could have used laps.
It's not better in the case where like wait, yo, hey
blasphemy.
I could play like I could right click Also, they don't have
a float counter I'm not
good alt in here Wait, who alt first?
What did he say?
Who did he say?
Okay What
what happened to me oh my god i don't even know what
happened to me i don't even know i'm at the portal actually
don't even get in i'm a tp wait it's doki i'm literally a
troll
are you up i'll kill her just do it so hard that idiot I
grabbed it, I grabbed it, I grabbed it, I'm dead.
Idiot.
Look at this door, go on door.
Whoever that person.
What?
Hurry up.
He first supports, he first supports up.
They need help.
Boom.
See?
It is easier.
Oh my god.
I think we cap it.
there we go now they're like oh I gotta try now we gotta try
now I never use my that's fucking right yeah earn it yeah
earn my you got earn it I'm a lucky that looks juicy he's
like you never use that I'm right I'm fucking that shit yeah
give that for free oh no not me not me i did yeah oh no
i'm trying to keep you up i swear
Sometimes it just doesn't work!
Oh,
I wasn't risking it.
What was that?
Oh, wait, it's the guy in the tournament!
Tyler won tournament, right?
Sorry, here we go.
That's him.
Yeah.
Sorry, my...
Yeah, we're going.
Alright, I'm sorry.
Everything is blurring together here.
I think Spidey's on the right somewhere.
I'm gonna do it.
I love that.
What are you gonna do to me?
I'm gonna run here just in case I fucking knew it.
Oh my god, please, please come.
I made a whole journey to come back.
Wait, what?
How do we not push up?
I like had an entire journey.
How did we not push up?
I've only done this map like two or three times and I don't
think I've ever successfully made around this corner.
How far strange are the TP?
Don't look spidey.
Well, it wasn't spidey.
It wasn't...
You can walk though.
We're like kind of close.
We won't be actually walking.
To be fair, we didn't have...
You gotta touch it.
No, it was so close.
The current score is 1, 2, 0.
I didn't even realize.
I was like, where's everybody?
We are hope and fear.
All right, here we go.
I hate this map.
I really hate this map in general.
It helps me see the darkness and face it.
Oh.
I think this map is just, it's very, I don't like the map
design colors in general.
Uh, and I just don't like the map colors and also like, I
don't like this concept.
It feels way, I don't know.
I don't like the wall concept and like, I don't like how.
I'll uh yes sir oh yeah no I knew it was actually him he
just didn't know it was actually me you good dude I just
like that hello my back you can fall off in this map I'm
just surprised you can fall off oh we a hard dive I think
he's got him he might I need it.
Oh, maybe you should have alt tabbed, bro.
Bro, I think he alt tabbed and he fucked up.
I think he alt tabbed and he fucked up.
We gotta think I'm back.
Yeah, my game is like lagging somewhere like Spider-Man or
something.
Here we go.
We're going in.
I'm hoping I'm helping all right that's good I'm getting
kidnapped by Thor thank you yeah I'm alive again they're
gonna have moon I don't want any seconds every time I'm not
standing near this are we okay we are we are I don't I don't
have Don't play nuts.
Oh no.
The hard time!
I won't be surprised if one of these players is EU.
The hard time.
You gotta ask to play.
We have to play triple.
We have to play triple, but I don't think they want to play
triple.
fuck you though instead if he gets it fast enough we gotta
play triple for this but i don't know if my team if they
play hard dive it's just triple there's nothing else we can
do grab
well i'm going to be doing this because i don't want to die
all right technically i can do this And then, but we are...
Okay, we didn't...
Oh, God.
We...
We sort of...
Oh, we didn't...
Oh...
I saved her a lot, but we sort of didn't.
I'm trying to see you.
But...
Oh, in our back, to the right.
Oh, my God.
See, I hate that room.
We have I'm gonna let her build up.
I'm gonna build up.
Oh, that's my strange.
I knew it.
I'm trying to help you.
I'm helping you.
Oh my god, I'm helping you so hard.
Okay, they have nothing left.
Oh my god, three more minutes of this!
Three more minutes of help.
You gotta be really careful of Moon Idol.
Holy shit.
Three more minutes of this.
I'm gonna use a lot of them.
Yeah.
Bring that.
This is real firepower.
This is bad because I...
I'm just gonna use this for my team.
I hope my I'm just hoping my front line win my front line
We're gonna play out of it
Oh, no, don't mess with the amazing spider-man.
Oh, no
Oh, no, no, we can't TP.
We can't TP.
We're going to TP!
We- Good game.
Nice try.
I had a feeling.
I was like, oh, it's three minutes of hell.
Well, we can't expect to win them all.
At least people caught- at least that was the most positive
game we've had.
Our second most- our second game out of four hours where
people were nice.
yeah they they game two of people not yelling at each other
you know yeah it was a pretty positive time i hope you guys
are appreciating the fact that i'm sacrificing my elo to
show you guys uh
show you guys weekend queues
the elo true the loss is temporarily that i can get it back
easily when i'm I'm not playing at this time of day.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
What are you stopping?
What's the thrill of that?
What's the fun in just stopping?
All right.
Here we go.
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Do I have another support player?
if all right let's play in this quietly into the background
i'm tired but i am ready i'm currently bro
okay reset reset the clock we gotta reset The clock.
The
game hasn't even started yet.
It's time to reset the clock, everyone.
The battle starts in five, four, three,
That's crazy.
Maybe,
guys, maybe we'll have...
Maybe the enemy team will also have a throw, guys.
We can hope.
We can still hope.
We...
Just throw the...
Guys, there's still hope.
Oh my god, they have a black bastard.
There's still hope.
They have a black bastard, guys.
There's actual hope.
Wait.
Is this a war?
This witch team can throw harder.
Let's let it go.
There's still hope.
it's still possible wait a minute wait they have a jet too
it's still possible
you know that's fine someone basic i think someone on the
enemy team instant dc the moment they realized they were
losing because elo was that important No fucking way.
Also, was it this guy?
Well, that guy was so positive earlier.
Why is he like this now?
I didn't want that one anyway.
That's true.
I didn't want that one.
Oh my god, I got him.
Okay, let's hope that maybe he won't.
Maybe.
Which hero do you think will be today?
Maybe it'll be different.
Who am I gonna banish from this match?
All right, here we go.
All right.
Never mind, my bad, my bad.
Please don't throw.
All right, here we go.
Hope was...
It's okay, I can still hope.
Hoping is fine.
Like, I can still feel hope.
I can...
Hmm.
Oh?
Honestly.
Alright, cough.
Whatever happens, if it's a fast match, if it's a slow
match, whatever happens.
Bro, I will show...
be funny i want to show you guys like whenever i have time
next time because i don't have another rival's tournament a
while i think i hope i think i hope
maybe maybe maybe i can show you guys what non-weakings i
mean actually my all my non all the majority of my rival
streams are non-weakings Never mind.
During my other rival streams are non-rival queues.
Yeah, I gotta fucking stop feeling hope.
That was my first mistake.
I felt...
Oh my...
Where are we?
Where are we...
Like, where's my...
Where is my team playing?
Oh my god.
I don't even think I can play.
like in this into this like I don't even like what okay I
think I actually have to play that
hey guys we're still not siloed it's just chilling all right
there we go horse they did these Fucking bums.
Shut up, bros, bro.
Trust me.
They play little girls.
They're like.
Shameless bums they are.
I feel you, bro.
As long as we don't lose a fight, we win.
Invis just tried to take a fight with me.
He only lived because he's more than healed.
That guy's actually stupid.
Oh, hey, hey guys.
Hey, guys.
We're buff queens.
oh my god he's one he's one that guy's one we gotta beat him
up we gotta beat up this guy all right uh when i die i'm
gonna stop the world people so you want to hold first of him
okay yes oh my you think he knows i i nodded you think he
knows do you think he knows you think he knows i nodded as a
yes i gave a nod i gave a nod i hope that was like
understandable best you're welcome you might go back i don't
know he's not coming back we are first at this
Alright, here we go.
He's so healthy.
Killer, killer, she dies, she dies.
Oh, no.
That's okay, they used everything.
I don't remember how to say hello in Rylos.
Oh, I'm gonna need you to one-shot their cloak out of their
ult.
I mean, I could try if you want me to just push up an ult.
I'll be on top of you.
Whoa!
I don't know where it's safe.
Little does he know I had nothing.
Little does he know!
Oh my god.
Supports are not even on the nest.
Ready?
I'm pumping all.
I'm frozen.
I... I don't know what's going on.
I got it.
I keep getting CC'd.
I'm getting tossed.
I'm going.
I'm getting tossed around, bro.
I don't know what's happening.
You look...
you look!
Who will win?
Help me, help me, help me, help me!
It's...
I'm scared.
I'm so scared now.
They look like they mean business.
Spending a character.
We got a spider.
Oh my god, I...
Test is down.
He's alive!
alive oh my god that was the fucking push up on that time
yeah generational we don't need it we don't need it we don't
need it we don't need it bro that's down okay all right
they're gonna they're not tping okay who's gonna kill you
you're so healthy
Who's gonna fucking kill you?
Wait, is that hell even old?
Did I miss it?
Nope.
I think she wanted to, but she died in her cloak and dagger
old.
It feels good to step outside my bubble every now and then.
Yeah, we just like out-damaged her.
I think her and Invis both died.
Oh.
Yeah, I'm gonna try to save my green for the silo, but she's
gonna try to bait it out.
Ashwin, a book.
Death
would make you an excellent assassin.
I've been told that we are but that kind of violence isn't
really my thing for the vibes today I think everybody right
now is playing for the vibes today
The battle starts in five four three two one All you need to
do is ask your permission area today is a very vibe here.
I think the week and it's literally for the vibes I will
soon show my ultimate power
Dr. Strange now Strange and poor Am I ults us ready?
Ready?
Is there anybody here?
I'm ulting this Let's go!
Oh, look at that Alright Where is Shoah?
Let's see Wait a minute Oh Wait, is that true?
I took her down.
Copy B?
I need to copy Invis and accept it for the B.
Ooh, hey, we didn't even win.
We didn't even win the point.
That's the way.
Oh.
Okay, we gotta help him.
He's mad, but oh no.
I'll punish him now.
Oh, hey, I'll punish him.
you know like oh my god or being able to do that's actually
crazy like why the fuck did they get on that ship for two of
these oh my god i up no he didn't miss i shielded that he
sucked i shielded myself i shielded it i fucked up so i
panicked that i was trying to save our our guys my ass
characters like you're secretly an s tier it's okay both
supports fucked up today it's okay both support messed up i
my placement was oh my god i i made him get closer to me oh
my god it's okay it's actually not okay but it's okay all
right let's have a look though
What?
Doki can mess up?
Unfortunately.
I know I'm not perfect.
Sometimes I don't play it perfectly.
I know it's actually crazy.
Okay, we gotta go in.
Oh, sick hell it did.
Okay, we...
This should be fine.
This should help us.
you still get his ass we can still oh sorry we have my oh
okay that's on her that's on her that'll make their olds
charge that's on her i you always invis punish your look you
look you always invis punish your uh so in the end isn't
really my fault is it is it really my i was also closer to
by the way i was closer to that i would really like this
captain america let me speak up there we go
with those exactly exactly i did say
Oh my god, I missed it this time.
I thought I had the shield this time.
I had to push the Thor because he was close to up and then
the fucking stranger was like, surprise!
I'd be aware of that.
And then he was like, surprise, bitch!
I'm like, oh man, not the surprise.
We have a nizzle first.
Not the surprise.
Because I would...
Okay, sugar.
Okay, so...
Now...
Now I...
I'm a hero.
I am an actual hero.
You're welcome.
I won't say portal.
i am a hero did you hit him excellent teamwork damn i don't
think he hit him oh my gosh she ain't she really ain't oh my
god what is that i'm sorry but what i'm sorry but um Bro,
you see the throw on me?
Stop picking heels.
Oh my god, and then...
What?
Oh my god, what?
What the?
You can capitalize on that.
Oh my god.
I
Um Why does she run away from the point?
Why did she?
Why did she but the sword can't kill you if you're alting
on?
She left the point with her alt I was so confused and then
she blamed our DPS and was like, I'm sorry is on me and I'm
like, but but you all did off point That doesn't excuse the
all off point
We all saw that right?
I look, I was like, where did she go?
Where did she go?
Oh, that's unlucky.
We're not living that.
Looks like the mission area is yours to capture now.
I was unfortunate I feel it was just the craziest shit I saw
I was just like oh man I just we want to live this look see
we got we live it oh my god See, this is why I turn off
effects.
I hate.
I forgot to turn off that effect.
Because, like, I...
I personally, I hate it.
I hate the effects so much.
Because it's so hard to see.
The only good one is the cloak one.
But, like, personally, I just...
I'm just not a fan.
It's just so much clutter.
It's way too much clutter.
Like, yeah, it's cool.
But it's just literally too much clutter for my screen.
i mean i'm trying to oh my god i'm trying very hard to keep
you up right now
please i have to reload i'm trying to keep you up oh sweet
nice free kill but i hope she lets me heal wait oh my god
he's gone moving right now match me now
This is actually trolling
Oh my god, that's awkward I wanted to fight close
Oh fuck what?
I fucked up Wow I fucked up, I didn't see him what happened
i didn't see the guy that was my bad oh my god okay wait
he's on moon night right i'm gonna swap off i have to swap
off a moon night if he's on moon night oh god i'm playing
like fucking mystery heroes because if he's on he's on moon
i have to swap off there's no reason to play I will admit
whenever I fucked up that was a misbe.
That was 100% a misbebe.
Yeah, just so much better.
Really?
Oh, yay!
Oh my god, yay!
Where is he?
Whoa!
There we go.
Yeah, heals!
Free heals!
Anyways, good game.
Oh, he's TPing, guys.
Oh, yay!
Yippee!
Other than that one time, I play that shit perfectly.
The counter-swap.
Oh, my God, man.
Counter-swap rivals.
Yippee!
Yay!
Look at that, see?
Technically, it's still two games of positivity.
still only two games where people were positive.
Too long.
I've been live for for six hours.
It's still only it's still only two games.
What a wild six hours it's been.
Alright, here we go.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright.
I'm tired, boss.
Well, that's too damn bad.
We're in here for it.
We're in here.
Ride or die.
Alright.
oh well we're not trying we're just hanging out we're just
we're not really trying anymore it's more that we're just
hanging out now
we're i'm the e-o-m-m demon
all right All right Log in and oh shit.
All right, wait, okay, this is doable now I tap back in and
I'm like all right.
Oh All right What monsters have you slain
the battle starts in five four three two one All you need to
do is capture the mission area got it From what I hear about
this doom carriage I don't think I'm gonna like them very
much All right, here we go Yep It's okay, surely no one's
gonna die
Surely no one else is gonna die Guys, um, please stay away
from the enemy Groot Wall, it's really hard to tell, but it
is Red
I know it is a little Difficult to tell, but the difference
between our group walls and the enemy group wall is that it
is red.
So if you are getting hit by the enemy group walls...
Alright.
Oh.
Oh, that's unlucky.
Yay!
Oh, I gotta stop.
I gotta heal now.
Oh, let's hope they're alive.
Okay, that's good because I turned around.
I turned around.
I was like, I hope everybody's okay.
I accidentally turned around.
All right.
What if they're colorblind, Doki?
Well, there's colorblind mode.
That can't be an excuse, guys.
Oh my god, I can't climb that wall.
I've just learned that wall is apparently unclimable.
I was trying to climb that wall with my fucking life
Guys guys you're on the group enemy group wall.
You're on the enemy group wall.
You're on Oh my god, he got four kills
He deserved it Little hope little hope I just saw them all
collapse on the enemy group wall and i'm like oh my god i
will need you to not be on there i really i really for the
life of me really need you to not do that i mean like okay
that's good i was a little worried that we did not have that
oh my oh my god i thought we were all here well to be fair
it was me the the invis and bucky i thought we could all
live that but unfortunately um but unfortunately we might
not have i'm sorry you were oh no but we'll get her invis
back at least it's all right the guy that got the 5k i
believe he can do guys guys guys guys there is that group
walk guys i don't know why we are oh guys guys i don't know
why we are
It's okay.
He used the...
Did he do it?
Oh, they stacked.
Unfortunate.
I'm surprised.
Oh my god.
Wait, is this a shotgun Punisher player?
We're not living that.
I wasn't even gonna...
I need you to lock in I wasn't even I mean all the people
lock in I need two points Two points is all I need um most
likely maybe I go
This is someone's like me up.
Oh Yeah, I don't think it's up just stop lucky that needs to
lock in that I really don't think
Where am I?
Get in the old brother, what are you doing?
I'm gonna go close.
I'm gonna...
You're taking for the raid, take it, thank you.
Oh.
Yo, can we get off like Punisher and like...
you know we're surprisingly having two characters that are i
mean we're playing punisher bucket but to be fair this guy
against the hulk at a group surely sure i'm sure my team is
gonna do more than me right the crazy part is that we have
those two yet somehow there is a lot of walls bye everybody
i'd be nice to talk everybody guys great job no i think the
crazy no this guy this punisher and bucky i'm sure we could
not like spare them or something i don't know like that no i
know the meow meow meow count is somebody i've or like not
someone just i recognize that name from count i don't
remember who because i was like yeah yeah that's a funny one
the thing about the crazy part about why people are like
complaining about our bucky and stuff is because um
it's because they
oh we were not supposed to use that with us but oh no
It's because, like, Punisher and Bucky is supposed to be
able to...
It's supposed to be able to...
Shoot the walls, but yet somehow...
Somehow!
I don't know how!
But our walls are not breaking.
Like, none of the walls are breaking, and I don't know why.
No I fucked that up Oh, guys, I couldn't get in yeah, I just
got the worst team.
That's fine.
That's crazy
I don't know why I'm like if I see Punisher, it might look
like the game To win this one because like if you do not
know how to play Punisher it shows you don't know how to
play Bucky It shows it's obvious it's okay hey i got boosted
here it's fine
you just touch the support role i know it's scary i know
you're like very like anxious but go on support
yeah it's ggs that's crazy round two light doesn't dispel
darkness it helps me see the dark that's great you guys can
play halloween no more it won't matter you guys can't shoot
anyways they're playing more they're playing groove man what
the fuck isn't it more gonna do against groove 30 seconds
before you attack two guys remember i've had only two games
the last six hours where people were very happy and positive
or like not i don't even take the bare minimum where people
said nothing mean.
Two games where people said nothing mean.
I can't see the three of you up there by the way.
That many?
Yeah, I know it's wild.
It really was that many.
Oh, we're on heal pool.
Oh, yeah, no, it's over.
That guy has stopped, Gary.
I know it's someone.
I just don't know who it is.
Only because, um, I was like, meow, meow, man, that's such a
crazy, that's such a weird-ass name.
Alright, I take it back.
This cop is cooking them.
Alright, here we go.
up oh well i hope he's okay hey i'm still fine
oh man i wish i had two tanks to farm this i wish man i wish
i had two tanks to farm my support Oh, that must be nice.
I mean, it's just cancer patients.
Like, what can you do?
I'll get those two points some other time, I guess.
Holy fuck, bro.
Like, the player is so bad.
Oh my god!
We're in life.
That
is much better.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Um...
let's get into some good trade wait I think I know oh wait I
know who it is I can't say it though I don't know who it is
I don't know I honestly don't know who if they're throwing
or not I I can't tell if they're throwing or not though I I
can't tell I just remembered who it is I can't tell they
could be throwing this could be actually their skill level
right now it's one or the other I actually where am I where
am I where am I what the fuck was that like I I actually
lost like I couldn't see like legitimately I think he's
playing for the vibes what the fuck was that visual bug did
you guys see that visual bug i literally couldn't see also i
don't think we're gonna make it like who's cute with them yo
who's cute with them bro like you gotta seek new people to
play with
i will oh my god I'm avoiding those two.
Oh, man.
Alright, let's get them out of here.
Who sold you there?
That's crazy.
I'm tired, Bob.
You needed two points, guys.
Two points.
Bro, you need...
It's alright, bro, you need two points.
You picked the wrong day to queue.
I'm literally playing because I know...
I know what I'm getting into playing in these lobbies.
But I think you have to not play in these lobbies.
You have to not play on the weekend.
If you really need those two points.
know what i'm getting into on the weekend because i always
get my points back in the end when i don't play on saturday
or sunday oh he's back you think he'll get us now he well he
needs two more games now you know what just because he had a
bad day i'll go in viz
just because he had a very bad day
He deserves some hope.
Oh, Invis got bad.
Well, I guess I'll cook it up.
All right, here we go.
Let's pop back up under their nose.
Do you think the world is ever going to be a good one?
All right, here we go.
Surely it'll be fine now.
It's gonna be okay.
I believe.
Oh, Phoenix is bad so I could technically play Rocket.
You have to stop them from securing the mission area.
Oh my god.
Are you guys okay?
Oh.
Maybe I should.
Nice.
I think we had life.
Blunky.
oh there's a hell of my goodness yeah that's what he said
just now oh he is peaking way too much and you're not like
that oh
that blasphemy guy just plays whatever the fuck he wants and
wait now he gets every hook possible okay yeah that's what i
was saying i was like i was like remember when i was like
guys i have a i know who this guy is and like it is a 50 50
on whether or not this guy is throwing or if he's trying and
yet now he's having the most generational play yeah he was
throwing brother
Oh, I am not falling for your rage fate.
All right.
I think I don't know if you started.
I don't know.
That's why I was like, guys, I.
Okay, I have to use that because.
I don't want to come back now because I don't trust my so.
See?
Now you see what I mean?
Yet somehow he hooks everything.
Now he's hooking every single thing now.
That's why I was like...
I know who it is.
I was just like, hmm.
Okay, right.
Okay, wait.
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh thank god.
But also not.
Must have been a mistake.
Nope.
Played it up perfectly.
Okay, now I know.
This is why I meet the animals insane.
of his life and he's cute and he's doing with the relaxed
guy he's doing with the relaxed guy
by the 2018 where he was flame I don't think I remember
somebody flamed me no we played me last game I don't
remember that I don't remember anyone flaming me last oh
that's that's an important I don't even, that's unfortunate
we couldn't.
There's two behind us.
Yeah, I don't even think we win this.
I don't remember.
I remember.
His name was Zaza something.
I throw for Zaza.
Oh no, you're, it's a wrong guy, wrong guy.
His name was throw for Zaza.
Tight deal.
Yeah, that's not the BP.
I remember.
I remember the names.
All right.
All right, here we go.
Let's hope we...
Oh, get ready for that portal, guys.
There we go.
All right.
Who got hit?
Oh, our mag.
He's got to live.
Our mag's got to live until...
Okay, now he doesn't have to live, but it will be good if he
does live.
No.
It will be very good if he does live.
All right, three more minutes of this.
Three more minutes.
We can do this.
I think I should go back to D-Gen Qs.
D-Gen Qs are at least more fun.
I will have to admit...
What the fuck?
I will have to admit, D-Gen Qs might actually be better and
improved.
It's a weekend game.
Oh, yes, somehow.
Wait, what hooked me?
Oh, wait, it's a...
This is true, true.
Alright.
I have a little...
Alright, here we go.
Oh.
There's a group behind us.
I will say I think legitimately DJing queues is a is much
better than the whatever these queues are
DJing queues are 100 much better than whatever the fuck this
is oh no he's trying now
Oh, no.
The widow's trying now.
That's...
Don't you hate it?
He's trying now.
Maybe I'll reach him.
Oh, my God, it did!
I do have to grab up, though.
Yeah, I went at a hard to test that theory up.
I hope he knows that I do have to build a halt up.
I really do need a build up.
Oh, no.
I have
to just die.
I don't think we can win this.
We have to die here.
I'm not wasting my health for that.
We lost three.
I should get out in time.
Yeah, I wasn't going to waste my health for this.
Oh,
that's unlucky.
Okay, I...
There you go.
Yep.
Oh, I couldn't do anything.
Yeah, it was unlucky.
The current score is 0, 2, 3.
Oh!
Time to switch things up.
Oh, right now.
Thank you for the torch brown.
Thank you.
Thanks, guys.
See, I think...
Unfortunately, for a guy here, for a two-points guy, it
might...
You might need three more games, buddy.
It might...
It could be winnable.
Round two!
We have powers.
We have...
It might become four games even.
I think it's just...
Oh wait, wait, wait.
What happened to our second tank?
Oh no.
It's okay, we don't need a second tank.
This always happens.
See, that's the thing.
I'm at the Q Dodge because I don't know who that guy, like I
know who he is.
But I don't know who he's throwing for it.
Could be me.
It could be the guy that...
It could be...
It could also be...
Honestly, it could be the guy that was, like, non-stop,
like, talking shit.
Because, like, he's playing Hella now, too.
Because the other guy is also...
I don't know who the other guy is.
I know who Meow, Meow, Meow is.
But I don't know who the other guy is.
I know who I won't say who it is but
I know for sure the other guy is playing with him I have no
idea which one he was doing
because then the other guy also by the way I think we all
saw what he was doing on Punisher wait He was, he was
absolutely, I, no, that guy, no, he was the relaxed guy, was
absolutely not given a fuck.
He, I don't know if you guys saw it, but he was literally
like, oh my god, he was literally just like taking zipline
and then the, yeah, taking zipline and fucking going in.
going in trying to play shotgun by okay I oh shit I didn't
even see was hot guys I knew I would not have played in that
position yeah it was the Punisher with a shotgun so I might
have to Q dodge because I don't know who the target is I
have no idea oh my god I can't play I can't play
I can't play Cloak onto this Because Oh my god That is way
too much damage I can't cloak up this I actually have to
play like raccoon or something It's just too dangerous Guys
guys Guys I think You can get a second take But a hot guys
could get us this hard Yeah Yeah I don't think we're gonna
get a second tank guys I'm not peeking that I fucking just
played again I played against Moxie for that show match I'm
not peeking that like we do he's telling me you're better in
the setup nice that was a I can technically all
right there we go all right
That's where I'm bubble, but then I have to talk.
Then I have to speak.
All right.
You guys, all right.
Let's see if I live.
Oh.
All right.
I like what I see.
Okay, the moment.
Oh, nice.
I don't have to let's go Wait, they're gonna Okay Alright,
we still have I'm I'm so scared of I really am really
fucking scared of Holy shit, I'm so scared of elting
Honestly, that's the only reason I why I haven't elted I am
so scared
i'm very nervous right now
please kill him if we kill him i'll be very okay
oh my god i got to use the all i got to use the all i got we
leave we leave everyone leave everyone leave the hot guy is
coming that was worth it that was 100 worth it because i
didn't have to worry about getting hawkeye whoa
i don't know if he'll live unlucky that's unlucky he
actually got three kills from that he got three kills
he got three kill he got so many headshots you can see how i
literally played like a pussy there yeah because i and i
yeah i might have played like a a pussy, but I I need you
guys to remember I I didn't die to a Hawkeye headshot Oh man
That sucks
I might have played like a pussy But I didn't die to the
headshot I didn't have to wait Just remember that Play like
a pussy, but I'm alive.
Oh my god.
I need someone to kill the hot guy, and then I'll...
Someone to kill the hot guy, and then I'll...
That's not the hot guy.
That's also not the hot guy.
Oh god.
oh my god
someone kill him please all right i'm testing this uh oh
unlucky unlucky if we're gonna take this objective we'd
better do it fast
everyone walked out of spawn oh shit oh everyone did one did
walk out of spot okay do you fair who am i gonna tp to who
am i gonna help tp with oh my god i forgot i was supposed to
swap to raccoon oh well
i was supposed to swap to raccoon
That really sucks.
That shit is really sucks.
That's really bad.
No, I actually don't know.
I don't think it would have done anything.
Even if I went...
Even if I went, uh...
Cheechy.
Can't be pizza.
He's not fucking...
Oh wait, he got third place.
right hey
definitely not pizza
unless no he's not he fucking he must be out of it oh wait I
had the q-dash that's q-dash time I'm gonna remove I'm gonna
remove it uh what was it I had a feeling they were doing I
had a feeling in we in real doom queue hours I had a feeling
I had a feeling see it is an ult account I told you guys I
knew it was an ult account oh my god is he doing the whole
oh that's crazy we in one of them is uh is appearing off
line wait really
beard offline?
Oh my God.
Have you eaten yet?
I ate lunch.
I had a good lunch.
I had curry today.
Not curry.
Sorry, guys.
Not dinner.
I'm not that hungry.
This is my food.
Uh.
I'll curry today.
So I'm like pretty full in general.
To be fair.
I'm pretty full.
It was a big-ass creep.
For anything.
I'm going to Q-Dodge.
I'm going to P while we Q-Dodge.
But don't worry.
I got you entertainment.
Plump.
Fucking knew it.
I was like...
I knew.
I know.
I was like, that account name is so familiar.
And I was like, knew it.
Because I remember.
playing like I remember like not playing with but like I
remember seeing that account somewhere
I had it back in I see you in GM see I am a PSA right now on
the dangers of weekend queues I am I'm giving you the
dangers of weekend queues right now watching really inspire
me do you have any tips on to play gambit damage if you if
you if you are heel bonding on gambit you're doing it wrong
basically that's literally how you play gambit cautionary
tale to everyone i do it so you don't so you won't i'm
having fun though i'm still having fun i like the I like how
Unexpected these games are I like how How How Wild The wild
Wild West right now Never know when's the New Disaster
Exactly Exactly you know what i'm saying
oh yeah you can we're just vibing i mean i'm just oh my god
what can i say instead of vibing what can i even say it's
tainted i'm just having i'm just chilling i'm just chilling
god damn it vibing was in my vocabulary like unironically it
was unironically In my vocab.
And now I can't even use it no more.
Bump.
Can't believe it got ruined.
Sorry.
This is sushi a little bit.
I'm looking for your Saturday though.
Sorry it's gonna be fun.
Guys.
i can't wait i can't wait to see for you guys to see all the
coolest stuff i planned up for saturday which hero do you
think you want to be today
all right we're gonna have a good time guys are we gonna
have a good game today all right guys all right is this
gonna be our third game where no one's gonna complain
is this it is this gonna be it guys
no hope reading you're asking too much
you'll need a top All right, here we go.
I don't know.
Oh, they're going to go Phoenix, then...
Like, what can I play?
Am I going to go on in with no Phoenix?
Guys, what if they don't have Phoenix, though?
Oh, wait.
We have heal pool.
You know, once...
You're right.
I just got to wait.
Once 1 a.m.
Everything changes.
You're so right, guys.
I don't know how, like, I'm taking the Gamba.
Oh, my God.
I'm on defense.
Oh, no.
This is the Gamba of the lifetime.
I am taking the Gamba.
That's where I can go.
This is it.
All in.
If they have a Phoenix, we all know who's gonna be yelled at
today.
and they have a phoenix well oh guys it looks like they have
a phoenix
I have a phoenix right now.
Ooh.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're all gonna shoot the earth, right?
We're all gonna do it?
Do I have to play?
It's okay.
We're all gonna do that, right?
Oh man, I can't even play Loki.
Who the fuck am I gonna copy?
Peelpool?
Like, what am I gonna do?
Oh, no.
Now it's just mild.
Now they have only mild to rely on, guys.
Don't worry.
I believe that they...
I believe!
Oh, my God!
believe he didn't have his phoenix up yet that's crazy now
we don't have uh oh oh that's awkward that's awkward yo
oh hello hello hello hello shoot me shoot me no he didn't
shoot me oh my god he's missing
i just saw him i just saw him he's missing He's him!
He really is!
I didn't!
I did not expect that!
You are nothing!
Good news is...
There's no good news actually.
There's no...
Why are you playing heal pool?
No strength can't force.
Oh my god.
That chore.
Oh.
I had a feeling that was gonna happen.
We didn't have any.
Bro.
Oh no.
I was wondering why I... Guys, we have so many us.
And why are we still neutral?
Oh.
Oh
Guys guys guys there are two flinkers guys guys guys there's
two flinkers Guys, guys.
Oh, I don't think he's living.
This is truly...
Yay, the weekend.
I love the weekend.
The whole pass left the game.
It...
Hmm.
Wow!
What a free push every...
Oh!
They hit a checkpoint.
Now might be a good time to stop them.
5-4-3-4.
I must be.
Thing goes upwards.
I will say that if anybody's gonna get blamed right now, I
don't...
It may or may not be...
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Let's get him over here.
Guys, hey.
Hey, hey, guys.
Hey, guys.
There is still the random fantastic over here.
The guy wanted triple support.
Who is the problem?
problem here
Which I don't think it's our thing I like how it was our our
Teal pool that was like bro get the fuck off thing we need
another support and I'm like
I'm in this should be oh I forgot to get rid of my words I
gotta live too overconfident in there.
Is he?
Alright.
Hmm.
I do think our strange got a little too excited.
Just a little bit.
Man, I wish we had another tank to heal.
Oh, eh.
Eh, fuck.
But eh, I did get it.
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Oh, never mind.
Yeah, I'm still streaming.
Have me.
Oh, thank God he got...
Oh, God.
I'm still...
No, I don't think any lobbies are good today.
The current score is 0 2 3 Time to switch things up
Including which side to do something You'll need a top-notch
team To win this one How is rocket the problem?
How is I have to There's no I cannot There's no way I can
play like They're like, Cluck, with Pooh.
They're like, why did he group me?
I'm not playing Loki with a heel pull.
What the fuck am I going to copy?
I will play Cluck, but I don't think I...
How was I the problem?
Why did they group me with the heel pull?
30 seconds before you're back.
Luna Jeff Bro doesn't know Luna is like fucking hard nerve
Oh my god Bro doesn't know Luna is Fucking dog shit Yeah
Luna Jeff Bro why did you Why did you you mean i think he
was just checking that they were gonna look at my heal stats
and then they're gonna see how did i get grouped up with
this i'm literally like that's crazy that they grouped me up
into this is actually crazy i was like what did i do
Holy shit You're like It's you and the dead poor And I'm
like me We have a dead poor What do you mean me?
If anything I was the one that kept living That's the crazy
part like that's right what is they fuck me for I don't know
is are they gonna be okay like oh yeah they blocked him yeah
guys reset the clock it's still two games guys it's still
it's still two games It resets the clock.
It's still two games.
It has not stopped me.
Still two games where people are not toxic.
I hope someone else is pushing this.
Because I'm...
I hope they're all okay.
Oh my god, we're still going in?
We're just back.
We're still...
I mean, fuck it, let's go, let's fucking go, let's fucking
go, let's fucking go, you know what, fuck it, let's fucking
go, oh my, let's, yeah, fuck this, let's go, let's fucking
keep on going, let's fucking keep on fighting, let's fucking
go, fuck it, I did not expect us to keep going, let's
fucking go, man, let's do this, let's fucking do this, I
guess?
Normally I wouldn't, but then I was like, you know what?
You guys really want to?
You know what?
All right, so this might be where like it ends.
Unless...
No, no more.
This is where it stops.
This is where it stops, maybe.
All right, here we go.
Bro, it's a 1v2.
I don't know, buddy.
There.
I mean, they have a little key.
It'd be pretty neat if we had someone go third support.
Please, I really need those.
Please, someone go goats.
I'm so close.
There is.
Oh My I'm alive
Oh, no, that's a fucking lap
Hey guys, there's still a lo- there is a loki over there,
but not sure
Hey guys guys we sort of ignored the foot but that's okay
did you see all of them just fucking ran did you see all of
them just fucking holy shit he's fucking great all of them
just ran to forward yeah i was like guys
You know, it would be pretty neat and weird.
You know, came back a little.
Oh, he got fucking blind.
I think my, oh my god, I have to be the fucking...
That actually was the fucking thing of the century.
But, I can't.
There we go.
Hello.
I came back for this.
I came back for it.
Alright, back to pushing cart.
I mean, I would love to push cart, really, honestly.
I would love to push cart right now.
I...
For...
Oh, are we okay?
Where's our teammates?
My mouse died.
Oh, my God.
I forgot to charge my mouse.
I'll be a die regardless, though.
Not going to lie.
Okay, that wasn't really a throw because, like, fucking dead
I was not living that I was actually no I don't know you
guys know that but that was it was not a winnable fight for
me hundred percent I was so fucking dead oh that's good oh
my god it's so close oh my god oh All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
Do we keep...
Here we go, I guess.
Oh, my God.
Oh, it's not winnable.
Oh, no.
It might not be winnable, guys.
They have Alt Advantage and we have Heal Pool.
We have...
We have Heal Pool and we don't know where the portal...
Oh my god and this is the portal!
Oh my...
You know, we did make it pretty far with Heal Pool.
Wait, we made it pretty far.
Heal pull is not... Tank pull is better.
Heal pull is not great with deal of support.
I would personally think.
It was a good try.
It really was.
I'm so...
I'm going to reset the clock.
Reset one.
day I'll find I'll find a player one day guys reset the
clock two games and no more no that guy that guy did not let
any shot I got I literally I was like how did I how did I
die and then I I looked at his cam and I was like oh no he
literally needed hit one shot on the hot guy and it was like
miss miss miss miss and he gave up I don't know I don't know
it but he actually gave up in the end I'm trying to shoot
him in the replay I fire and I missed again and I fired and
I missed and I fired and I missed again I don't know I think
it's insane that he that he missed and then gave up he gave
up why did he Did he give up?
He didn't use like, it's not, this is not my day.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna keep going.
It's not my day right now.
It's not my day.
Well, I don't think any rank is, is like, okay right now.
Not during Sunday and Saturday.
Not during either of those days.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
Alright, remember I have to like Start trying, I pick Invis.
That's crazy, my mouse died in the middle of it.
I want to order that new mouse.
I still want to order that new mouse.
Yeah, I do ranked from Celestia too.
To be fair, that's on me.
I feel like there were I feel like, okay, I will say there
were maybe five games that I personally threw, like, not
through, but like, like, I would say, like, four to five
games that I didn't play my best, but the rest of the games
were, was actually, like, pure, RNG, just people screaming
at each other.
I don't know we all saw that right there were so lots of the
games were pretty much like unwinnable on hero select and
then people just started screaming at each other we all saw
it
I can play rocket now I play I'm playing this I'll play in
this just to play for my team
I heard it.
Yeah, I was just like, oh, I'm just like, huh.
Cosmic rays didn't make me who I am today.
My family did.
Yup, anyone here?
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Let's see.
I'm gonna double check my, check my mouse.
I have seen you, sister.
How fair you?
I have no desire for small talk.
All right, how much has it charged?
12%, okay, that's not a lot.
All right, I'll let it charge for one game.
I hate Wired Mouse.
Wired Mouse is not it.
I'm not, I'm not a fan of Wired Mouse in general.
It's just, I just don't like, it just feels very annoying to
play with.
Yeah.
I forgot to go right side.
We're on the upper other side.
I was so used to being on the opposite side.
there's a thore there was a thore i hope he didn't see me my
aim is a little wonky though with wired so i'm not throwing
too much
there's nothing on left
oh that's fast that sucks we don't really have like
frontline tank that's the only issue we don't really have
like a front line oh there we go there we go yeah oh no
that's that often yeah we got what we wanted oh that's not
cool gonna save so we actually need it up but our Agnew is
doing a lot so I don't know
all right welcome back again that's five throw it throw it
throw it nice all right we still have Luno too they don't
have Deadpool yet all right oh I hate playing with Wired
Mouse it feels so fucking like I don't know why I don't know
if this tech people tech people I need help why the is um
why when i play on wired um the sense is higher like it's
not like and i'm not like placebo effect right now it
actually feels a lot higher is there a reason why buggy's
going all the way back buggy's going all the way around hey
guys yeah
that's unlucky That's unlucky.
That's unlucky.
Oh my god.
Why did we leave?
No, but thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Oh, we had a great stream.
That's awkward that we left floating there.
I was like, what?
What?
Why are you...
Our mag is so scared for no reason.
There's a higher default DPI.
All right, I'm gonna have to fix that then.
I did not know that.
Okay, he's...
Oh, that was so cute though, but...
Oh, nice.
All right, I'm trying to help.
Fantastic on me.
All right, here, you're fine.
You're so healthy!
And I have a look!
Okay, Spider-Man's gonna try and grab me.
Uh-oh.
Nice.
Atty Rank from Celestia.
At least somebody's having a good weekend kill.
Not me, unfortunately.
Bad to use that.
I was really weird.
Oh, it's fine.
Really me?
I did not read you're the fantastic on your school I did not
expect him help Ella help Ella yeah spider-man all soon
watch out oh yeah keep running up keep running man he's on
me he's trying to spawn cat me look at me look at me look oh
my god tell me he's on me he's on me he's on me
team still be ready to push him i'm gonna stay with you okay
cool he's over there though i hope he's healing them because
i'm not he is okay that's good
that's good fantastic and die fantastic okay that's good
Oh, oh, guys, we're just one.
So what?
I got you.
He's got an alt, though.
So I don't know.
He still has alpha.
Alright, let me double check.
I'm going to check my mouse settings then.
I did not know that it does default.
It changes my mouse DPI.
Nope, it's still 800.
It's still 800.
100.
That's weird.
Alright.
See, when I start having to try, I play in this.
When I just want to chill.
Yes.
Mouse acceleration.
It could be mouse acceleration.
But to be fair, I like never do this shit, mouse
acceleration, for some reason.
I'm not...
That's the thing.
When people were hard criticizing High Guard, they were
like, Oh, the motion blur was always on.
I can't fucking see shit.
And like, oh my gosh, the frames, the frames.
But I'm like, uh, but their eyes are better than mine
because they're pro.
So it's like, for me, I was like, I hate that.
Photo queue sucks.
That was like my major.
That was my major.
I didn't even notice the crouch.
I, I, I didn't like, I feel like the one thing I definitely
should have noticed was the crouch top.
There was no, uh, there was no hold toggle.
thing i i was like oh i didn't even notice about that i
should have noticed it
i had to use that but there's a there's a fantastic on your
food
it's fine it's fine i planned so planned Behold the god of
thunder!
Oh!
Oh my, that was just way too much damage.
It was just way too much damage.
That was a thin screen right there.
You shall see the extraordinary power of the trickster
goddess.
An opportunity for combat.
But yeah, I definitely should have noticed that there was no
holes to toggle.
I did find it very fucking weird that my Like crouching.
I mean, hold it to crouch.
I was just like, whoa, what?
It felt like that.
Again?
That's so fast.
He can die.
I thought you said he can die.
I'm not gonna heal.
Please.
I'm the only person not full.
I didn't see.
I'm sorry.
If I knew.
Oh my god.
She can die.
Oh, what the fuck?
It worked out.
Everything worked out.
It all worked out.
Wait, you're up really far.
I don't know how.
Maybe.
Here's what they are looking at.
Oh my god.
That's good.
Oh fuck.
I hear you.
realized she was still alive.
That was my bad.
I legitimately thought she was dead.
Get him!
No more no bubble no bubble.
I fucking took him off of the high ground.
Oh no.
I didn't know I was under it.
circle it's okay it's winnable
yes it's supposed to happen because when the map moves well
technically it's not technically that's not supposed to
happen but it's a it's a game bug that's still like this
it's not supposed to be like that The curse is broken.
Nice.
I had to just play Sue.
I really did.
I usually have Donga.
I have to avoid this guy.
I'm sorry, but I don't want no heal pooling by team i really
don't i nearly all right that should be that should be
enough yeah yeah bottom don't bottom bump bump bump bump
bump bump bump bump bump all right let me and see how much
my battery charged i don't expect to stream this long today
but i know i don't know why are those streaming rivals 30
percent you know what I'll leave it charged until our game.
Yelpua!
Yelpua's just fucking ass.
Yelpua is fucking ass on dual support.
If you're doing triple support, it's fine.
It's just...
Not dual support.
I'll go low key.
I'll play for the win.
Tank pool is the best.
No, it is.
100%.
Tank pool.
It's tank pool, heal pool, and then DPS pool.
But even then...
If you're gonna play triple support, you play Mantis triple
support.
Why the fuck would you play?
Why the fuck would you ever play triple support with...
With...
Healpool when you can play triple support with Mantis.
It's just literally the better comp.
Like play Luna.
Yeah.
Like play...
If you were gonna throw at least play Luna.
Well.
Pick your hero.
Or villain.
i'm not judging all right
oh well i mean it works i would play jeff i mean i could
play man
wait mantis ultron in this that is a it can work if it does
it i'll go get loki it's a very weird support god That's a
word I will say.
Um...
Is it today supposed to be...
It was until I...
Until I got the rival's bug.
The siren called for me and was like, What if you just keep
playing?
And I'm like, You're great.
They're like, Tomorrow's your rest day, Doki.
What if you just keep playing?
like you're right
I don't even enjoy the streams
well he's the only one opening up for it
which way which way is the enemy okay I got a little
confused I was like which way is the enemy though
Oh, there's something wrong.
I might just check my mouse settings now.
There's something.
Yeah, my mouse sense is high.
I need to check the...
I unplugged it.
I unplugged it, but my mouse sense is very high right now.
I got a check-in mouse acceleration was accident.
What the...
Oh my god, if I do...
Oh, I could have...
Oh, I'm mad.
And it like actually jumped scared me.
I was like, what the fuck?
Is she just standing there?
I actually got jumped scared.
I got so confused.
When I saw it.
It looks like Namor called in his swim team.
You don't have to fight alone.
It felt nice.
Here's how you shoot.
Yeah.
I should DPS more, but like, bro, they're doing it for you.
me all right all right go go go what the is going on
all right all right all
right don't worry i know they have like oh they don't even
have gruta anymore nice i like that what can i shoot
everybody dies so fast i feel like i can't shoot nothing oh
i should damage miss that
there you go
fuck you
bro okay bro okay fuck me i guess like me i guess oh no oh
what did they pour oh they pour it up oh yeah wait oh no his
duo died we gotta wait ultron's boyfriend died
boby ah he that's my bad that is my bad That is actually my
bad.
That was my bad, but we also have three other supports who
also did not look at you So like is it really my bad?
I have the lowest I have the lowest heal output.
So is it really my bad?
My heal output is is theoretically be a lowest
There you go It's Shenzhen's over, Shenzhen's over.
There we go.
Alright, here we go.
No, I'm...
He's...
I assume Amadian 3...
That is his third account.
That's what I assume.
I...
No, it is weird.
Alright, I'm gonna check my mouse settings.
I... Something feels weird with my mouse.
it feels super high I'm gonna double check now where's mouse
mouse enhance pointer okay where is the additional mouse
thing stereo point what okay no everything seems fine.
This is my DPI.
Feels hot for some fucking reason.
Yeah, I saw.
I saw 800.
What the fuck?
Oh.
Maybe I played on the high sense too much.
And then my muscle memory was not great.
It was some shit.
My muscle memory was like, whoops!
You played on high sense for too long.
I'm like, oh my god, I didn't even I noticed they fucking
portaled again.
And they're like, it's two.
It's it.
That's it.
Like...
I do not want to play against our torch.
I'm pretty sure Amalian 3 is like this guy's through the
couch.
I'm pretty sure.
Like, I have a feeling that it's his fucking third account.
Yeah.
Like, I don't...
Oh, that would have hit him.
Am I?
Okay.
I was gonna say it.
I'm a little scared, though.
I'm gonna...
Well, let's hope that...
Oh my god.
Wait, we don't have a second up.
We don't...
There's so much damage!
Who are we gonna do?
I expect more damage!
I can't do anything about that.
Sorry, but...
There we go.
What the fuck was that lie?
That was a- that was some fucking wild projectile lag there.
I should not have hit that.
I'm like, I mean, I'm not complaining.
What is that up?
What the fuck was that up?
Alright, let's go.
Yeah, yeah, I'm like, you know what would have been helpful
if you fucking save that all for that?
I think if you saved it, it would have been fine.
It would have been nice if they peaked me so I can farm just
a little teensy bit.
Where are they going?
Oh no!
I back out now.
That's where they're going.
Okay, a big issue.
I never miss.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh my god.
Wait, this guy's dumb.
Wait,
I'm just like, wait a minute.
This guy's making stupid.
Let's kill him.
Oh, my.
ROTPA?
Okay, I might have threw that with that up.
I just thought he was fucking stupid.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I think this is it.
I think it's the DJ Qs.
Nice up, nerd.
I was like, wait a minute.
That's fucking stupid.
And it's like, yeah, dumb as hell, but run at him.
I made it.
I made it to the promised land.
We finally reached the D-Gen hours.
The peak, the peak rivals games.
We fucking did it, guys.
Holy shit.
We fucking did it.
Oh, GG's.
I didn't see your main before.
I was like, I knew for sure.
like, this is what we, GG's butt, man.
I was like, man, I know that's not your main.
I,
is this what you call the promised land?
I told you, the moment you head to DJ and Q's, the game's
improved, guys.
is my land.
That is my queues.
Those are my queues.
That's where I thrive.
It's literally how I thrive.
Somehow.
It's my home.
I feel so comfy.
It's my people.
I don't know.
Yeah.
He's still here, but I don't know.
No, I did weekend queues for the first time and went from
Celestio 2 to GM 1.
I was like, can't be that bad.
And then this is now PSA to never queue at this hour.
Like, on this day and Saturday, we never queue on these two
days.
This will be the last time I ever play on Saturday or Sunday
for rivals.
It'll be the very last time.
It isn't, no, it's crazy.
It is actually insane.
I've been streaming and playing this game since the
beginning of the season, like on and off.
But none of us, I don't think any of us has ever encountered
lobbies that were this special.
I don't...
I do not think we've ever encountered lobbies like this
before.
That was, guys, third game!
We made it!
Third game?
Guys, third game!
That someone wasn't toxic or blamed somebody.
We fucking made it!
We've hit game number three!
Yeah!
Put it up on the board.
Take a picture, guys.
We got to take a picture.
We made it.
Three games where no one blamed anybody.
And like, everyone was, like, nobody said anything.
Which is already a plus.
You know?
We were doing, like, the bare minimum.
Guys, this is, like, the bare minimum of people not even
saying anything.
wait no there was one word yeah you know from just sunday
cues from just sunday cues i literally had we've only had
four games where someone did not throw did not blame someone
did not yell each other and just played the game and was
either just play the game or was positive about the game and
I've been streaming for seven hours and all those other
games people were not happy like there will be arguments the
fact that it's easier to count the games that were not bad
no it's it's the weekend views bro I tell you it's the
fucking weekend queues.
It's where like...
It's where everybody comes on.
When you're desperate for people to not even say anything.
I am surprised we went Luna, but you know what?
I won't judge.
All right, we're not gonna okay, cool.
I didn't want to use that but like I also don't didn't think
like my Luna would live Hey It's my art did our venom just
try to dive an iron fist?
Whoa Maybe the wrong target?
I don't know that's just my opinion I was like, you can dive
anyone in the world.
Who will you pick?
Uh, that was bad reaction time for me.
I legitimately thought they were closer.
Because both our DPS was not there.
Yeah, see you dropped?
Exactly!
Exactly.
You see the way now.
what you see the way this is like a psa i mean she has all
first so
oh i mean that's cool oh that is not no longer cool where's
my all right here
okay okay let's okay guys guys i don't know why we were all
we're all split up there but we got oh all right i don't
know they have a mag do they have a mag i was gonna say this
might be a cloak angle but they do have a mag
oh wait i didn't even realize i have a moon night looking i
was not paying attention oh okay oh my god i didn't have a
phoenix okay i guess i just don't play nothing I don't have
to taint the mag.
Alright, the mag has to pick me or Punisher.
It's okay.
He has to pick one or the other.
It's alright.
That I'm also fine.
Oh!
He picked the Punisher.
He really did.
I did save.
oh my god
oh my god i'm trying to heal buddy like we have to kill this
guy i don't know i think it'd be easier if we just kill this
guy what did it i'm trying but like i'm fucking firm on the
crit bear i am ready to put on a show Alright, what?
Oh, wait, never mind.
I wanted to...
I'm just not gonna fucking believe it.
Alright, here we go.
That was such a huge risk.
When I did that.
That was like, I think.
Oh my god, you didn't realize.
Oh my god.
I'm trying, buddy.
I'm trying to heal.
How do we not shoot the Loki?
Oh, how is he still there?
I can't do anything.
I'm just a fucking baby.
I'm a joke.
I'm gonna steal that spot next time.
I can't play Loki.
They're playing Moon Knight.
You know what's crazy Are you just like not shooting the
Loki height?
Don't talk bro.
Don't fucking talk.
No, no, no, no.
I can't go back.
Guys, reset the boy.
Reset the timer.
Yeah, let me, let me play it on Punisher, bro.
Reset the calendar.
Like, what are you doing?
You're just sitting back with your dicky.
Because the crazy part is that our record is one game in a
row where people are...
I haven't seen you bait out rooms once.
I think this is a...
I think this is making rivals look bad.
It might...
I'm sorry, rival this, but like...
It's not my fault that the community is a little bit trashy.
What is that?
This might be a negative.
This might look bad.
It's definitely God.
Guys, I think I'm accidentally making rivals look really
bad, right?
Or did it me too?
Wait, who's my other...
Oh.
You started out in the game O3, bro.
Let's not forget that.
I did not forget that, brother.
I was like, wait, was my other...
Oh.
No.
There's no other support.
It's just me.
It really is.
Oh boy!
That's the funny part, Doki!
What other support?
I was confused a little bit.
I will have to sit.
well our one support all is gone now oh that's huge that
really is huge it's okay I can rebuild this guys I can I can
rebuild this guys just believe in me believe in your one
support I think our Punisher is now throwing I think our
Punisher DC'd wait the enemy someone CC'd on the enemy too!
Oh, he's back!
He's back!
Oh no.
Wait, wait, my other support!
My other support is back!
There is another support!
Whoa!
Wow!
You're alive!
Oh my god!
Guan Guan saw me playing D-Gen Hours!
I fucking do it!
It's the D-JQs coming in clutch!
It's actually the D-JQs coming in clutch!
I've been rewarded!
Okay.
I'm gonna say...
I cannot first.
I said it.
the most timid voice because i don't want them to yell at me
whoa oh
i didn't want them to yell at me so i said it in a very sad
voice so maybe they'll pity me like maybe they'll pity me
gone gone said I know you've been going through a lot okay
we did not need to use that Luna of those so I'm a little
worried now oh no he's back please that's
huge that's huge that's so
he's not you he's you're horrid at the video game who's
who's above who fucking horrible players you're we won
because there he got he saw he saw where what i've been
going through the morning and night yeah do you guys want to
know what because the loki was the one
I'm back, baby.
I'm back.
The Loki was the one that DC'd.
The raid boss test is dead.
The raid boss fucking...
They took the raid boss down.
Don't worry.
The raid boss down.
Let's go.
Yeah, the one that held their team together.
Where the Twitch from?
Thank you.
There's hope.
Guys.
See, there's hope.
I told you.
The D-Gen Qs are my town.
They're my territory.
Yeah, focus.
I took that Loki out.
IRL.
That's like, give me back my Elo.
You don't need it as much as me right now.
Actually, I don't need it either.
I'm just taking it for fun.
I also don't need it.
This is it.
Taking Elo.
I'm taking it back.
Taking it all back.
Exactly.
Bob.
Fuck!
Vibes are gone.
Words go.
Well, my vibes aren't gone, but the words.
Can't say vibe no more.
some people will start memeing it even though it's my
favorite word
i'm so sad took away my favorite word and he took he took it
away chill chilling his back it's not the same guys it's not
the same It
was my favorite word before they ruined it.
It was one of my favorite words.
We abandoned this.
Now it's gone.
Never mind, I don't care anymore.
What happened?
Never mind, I don't care no more.
Are you fighting?
No.
Alright.
What fucking can I play?
Oh, Phoenix is bad.
Well, Phoenix is bad, so I might as well.
You know?
Makes sense.
Okay, I'll I go actually cloak only because that Cloak is
just so strong.
No.
She's actually so fucking strong.
Pushing was.
I mean, the counter was reset.
No, not yet.
Not yet.
All right.
Two, one, three.
All right, here we go.
Yay.
I feel like this is the most I've streamed on Twitch the
last week, which is like two whole streets.
It's truly the most I've streamed on Twitch, guys.
Oh, they have mag.
Okay.
There we go.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
He fucking...
He jumped away from me and I got scared.
Yeah.
I don't...
know you saw the impus just walked walked away from me and
i'm like i got really scared guys i thought i thought i was
gonna i thought they were they forgot about me i think they
actually did not gonna lie they definitely oh no oh no we
created a monster what do you mean by that dokey Guys,
they're on triples.
We went triple support.
They went triple support.
We created a monster.
Oh, no.
They're going two, one, three.
Now it's two, one, three.
Holy shit.
Who's gonna fucking kill that?
Oh, time did run.
I mean, I could.
Oh, no.
That's unlucky.
That's very unlucky.
Okay, well, now we know.
Now.
Okay.
There we go.
It worked out.
the end it worked out in the end we needed those two us to
kill people it worked out it really did surprisingly it
really did work out not that though not that okay it's fine
okay all right okay i can i'll second i'm like can you go
mag after you all
typed it.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, my.
Why are you standing in the square of death, guys?
Why are you?
See?
It's too orange!
It's too orange, guys.
Dude.
It's just...
It's just too fucking orange.
I told you all.
They couldn't see it.
Me next.
I did second.
I said me second.
Alright, Invis first.
his first oh okay never mind me not next i guess
where was that the moon haunts you my god i guess me not
next
i did not see that uh
Are we...
Oh!
Not... No longer...
Two... One... No longer!
Three!
Support!
Can you please go, Mahaga?
I don't think he's gonna go Mag.
Just don't... Don't explode if he doesn't want to play Mag.
Just don't... Don't get angry.
Please don't get angry.
Just...
It is what it is.
Don't... Don't get angry.
Oh.
Don't get angry, guys.
Don't.
Don't get angry.
It is what it is.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Where's my tank?
Oh, shit.
Is my tank gonna be okay?
She got well done.
Oh, no.
Don't get angry, guys.
It's still winnable.
Don't get, he has been walling people off.
I will sit.
I think we can combine Mantis and I'm an altman.
I am Groot.
Like so hard.
Do you want to alt Mantis?
Where is he?
Oh my god.
I was like, where is he?
I was so...
I got...
Oh, we did not need that for shit.
Oh my...
We could have used that on the last fight!
Wait, so what did we get in Bizzou?
Oh, not me!
Not me!
Right side, we have Coco.
Come on, right side, we have Coco.
Not me!
Can we get it?
They have a storm bolt coming off and he's gonna die.
Whoa!
Here.
I might be dead, though.
Yeah.
Hey, I'm Ace!
I'm Ace!
Oh!
Yeah!
Okay, I'm coming off.
I'm very slowly coming.
Oh, this is...
Oh, that's it.
Oh!
Oh, my ace got taken, duh.
Not my fuss.
In the end, I was not playing for anything.
It's...
We gotta reset, reset the clock.
We gotta reset it.
set the timer we have we have to reset it again
it helps me see the darkness and face it
not me not me was it me
i didn't do nothing It's alright, they give it to your one
son, they give thank you.
I was in the problem!
The battle starts in five, four, three, three, three.
Oh, I used that because I was gonna do a sick ass let fade
from the grab and then it's gonna grab my teammates instead.
I imagine.
See look at that sick ass.
I didn't fade it though, but Almost where it
Don't worry.
Oh man, maybe worry a little bit.
I got you
All right I don't know if I should talk All
right here oh god oh my god I'm fucking so good at this
video game are you next to me next in this in this in this
in this in this in this oh we
save them save his life save his life
Save his life!
Oh my god, save my life, save my life, save my life.
It's okay, you don't need to save my life, my life no
matter.
My life don't matter.
I wasn't sure we get the lights out.
Oh my god, we're missing the triple support and triple.
Look at this walkback!
This walkback is crazy!
I want to say this is a fucking insane walkback in general.
I don't fucking believe in this walkback.
I swear to God, this walkback is insane compared to, like,
the other maps.
This feels longer, right?
Guys, I peg men 6-7 go first.
This, this feels, it feels longer, right?
I'm not fucking like dreaming right at how long this felt.
Okay, this is bad.
Like I'm not fucking dreaming right with how long this walk
back is.
Look, we are stalling like our fucking hearts out.
All right, we go ahead and make it through.
Yeah.
Definitely longer than any of the other maps.
I feel- the moment we walked back, the car was already
halfway.
Like almost- it was already at the point.
No, I hate this map.
Like, I swear- I swear to God this shit is like-
Alright, nice.
That's cool.
Oh wait, that's not what I wanted to do.
all
right we gotta go over now we oh we gotta go over now oh my
god they went back to triplet it's the fight of the triplets
apart who will win
they're going for group combos now group me
You can go first, Invis.
Oh my!
I said Invis first, so if she doesn't do it, that's on her.
Manta...
He's looking for it, he's looking for it, he's looking for
it here.
Oh,
I fucked it up.
Just fight.
I'm doing it.
I fucking knew it too.
Oh my god, I fucking knew it.
I knew it was gonna happen.
That's right!
That's got game sense, bitch!
That's got game sense!
Oh my god, I'll save you.
I'll save you, my queen.
Okay, but like, I swear to God.
Okay, that's...
That's on you for...
That's...
Okay, she was stupid.
I don't know why she...
Not my fault.
Actually, no.
not my fault.
Actually, she was 1 HP and she fully committed that.
That is not my fault at all.
I'm trying to try my best.
I'm trying my best.
I'm so dead.
I died for him.
I died for this guy.
I died for this man.
I had like really good positioning.
I'll let him build up.
Whoa.
Oh man.
Um...
You know what I was saying?
Quarter attempt.
I think if I didn't die for our, if I didn't die for our
Invis, or like for our Hella, we could have won that.
Never save your DPS.
Yeah.
Why do I sound scared?
It's because I want people to pity me.
Surprisingly, people don't want to yell at someone that
sounds sad on mic.
Not, no, let me be more specific.
People don't want to yell at a girl that sounds sad on the
mic, which I've noticed.
So I'm trying to farm the empathy so that they don't yell at
me.
for for now
and i'm sad maxing and my god she's a genius so how are you
real so if i when i do call us if if i sound sadder and or
like more if i if i sound sad and not confident they will
they would pity they would pity me more and then i won't get
yelled at
well i had to coordinate all stuff because i'm um i double
ulted with my mantis last time
But it's okay.
Surprisingly, I will say, surprisingly though, people have
got, even though this game, people were a little toxic.
Surprisingly, people got a bit nicer.
Got a bit nicer.
So, my theory was technically correct regarding the Gen Qs.
No, it doesn't.
People, they got, they were being a little toxic there.
yeah everyone is fine oh god whoa my gosh that my voice
there oh my god my voice got up there but surprisingly all
the students and the little ones have finally went to bed so
now the cues are just are more stabilized yeah i know i'm
sorry my voice changer malfunctioned and it's fine.
It's back on.
Sorry.
That was just my voice changer fucked up a little.
But it's okay.
It's back on now.
That was just like, you know, static.
You know when the machine stops working?
No, it's not the real voice.
It's like, you know when the machine...
What the... Okay.
You know when the machine stops working?
I mean, I could play Loki if you want to play, too.
Like, play.
Oh, okay, never mind, I guess not.
Okay, um...
Yeah, that's like when...
When the machine starts malfunctioning and it goes like the
static crunch, yeah, that's it.
The static crunch thing.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
Alright.
all right here we go what the fuck if i want to play this i
would have paid oh my god i'll pay zoki actually yeah i mean
this works too yeah suit jeff mantis that works i would play
rocket oh triple support tab
what oh strange is that again i mean okay
oh my what happened to my team what what happened to my team
oh that's what happened oh my god i see him we have a mag we
have a mag luckily they made it halfway stop them why me i'm
not gonna peek
yeah i was gonna say i'm not i'm not peaking that i'm not
i'm actually have to go rocket there's no way i'm playing
cooking against this i'm not playing sue against this this
is like up is someone else touching the point because it's
definitely not oh we can't actually do anything all right
yeah I mean I can oh
oh nice yeah I saved your life you're welcome oh my god he
wanted us to beat him oh my god please I'll go first.
I'll go first.
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, that's fine.
Okay, that was it.
Should
be fine, right?
Too many of us.
Too many of us to fucking do defensively.
Like, I don't know what there's not enough.
Not enough for us for the amount of dps us we're going
through this neutral fight sucks
oh he's dead i say guys technically it's a win because
nobody is flaming
technically we haven't had anyone flame each other yet Our
only DPS is O3.
Our only DPS is O3 right now.
Don't worry, I got you.
Don't worry, I believe in you.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
I really do.
Oh my, I really do believe in you.
Oh my god, did you like that pull?
That pull, and we didn't kill him.
Oh my god, that was a sexy pull.
That was a sexy ass pull.
And we did nothing.
By the eye of Agumoto.
Disappear.
Wait, are you...
Okay, I was gonna say, I thought we agreed.
I thought we agreed.
This is real firepower.
there we go I'm not fucking wasting this all they have like
20 more ults I have to worry about right now like I'm not
I'm not matching that shit they literally have 20 ults I
have to give a fuck about
all right I need to have our supports build up I don't see
Jeff and Mantis as a double support out only because like
Jepholt is so weak supporting wise I don't find Jepholt very
supportive in general I have to use this this is best prayer
when you're in the invis when when they mock uh mox you all
when they you know when they hawk guy oh I don't know
whenever I see a hawk guy I'm like
hot guys okay come on my pulls have been on fucking point
today look at that my pulls have actually been so fucking on
point it's crazy i
don't want to heal too much but i'm worried about the hot
guys i'm backing up
okay that was scary
Oh my god, Jeff is a controller player.
Oh, they don't know which one is me.
Haha, they don't know which way I rotate it now.
Oh, yeah.
Alright, that was close.
Alright.
Alright, I should let them heal now.
Oh, no.
Alright, nice.
Oh, I can peek now.
I can peek!
I can look now!
There's no point in me healing.
gotta i don't need heal if it's like i'm just oh no hawka we
can guys it's possible no more hawka
oh my god i'm just chilling you see what i'm doing i'm just
chill i'm just letting her matter i don't need to do
anything technically y'all want to hide y'all want not him
though not him oh my god
Goodbye I had a feeling I was about to run away.
I I was about to run away
Yeah Oh, why are you hitting me for?
Oh, no.
Oh, no, there was nothing I could do the current score is
zero two three time to switch things counterplay we play
cloak but you'll need a top in this stronger there is a way
as you play cloak that's literally it i guess i'll go cloak
can go do a support with Jeff and Cloak.
Cloak also is possible.
As long as they don't hit the alt.
That's the thing.
As long as they don't hit it.
Alright, here we go.
You can stack it, but it's not really a good investment to
stack it.
In overall, but...
But cloak does work if they none of no one shoots the all if
no one shoots it will be fine That's just that you know in
the perfect world and a perfect world
Wait, why are we on storm?
Hey guys, there's a there's group walls there's name more
there's I Guys, I would like someone to hit one.
I'm going to be here.
There's, like, a Neymar behind us.
And, oh, it hit him just there.
Oh, my God.
Thanks, Sayu.
Thanks for seeing me.
Oh, my God.
He's...
You're in the...
Oh, no.
No.
I...
I don't know if this is...
Guys, guys.
Oh my god.
Guys, there is a positive to this.
And nobody is toxic right now.
If you think about it.
There is...
The positive is...
Technically...
No one is toxic, so I count those.
I You can count I think you can count that honestly I think
you can actually Count that
Alright Sure I don't know when to go But sure
Guys I want to Okay Did he Yeah
Oh, all right, I'll take this.
That works.
That works?
It works.
I saw him go.
He thought he could get away from me.
Red like a fucking fuck.
pro tournaments and I'm so tired oh no they got kidnapped oh
god damn it I almost got oh yeah oh goodbye everybody I
can't do anything about it my damage is so week all right
with that portal wait they're on triple support those
fuckers oh i'm so sorry i didn't know i was on cloak i'm so
sorry oh i'm so sorry why don't we just walk that
oh my god
oh i need him to know that i can't stop that unless i knew
he was gonna shoot his unc on you like he has to know that
like i i i oh my god he actually missed him wait Wait, we
have to play longer.
Oh, no.
No.
Yes.
Now we can't even pull it back, though.
Now we can't.
Oh, no.
No.
No, I didn't think it was where my...
I don't even know who to...
Oh, I think it's Sasswax.
I think we know who to avoid, though.
Oh, no.
That's fine.
It's fine.
We don't have to play longer on an unwinnable game.
Wait.
We don't have to play longer in an unwinnable game.
That's crazy.
We never went Punisher.
for the group or was that's a plus oh i'm at the edge let's
go hanging by the thread all right wait who else i avoiding
okay uh this guy mr hero man wait this guy's a support
player wait this guy's highest rank is it's celestial three
we are he's at his peak i'm let me see who you're playing
with let me see your fucking clan that's right i'm shaming
your clan too i'm now your clan knows of what you've done
i'm living on the edge oh my god i've been playing nine
hours oh eight hours i'm sorry guys i have a I have a
rival's problem.
I...
We know.
I'm sorry.
I don't know how to stop.
I
need an intervention.
I really do.
Set one clue.
got chilled guys guys you can calm down calm down everyone
calm down we don't have to go that far first step close the
guys calm down calm down we don't need to go that far i'm
not the type who fades quietly into the background Who
am I going to banish from this match?
Yeah.
Alright.
Let me disassociate real quick.
Look at the meat.
And then I'm ready.
You know what?
I think it's time.
Since it's D-Gen hours.
Guys.
I'm about to put on my jammies.
your hero or
uh gambit's through gg oh no gambit and loki and we have a
rock god yeah okay it's i can go gambit if you can take i am
loki i will go loki if someone wants to go yeah do you play
gambit rock did you play tank
I think rock the Lord plus plus rocket plays rocket
The Lord plus plus rocket I This is the you know what this
is the game.
I deserve to do rank on honestly Honestly
This is this is this is the game.
I deserve to get D rank on No, you don't stop.
But, I mean, it's fine.
They have a moon that we don't have.
Oh, my God.
They're just going to use the combo.
You're so lucky.
I saved one more card for you.
Oh, my God.
And then they're running triple.
They want to win so bad.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
I have to reload.
Can any of us touch point?
Yeah, we can.
Stop healing.
Stop.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Don't stop.
Actually, don't stop.
Actually, do not stop healing.
That was my bad.
That was actually my bad for suggesting that.
Oh
Does he is he get res or not?
Should we go in without it?
Let's fucking go in without him.
Fuck it That's all right I realized that made me All right,
we got one support out One support is out All right
Okay They really went Triple support Loki, Gambit, Medica.
Why am I not on that team?
I could have been their Loki player.
I could have been their Gambit player.
I could have even been their club player.
And nobody wants to play Loki.
You know, they could even play Gambit.
it.
You know, you know what's fun to play?
Oh, ready, you guys?
Yeah, but never bust!
No, we could, like, literally burst that.
Oh, my God.
And all we have is rocket.
Lord, plus, plus, plus, rocket.
Yeah, but now we're going...
The thing is, it doesn't matter.
You don't!
You can't even play Loki!
Oh my, oh my, they do have a moon night.
They do have a moon night, though.
They do have a moon night.
We can't.
We have one tank, though, for this, which is not ideal.
Oh my god, I think he's dead, guys.
I think he's dead.
I don't I don't think so I you know like I cope a lot but
even even then even then I feel like even then I think this
is actually uncopable I think I don't think you can even
cope on something like this I mean I can low here
Does he not play Loki?
Loki is not that hard, buddy.
You fucking put drones and then you...
No, no.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission.
We need some kills.
Ha ha ha!
That's crazy.
That's actually insane.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I need one more.
I need one
more.
All right.
We have one more Gambit never follows if you want to.
Oh, we don't need to use it.
We don't need it.
We actually...
No, no, no, no!
All right.
All right, whatever.
We lost the alt rotation, though.
We might have lost the alt rotation, which is what I'm
afraid of.
We might have lost the alt rotation.
We maybe...
Oh no.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Oh my...
No, I'm fucked up!
Hey, JK, second life, second life, second life, second life,
second life, second life, second life, second life.
Second life.
Guys, I really...
I'm sorry, but I...
I need you guys to stop healing for me.
Okay.
why oh oh my okay we lost the alt rotation
okay now we lost the alt rotation i
okay Gambit first always No, please don't blame me It's the
rocket, come on It's the rocket You always do gambit first
It's the law It's, oh my god Okay, I'm letting my low key
here It's the fucking gambit law
It's literally gambit law
It's literally gambit law Oh my god
Please please look I'm right.
Oh my god the Loki just looked at me Yeah, it never falls We
folded it It's the support laws I'm like oh my whatever I'm
letting me rock it out first I'm letting yeah, it's all
anyway.
Yeah, it's all first The thing is he keeps healing even when
he has all he's not supposed to do that I don't have a oh my
god and then the rocket dies oh my and then the rocket dies
okay me oh my god fuck me first let me off first let me I
said me first I said I said me first.
No, no, no, no, no.
I...
Did I not say...
Okay, I said me first.
I...
Did I...
Did I not say me first?
I'm like...
Rocket...
Yeah.
It's a sign.
He was like, yeah.
Yeah.
Bro Like he's like No, no, no Reset Oh my Yes Alright, back
to the mines Wait, 248.dash 248.dash Alright, that makes
sense Back to Here I was like
Help Help you Gamp it all first Gamp it always first When
did it?
It never stopped being No, he didn't admit it The rest of
our team admitted it The rest of our team was like Oh was
just in awe.
I'm just like, I swear to God.
We all saw it, right?
I swear to God, we all saw it.
But even then, it doesn't even need to be verbalized that
Gambit Hulk first.
It doesn't even need to be a verbalized.
thing.
It's just, it's like, it's like, it's like, why it's gamut
first?
Because gamut first builds all for the team.
And it's so aggressive.
It's such a, because gamut first is because when you gamut
all, you gamut all, you can, there's, you most likely can
just win the entire fight with just gambit all you don't
have to use anything else yeah you take space you aggress
and then it helps your entire team builds all so if you just
use gambit all you already set the you set the pace of the
fight and then if they fight back and the gambit all isn't
working use you throw in the other all yeah the other
support all is like the backup yeah it doesn't matter It's
more so of like Gambit Alt first because you can clean up
the entire fight with just Gambit Alt.
If you use a Rocket Alt, you have to use a second Alt.
Why am I crying so much?
I unfortunately had a very special player last game.
But now that he's gone, we can go back to our usual face.
Also, I just realized I had to swap stuff.
around real quick if I want to use this skin suit
all right here you go there yeah now I can do this oh that's
too much too close But that kind of violence isn't really my
style.
Okay.
Wait, day 10 hours.
Which means...
Which means it's this time.
It's baby time.
Oh my god.
Our food.
Oh!
that oh my god um i don't want it
i'll be back come back
oh my god what is that like oh no i did have a second fall
oh great
What?
Oh no.
Oh, I just almost made it.
I just almost made it.
Yes!
No, I agree.
I agree.
Don't you gonna see me again?
Oh my god.
That rocket does not deserve my elo.
That...
That rocket really does not deserve my elo.
Oh my god, I wish we had.
No, it's not the Angela.
It's literally...
He gets Bucky pulled.
He doesn't deserve my elo.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, there he is.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry, Hakka.
He wanted to pull me.
I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
It was me or you, buddy.
It was me or you.
Oh my god, I'm so...
They're not big to me!
It was weird.
Oh my god,
I got it the wrong way there.
Oh my god, I'm sorry!
I will say I'm gonna say it again this rocket does not
deserve my elo he really does not
I'm gonna say it
That's got it.
That was a sick-ass pull that I did.
Did he did he do it?
Okay, I hope he builds all in time because
What the fuck the fuck the clock fucking died?
Okay, I really need you to build up right now.
I'm letting you build up Like as fast as I can look at that.
I'm being a very smart player
oh no oh no I made it got you I fucking made it wait why did
he fight outside of us why did he fight outside of us though
I don't know why you
fell far outside of them but okay oh please i should need up
please please please please i really need up please please
please fight here
guys there's an emma on point guys looking at him if i can
Can we?
Alright.
Nice, nice.
A nice dagger.
Alright, alright.
Build up, build up, build up.
Build up, build up.
Build up, cook.
I'm letting you do it.
Oh no.
Last side, strongly last side.
No!
You just lose that.
I just got...
Wait, why am I still alive?
Okay.
No!
He was dead!
He just needed to kite it!
If he kite it, it would work!
Better stop that vehicle!
all right he has all i don't think this this club would give
me the same etiquette of like letting me build alt and i
legitimately like the only reason why i know that is oh oh
oh my god
i'm pulling him in oh let's hope
Oh That's unlucky.
I honestly think I'm still need another inch.
Can I suck?
What does he play?
All right
We got that guy.
Oh no, they risked.
I healed as much as I could.
Time to switch things up.
Including which side you're on.
Oh, man.
I...
You know...
What does he even play?
Just run triple
Just triple support
All right, I'm not the type who fades clearly into the
background All right, we're doing this.
I run mantis.
Oh my god, it was a He's a rat player
Was a rat player Life energy is a powerful weapon.
I have to play Mantis.
We're running triple.
Is I a Mantis?
Oh, we don't have a Loki.
If we had a Loki, I would run Adam, but we don't.
Mantis Peaches put Klintar on top of the list.
Oh my god.
I will say that Raccoon does not deserve my Elo.
I don't care.
Usually I don't care where my Elo goes to, but this Raccoon
in particular does not deserve my Elo.
The battle starts in five.
Careful that Angel pulled outside her.
Or she's probably gonna pull from right side to left.
Alright.
I need to like...
It's so hard to hit right here.
Oh, what the fuck?
oh my god someone save him somebody save him i like six oh
nice someone did
oh my god somebody save him again i cannot heal that i'm
sorry but i cannot heal that all right well we have two out
yeah i'm back to hating I'm back to hating.
I'm back to hating rats.
Oh, there we go.
That easy.
No res too, by the way.
There we go.
Am I?
We got this.
All right, there you go.
Bro, oh my god, that's illegal.
He's getting healed or some shit.
All right, here we go.
Whoa, that all fucking sucks, to be fair.
Oh, what?
Okay.
Oh, my God, we are alone.
All right.
All right, me next.
Solid behind, solid behind, solid behind.
There we go.
I'm dead.
All right, here we go.
Oh, my God.
I'm alive.
Oh my God!
What the fuck is their hella doing?
He just ran in the middle of four of us.
To kill me!
I was so low!
He doesn't know.
I was literally...
No, their hell is actually like...
I feel like both of you guys just walk out randomly.
He literally...
He was literally...
He saw me.
And blood.
Whoa.
he saw me for sure so I need damage boost my DPS too there
you go there you go my back we kite we kite we kite we kite
we kite we kite we kite we don't have to fight this I don't
know if you guys know how fucking far that all is maybe
counter-all now maybe counter-all now there we go oh never
there we go i was saying that before he instantly killed too
well lucky that was chill i mean we didn't think we didn't
know we were gonna do that to be fair find this dog be fair
we didn't know that was gonna happen oh my god why is this
here i know where the rangers don't unvenom
all right all right let's follow
oh give me in here give me in here get me in here where is
it get me in here
hello one hello one hello one is he
oh my god I can't help this there's so much there we go oh
my god what's going on
what the fuck is going on
come on
It's BND dead.
Please!
Oh my god!
Oh no.
That's bad.
See that?
What the?
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Nice.
It never ends!
Wait.
There we go.
I'm like, what the fuck is going on?
What's going on right now?
I can't give you another one, bro.
That's on you.
He hit 20 headshots, buddy.
That man hit 20 headshots, and I gave you all the heals
possible to survive that.
That's honestly on you.
Oh!
Those
There we go There we go
Oh my
I swear to god, you better live Oh my god, I swear hello,
hello, that is a hell Hella!
You had!
So much pocket!
Hella!
Hella, please!
Oh my god, Hella!
Hello!
Round 3!
Go!
And still destroy them.
Oh my god.
My brother.
Hello.
Hey.
We all saw what you did.
Hello.
We all saw.
It was caught on 4k.
Hello.
then lately
The fact that we all saw
I hear There
we go Shit.
Awful, by the way.
I didn't realize they were on group.
Right here.
I'm trying like...
I already used my leaves, which is a little scary.
Okay, I need to make sure.
in like there you go
he messed up he fucked up
oh my
judge jury i said fun right time i should just get this i
don't have old let's go let's go good old
I can't tell what's going on there's so much there's
actually so much shit on my screen
that Groot has a oh my god okay
oh no this is bad it's actually pretty bad now for us we
have nothing
oh my god thank god
oh my god we're dead here no no we just
we couldn't kill anything
we literally need to kill we had no damage i literally
killed two people but we had no Damage.
Oh, here's our weapon.
I get a good mag up then.
Look, we have to use that.
We have to.
We have to utilize that.
Just walk forward, walk forward, walk forward.
Yeah, we need a walk forward, creeps, bro.
Oh my god, I almost killed him too.
I'm so sad.
I actually almost killed him.
We were so close.
Okay, where's he?
Where's he?
I damaged whose head?
Is that?
You did.
You ready for it?
Just one day.
They call me Dr. LeBron.
Oh my god!
Why wouldn't the Groot die?
Time to switch things up.
I wouldn't the Groot die.
That is just so much shit on my screen.
There was way too much i need to get water i need i need to
get water
30 seconds before you attack get ready
okay i'm back calm down a little bit after that that
okay all right i'm calm
this is not what i wanted to damage but
oh you get rose doesn't matter at least he doesn't have rose
you know i got there running triple they're running triple
okay i don't know who i am fucking
bro we that tree is taking oh my god i was so mad all i hear
is think that's all i hear oh my god that tree
This is real firepower Nice nice big they doubled and they
use uh no guilt.
I think No, this is so so winnable we'll get such battles No
guilt Oh here Oh, nice nice nice nice Okay, there's
something here.
Oh my god!
Go straight, go straight, go straight.
Okay.
Your car.
Oh, you should lock it.
I swear to god, I'm out of here.
There, there, there, there, there, there, there, there,
there, there.
How are you?
Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding.
High key.
They have to touch.
Nice, just go point.
Just go point.
Everyone just go point.
Nice.
Just go point.
Loki on point.
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
Just go point.
Nice.
oh my god that's all i hear that's all i hear in my head no
elo for you you rat no elo
let's go
every time i close my eyes i hear it i fucking hear it i I
can hear it.
You're not getting Elo from me.
Oh my god.
Winning out of spite.
I'm glad it's over.
Bro, their entire team was like, everybody on their team has
played support somehow look at this wait same with me oh
wait but Groot has Groot Wallace yeah but like everyone else
has had holy shit like this they're like this ain't working
except for this guy this guy knew what he wanted to play
this guy this guy everyone nope okay he obviously he's the
rocket one trick but everyone else was like what the fuck do
he Oh my god.
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
I closed my eyes and I can still hear it.
I can still fucking hear it.
If Doppler, they even kept giving us up to...
Ding, ding, ding, ding.
Thank you.
They deserve that, L.
I'm not...
You ain't taking my E-Lo today.
If...
He is the one rat that doesn't deserve this.
he hits that rat oh my god they had a 15 kill streak i mean
it was not that hard they had no damage this team had no
fucking damage like like this fucking team literally their
star lord was shit i'm sorry bro i'm sorry but bro i wasn't
even like like that wasn't even me at 100 at mantis too
Like, I was whiffing shots.
It does crazy.
That's crazy.
Oh.
Man.
What a game.
That, you know, at first it was, it looked quite loosable.
And then we went triple support.
And this is why I was like, we should have had bands, guys,
during the show match.
I forgot about.
I forgot.
I was like, wait a minute.
Alright.
Hi.
Oops.
I'll get me in Loki.
I'm ready.
we bet game it
i need to disassociate after that game guys that i'm that
game
yeah i need a moment i had to lock it i need a moment after
that
I feel like I felt like it's going fucking crazy hearing all
those dings.
I'll be strong, run it.
All right.
I'm ready.
All right, here we go.
What if I play cloak?
I think I deserve that, right?
25 you know what i deserve kill i deserve the chill there's
no tree i'd rather see i deserve this i deserve to not aim i
realized after having to aim on mantis i deserve this i
deserve auto aim battle starts in five three two one do is
capture the mission area got it I deserve auto him
Ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding Every
time I close my eyes Okay,
I'm not no fucking no crap Oh Doing strange Nightball
nightball nightball nightball nightball wall whoops whoa
that's awkward that's awkward oh my god that's a heel pool
oh my god they have Malik oh my god where do I go where do I
go when I uh I have to swap I actually have to go Loki.
I have...
Pregnable bubble.
Where's the Loki?
What are we planning on going yet?
Alright.
You cannot finish.
You cannot first.
Oh my god, I'm sure one X.
Spidey, that stream was bloody as fuck, bro.
See, I told you.
And it's sick.
BAM!
Oh.
I...
Look, um...
I don't know how they all died through it.
How did they all die through it?
I'm dead.
Oh.
Phoenix slash.
I like what I'm asking.
How did they all...
who what the fuck what kind of damage was that it was just
you yeah it's not that much better I was surprised oh my
gosh I was gonna I was gonna play oh I have to play Loki I
forgot about that I got two I was like I got two like
shocked I was like how the fuck did they all got that oh my
god oh you're like so surprised and then you're just like
how i'm kiting that goodbye my goodbye buddy i really want
to swap that oh no by the eye of
All right, here we go.
Oh, here we knock go.
I don't think we need it.
Oh my god, buddy.
All right.
That seems like a waste in general.
I'm just going to use mine here probably to walk in.
Oh, good man, I got it.
That depends.
I mean, okay.
for fun oh we oh oh we did not need that um oh
is there anyone in me that's zoning out zoning up
You can fight them in main fight them in main here.
They're down the healer They're down.
Sorry, healer.
They're all TP.
They're all TPing.
Can I grab a bubble for me?
Oh, yeah, yeah, I got two Oh, you're getting cold y'all who
kills amazing.
Hello, I did not mean to do that.
Hello Nice Jenny Phoenix Her Phoenix is so fast.
Oh my god, please do not let me go.
Let me die.
Unless.
I lost 7 or 10 placement matches and I'm crashing up.
That's on you.
You know what day it is today.
You know it's a Sunday.
That's on you.
You could have chose any other day to play placements.
You could have chose any other day.
Yeah, but.
25 time.
Not on West Coast.
Still 11.55.
Still 11.55 here.
Mocha, thank you for the Twitch private.
Thank you.
Yeah, but there's no way.
There's no way.
7-10 games?
He queued during the Sunday.
He queued during the Sunday, guys.
He queued when it was Sunday.
There we go.
Oh.
That's awkward.
That's very awkward.
We don't really have anything.
Oh, we still don't really have...
Did anyone clip it?
Oh.
It's all right.
We didn't have anything.
You know, they they used two us guys.
That's fine They used two us they used two us.
That's a trade
That's a trade I'm willing to make We used nothing they used
two us we pour we not pour no now they pour now they pour
Whoa Now me scared.
Jesus.
Well, these are one of those moments where I wish I had a
rocket up because this shit is scared.
I might be dead.
Okay.
I mean, that would have, that would have just hit it.
I think they're saying to you.
Welcome to the scene, Diego.
Okay.
Who was he trying?
Hello?
No, guys.
Alright, we don't have up, though, so...
That's the only...
We have... Oh my god!
We used everything!
Hahaha!
Oh, that's not good.
I want to use this somewhere else, but I guess not.
See you, Marcel, sorry.
That's not your fault, bro.
Okay, if you peek me, if you peek me, if you peek me, if you
want.
It's okay.
We got one of those back.
I have to kill Connor first.
We're gonna have to free all of them.
There we go.
We have to use both of us again
Okay Okay, so We have no else again.
We have I repeat.
We have no else again What?
No, no, no, we'll take it.
We'll take it.
Trust in the value.
Trust in the value of that all Hey, just kill the pun kill
the pun.
Oh my god, I'm getting killed
Um, I do want to know why do we?
Oh, no.
I don't think you can hold this around like three.
All right.
So why do we all stare at the alt?
Why do we all, I am a little worried that we all just stared
at it instead of coming back.
Like, we could have came back the point.
They're like, don't worry, clearly their team is definitely
not gonna respond or anything.
Do you want to go?
I'm off angle as well.
I don't know what was like the plan there.
There you go.
That shit will catch its deepest fuck
Oh my god, that's so
Why do they have an iron mesh?
Yeah!
I actually pumped my fist up after that Oh my god, I'm such
a nerd I'm such a fucking nerd I actually I pumped my fist
up for the Like, you know, like the one-piece pose where
Luffy is like, yeah, I literally just did that.
God damn, I'm such a fucking nerd.
I gotta avoid you.
Oh my god.
Wait, not Marcel.
This guy had three...
This guy was not real.
I'm pumping your fist at midnight during Marvel Rival's win.
I've sunk that low.
I've hit that point in my cues.
I really have.
Damn.
Rivals!
And then I shout out, rivals!
Ah.
Hydration is important, guys.
Gee, thank you for that.
Gifted some.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
To MVP, bird.
Alright, disassociation tab.
Dead game.
Bird game.
Game.
I ask and I receive.
Why is my team for the-
The only- No.
Me?
Rocket.
Please.
Oh wait, not Rogue.
What the fuck happened?
We want to rock it now.
We did so much.
I did so much.
Guys, did you see how...
Did you see how everyone is a lot nicer now?
You'll need a top-notch team to win this one.
Can I rock it?
you calling a raccoon oh no i know you could just say no i
don't really care but
not you know cosmic rays don't know you know what be the
change you want to be i'm not the type who fades quietly
what if they play phoenix huh
I lost on my adrenaline.
Fever change.
I'm like, wait, but what if they go Phoenix?
Wait, did they ban...
Oh my god, wait, they ban Phoenix!
Wait, they ban Phoenix, right?
I forgot, the chick!
One!
you have to stop them from securing the mission area it's
okay my third oh okay i go rocket it does not look like we
have a shield oh no i have to be wary of hawkeye and angela
okay that's not me i have to be aware of so many things that
i am i'm so scared right now like i oh
my god
where where and just not and hawk got
i don't know where the fuck he went hawk got to the left top
left top left ping
oh my god i don't want to play in biz into that there's more
of them than us i don't want to out there devil please like
it'd be so useful if i got him she's late don't try no our
back didn't stop so that's why we didn't get it what no what
your first time respawned it was two ticks already wouldn't
have had time uh i thought maybe i was expecting someone
else and that is you still this daredevil needs to swap off
oh no oh no there's an angel behind This is the easiest I've
team.
Don't get Hawkeye.
She got Hawkeye.
Can we get off Daredevil, please?
Like, for the love of God.
Oh my God, stop whining!
This man's not gonna give you Daredevil!
Stop crying!
Please, buddy.
You also look to calm our dives if we're going to die.
Okay, he is on VC.
I was going to...
End of the top right.
He died.
Fucking blows up.
He is going in my zone.
The moon haunts you.
He's just not going to swap.
Just flame him normally.
just it's just a 5v6 each fight I'm going rocket fuck this
fuck this I shouldn't go rocket it's technically a throw but
like why is he going in bro back up please back up okay I go
back to dude I wish I fucking a daredevil into this I don't
know why he's pushing me oh my god
He's still...
You're not gonna get him!
Just teach he go next!
It's never happening!
If he doesn't want to give you Daredevil, it's never gonna
happen!
That again?
No.
What the fuck is it?
I don't think he's gonna get...
He is shit.
He is dog shit.
I will say he is dog shit, but like what are we gonna do
about it?
Nothing Please bubble me, please.
Oh
Don't fight it.
Just let it happen.
I knew I spoke too soon, guys.
Guys, I knew I spoke too soon I was like oh it's nice it's
nice that my lobbies have been pretty nice so far okay you
can get on is he is he still is he still going on about is
he really still gonna go on about this man I want to let you
don't get there don't get hawkeye don't get hawkeye don't
get hawkeye don't get hawkeye don't get hawkeye don't get
hawkeye don't get hawkeye don't get hawkeye in 10 shut your
fucking bitch ass up sorry 3 and 11 you walk out of spawn in
fucking instant high I'm trying to make value because it's
fucking 5v6
that a myth fucking stalling that we're good though this is
nice kind of good
the back on the other back touch touch touch touch touch
wait did he the daredevil finally spoke back did the
daredevil finally speak time to switch things up including
which side you're on you'll need a top-notch team to win
this literally you're just going in 1v6 every time get the
Fuck off, Cap!
Yeah, what dives am I supposed to ping?
When every single time I walk out of spawn, you are fucking
dead.
You fucking...
He wants to say a slur.
He stopped himself.
He wanted a slur.
He really did.
He was this close.
Fuck you what?
today we're gonna play a game what slur did he want her to
save the daredevil but don't say in chat don't say in chat
just don't just don't don't say in chat though All of them.
I did not deserve minus 22 when I had this gal by deep.
Chat, don't answer that.
Just a little question.
Ah.
All right.
It's time to party.
Dead game.
I don't understand.
We're game.
Game where?
You think
you want to be today?
Okay.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
I play Rocket.
Rocket please.
Is High Guard active?
How do you check?
Players on Steam.
What is it like?
Steam charts.
All right.
High Guard.
What's the player blaze night like now?
Is it alive?
Hi, guys.
Ah.
Man, guys, I feel too bad.
I...
Guys, I don't even want to mention it.
Okay, wait.
Marvel drivers.
You'll need a top match team to win this one.
That's just too sad
Wait Apex legends.
Oh Man, I
Mean it's alive Thank God 19k over what sorry sorry that was
a little sweet that was just a little sweet
oh man i kind of like this oh yeah it goes and switch the
thing it's like i know why i didn't just go man just like
that no i checked overwatch too it's
it might be like pretty similar to how i got right now
overwatch but unless I read it wrong overwatch looked like
it had a similar player amount compared to compare the high
guard is yeah fab that's overwatch oh man they're doing a
fucking stupid-ass combo oh they have cap What the fuck?
Oh no, it's that.
Oh my god.
It's hard, dive.
Yeah, yeah.
Why did we give so much space?
For no reason.
We literally gave, like, so much space.
I'm fucking swapping the cloak.
They're going hard, dive.
I'm fucking not playing that shit.
is really just cat what the fuck like we do not need heal
pool what i was gonna say reset reset
we're not resetting guys not even it's just one oh my god i
might actually have to go i had to go this first
i'm gonna say we definitely don't I don't need...
Nope,
I'm dead.
I was already in too deep.
This wasn't even a daredevil that was complaining.
Guys I don't...
I think this is...
Can we get like some real things?
Yeah, I'm going in my door.
Thank you.
Hey guys, are we...
We're gonna...
Please, let me have...
Oh my god.
Wait, how does our Luna have 91?
He is so lucky I'm a gamer.
Oh my god, please.
Guys, I should have avoided the Luna as well.
I...
I should have avoided the Luna.
as well guys I yeah I this is I yeah yeah no no no it's not
sleep dive we can still it's salvageable it's salvageable
this is what I mean is so pretty and G, not gonna lie.
And we have, do we not have Nuno?
Yeah.
Like, wouldn't it be fucking cool if really we're gonna kill
Cat when they're free pushing the car for 20 years.
Alright, five minute dream home.
Don't worry.
This will head.
This will make it.
This did not make it
I don't even think I should even come anymore for this game.
I
Yeah All right Yeah Oh my god, you what it was so far from
us that like Oh, I need help There you go
Hey guys, are we all okay?
Oh, well not any guys.
Um, okay.
Okay, we backed up so, so far.
We, we backed up so far.
backed up so far i don't even know where our spawn is why do
we back up so far i'm sorry right sometimes it'd be like
that oh
not you though unfortunately not you though not me though
Can we?
Yeah, yeah, there we go.
Oh my god.
Look, I killed as much as I could.
The only thing I know is that I technically got more else
than our Luna.
Technically, If you think about it Okay, just fight in
there.
Why didn't you fight in there?
Please keep me up.
No!
I always just what?
Ah, you are Luna.
Time to switch things up, including which side you're- That
I will say You'll need a top-notch team if you need help you
don't have to play Luna oh thank God oh thank God she could
have done that in the beginning but oh thank God all I'm
saying she had the choice to not play Luna
but unfortunately free will is a thing It's very
unfortunate.
Very, very unfortunate.
Yay.
I just think, other than...
I'm very tired of seeing Moon Knight Groot.
I'm actually very...
Like, I feel like that has been, like, majority...
I hate this meta, actually.
Other than Dive, this meta fucking sucks.
Because there's no counterplay.
It's like Reaper bait.
There's literally, there's literally like no counterplay to
this.
I feel it.
Like other comp, like there's like other counterplay.
It's just literally just don't group up.
That's like the counterplay.
And I think that's just fucking stupid.
I just think there should be more counterplay.
I just don't like this current meta.
I feel like this meta could definitely be improved on.
Just not a fan.
I'm just not a fan.
Just because like, what can you do when they have the group
combo?
Really.
Just literally don't get hit.
Don't just don't get hit for it, you know?
Just don't get hit for it.
Well, let's hope he's a lap
Oh my god, here we go That should be ours, by the way
Wow Maybe it was easier Why the fuck is not on captain no
more They're pot right now Phoenix potting Oh, that's
unfortunate Oh that's unfortunate buddy
well don't worry we got this right oh there's the hot guy um
i don't want to push up
Are you gonna look this or me?
Because I don't really want to look this.
Maybe Doki Ultra?
Oh, hey, nice.
We did it.
Nice.
Here you go.
Yay!
Good ult.
Um, we used three ults.
Is it really good?
What the fuck?
Are they alive?
Oh, they are.
Oh, not him, though.
I think it doesn't make me easier.
We may be chasing everybody.
Why did we play this at first?
Wait a minute.
You mean we could have just played this?
As an Invis?
Wait, is there...
No Hawkeye, no Hawkeye, no Hawkeye.
Okay.
That's very ambitious.
Oh, he jumped forward.
Back up, back up, back up.
stay in there stay in this little bubble i gave us
oh man can we get him do we get him though we didn't get him
i mean
oh this is a bad neutral fight guys
guys how am i supposed to oh if you all keep dying on the
neutral up all right here we go okay like what the no it's
fine he's fucking his shit
i mean i'm oh oh
guys did you know there's another guys um did you know we
can go this way i don't think they realize
oh thanks please just kill him
all right um i think it's awkward that my team didn't
realize there was another door and we just kept congesting
into that one cubule i'm like hey guys hey guys
Oh my god.
Oh my god, you're fucking welcome!
Oh whatever.
Oh my god.
Is she alive?
He's not alive.
He's not.
But I think this is gone now.
Oh my god.
Please.
No.
Why are you still fighting?
Why are you trying to fight the bush?
I didn't.
Why did you try to fight the bush?
Why did she...
Her team would die!
I need a portal.
Oh my god, there's so many questions!
I have so many questions.
questions yet no somehow no answers to any of it back up
back up back
up do you go
where is he where is he oh
my gosh i went deeper actually i went deeper without oh
my i I can't do anything about that.
I can't do anything about that.
He got bubbles.
He actually got bubbles Oh my god Oh my god I don't I don't
I don't know
It's okay Chichi go next It's truly a...
G-G coat next.
I... We made it a lot further.
You're a tank player?
Oh, no.
I lose the rocket, though.
I have this.
Maybe... Maybe he doesn't come back.
Maybe the rocket doesn't come back.
That Vayna's been playing this game as long as I have.
I did.
I avoided.
I avoided it, but it's okay.
There's one thing that will make me feel better.
When will we stop?
Rivals is light.
Rivals is air.
Rivals is eternal.
Can't stop me.
My manager just messaged me and all he said was redacted
king are you okay with this redacted and i was like yeah
redacted it's okay tomorrow's my rest day so i'm not cooked
yet
Can I raccoon?
No, I'm defense.
I'm defense.
Oh my god, it's you.
That Valentina?
A border.
A borderline?
No, not in this, you know, they're not down here.
They know not to play, they know not to play play the pits
like me.
They know not to do that.
They're smarter.
Sorry, tomorrow.
No, it's not.
Shh.
No.
Third wind.
Oh, what the fuck is all of these talk on bed?
Can I rock it?
It'll be pretty me
So with all these Luna players God fucking god damn it It's
okay I can pull this off Wait It's okay We found Phoenix
It's time Some serious tech you're wearing there bump bump
bump bump bump bump bump bump bump bump bump bump bump we
bad phoenix i can
oh there he is he is he's looking for it oh he's looking for
it.
Don't be a shame if somebody got grabbed.
Are we still tanking?
Oh no.
I didn't think we were close.
He warned him.
He did warn him.
Oh.
Do I have to play?
Why do they have a real support
I can't keep you up forever, Luna.
I have to heal other people.
Oh, fuck.
Is
he catching my orbs?
Yeah, he is.
Oh, Hulk.
Hulk or Hulk?
Hulk.
hulk hulk oh hulk oh
i feel like the enemy team has a better comp than us but i
don't know what is up with
we're fine right good luck good luck good luck good luck
Good luck
No, I got him
What was I supposed to do?
Okay, I at least he's not a hulk anymore Who the fuck is
ballet?
Not Bro your support player never dual support
Oh my god, yes, I'm a homewrecker!
I mean, like, not like I wanna be, but I think...
On rivals, on rivals, on rivals.
I don't actually want to be a homewrecker.
On rivals, on rivals.
On...
Toke is a homewrecker.
On rivals, guys.
On rivals.
I don't actually mean that bro our Hulk needs to get the
fuck off it's not working not bad I mean it's like a funny
ha ha you know how it's like funny ha ha when you when I'm
like
I don't know how the fuck you didn't live there.
I just think it's funny.
Ha ha.
OK, guys, you know what I mean?
You know what I mean, right?
I hope we're all shooting that.
That's awkward for me, though.
It's really awkward.
That's why my frame has been so bad.
Oh, good shit.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, I'm like, fuck that.
What the fuck?
Where is our other guy?
Put it there.
You all know what I mean, right?
I don't mean it actually, you know?
I'm not...
I mean, okay.
I mean, he, like, fucked up, okay.
Let me ask my...
10 hours toky i'm great i'm doing great 10 hours still
getting content let's go oh come on really bucky no fun what
the fuck is going look at that i like how we swap that what
the that guy is so low i can tell you guys look That's
Spider-Man as long as I'm a little worried
But oh my god I died bro, okay
Shit he's so lucky My
turn What the fuck Okay Okay.
Okay, I did not mean to press shift.
I did not mean to press shift, but that's...
Oh my god, he's so lucky he's still alive.
Oh, fuck!
I was pressing F.
What about?
Alright, I'm coming over.
It's okay, I have my shift soon.
Oh, yo, don't be so...
No!
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
It's not.
No, no.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
He got the clothes.
He's got the clothes.
I'm sorry.
He's gonna get us.
Oh, we're live.
I don't take this.
Oh, never mind.
Wait, wait.
We did it.
Boy, no.
Somebody TP and hold.
Wait, Loki, you need a TP.
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna make it buddy
i fuck that up a little bit
i they didn't know they didn't know i was i don't think it
was you guys I will say even though if I go through that
portal I don't think it would have been winnable No, I don't
think I would have lived if I went through that portal.
I legitimately don't think so I think I would have I don't
think I would have built all the time I don't think I kept
my all okay, I kept
think that was gonna happen.
Nah, fuck, I did not want to do that.
Alright, I'm sad.
Fuck.
I don't know how to fucking play this character.
I'm so sad.
Oh my, I'm not fucking risked.
We lived, we lived, we lived, we lived, we lived, we lived,
we lived, we lived, we lived, we lived.
We lived.
I will say we lived, we lived, we lived.
Now I actually... Okay, I will admit, now I threw...
Now...
I threw that
Oh, what I will admit I will I'm sorry I am sorry I am so
sorry
Oh I think I have to go in this I don't think I can play I
don't think I can thing look you that legitimately why would
you waste that what guys
we gotta oh
yeah oh my god there you go he see not he see not he see not
okay okay i have to like open my third eye I had to open my
third eye for that.
You need a top-notch team to win this one.
I'm not the type who fades quietly into the background.
What do I...
What do I steal the duo?
All right.
As long as they're not a support player,
what if...
Imagine...
All right, I'll look at their profile.
If they are not a support player, I'll play.
I'm going to steal their duo just for the memes.
But guys, homewrecking is bad, but if you do it in-game,
it's pretty funny.
If you break up an E date, it's pretty funny.
not rock
true doing it for the fuck I'm an e-wrecker I am I'm an
e-wrecker okay that was a good ass fucking hold
oh my god bro this hug is like either he's feeding his ass
off where he does a good slay there's no in between it's one
or the other
oh i fucked up that blow
well i didn't die oh my god oh my he doesn't even know where
i am
oh my god of course the aug was one hit it's five will he
live there's 20 mines oh my god he's alive oh i'm
not gonna use it here
miss guys guys no no not loki not those not if we are
struggling no no no we are struggling
oh i don't know why i pulled that i that was a little silly
of me to do i will say That looks...
I should...
Oh.
You still got somebody?
Um...
There you go, that's fine.
My team...
Um...
I wanted to...
Oh, I wanted to...
I mean, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I...
How do they get more Moon Knight Alts than us?
Um, it would be pretty cool if we didn't have a hug.
Guys, I feel...
I... I don't know.
This isn't the time for a slow dance.
I think...
I don't know.
That's just my IMO.
She almost died.
Bye, everybody.
What?
Alright, Hulk.
You gonna...
Maybe.
Um...
I don't...
I don't know.
Dude, you're at just a point, you're just like...
Oh, there we go again!
Whoa.
Yeah, fuck this guy up.
Obviously.
We don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
There he is live.
Oh, we technically have no...
Um...
Let me out of here.
Oh, what the?
What hit me there?
Yeah, you want to know why?
We had...
We had a hook.
And...
Hulk and Loki
Why didn't you swap That's a good question Alright let's see
Let's see if they're actually doing or they're like Fucking
with me
Alright let's see I gotta know I gotta know
Alright god damn it i don't know if they're a support player
or not invisible okay okay invisible okay wait their duo was
this person god damn it how am i gonna investigate how okay
c r f n d s c r f n d s i will find your how do i Leave the
duo.
Okay, I'm going to friend them.
What role do you play?
I'm going to E-Rek.
No, it's not Homewrecker.
It's E-Rekker.
It's different.
I'm gonna break the duo I play support and flex tank leave
your duo
I'm a good
person I just broke I'm a good person I He says, they...
Okay, okay.
I need you to see this.
Can we play?
This was...
This person was never loyal in the first place.
No hesitation.
Left their due...
Zero hesitation.
Asked me to play with them.
And then the other guy was like, No, don't leave.
Don't leave.
And then zero hesitation came to me.
It was a test.
I was testing.
If you're seeing this right now, Nyla, that man chose bros
before hos.
Or hos before bros.
I don't fucking know.
Whatever it is.
That man didn't choose you.
Not up.
You're welcome.
You're fucking welcome.
Now you know.
It ain't worth it.
That guy ain't loyal.
They're willing to drop you so quickly.
Guy ain't loyal.
You're welcome.
I'm here to teach you a lesson.
she's with whip i'm not a home wrecker i'm an e-wrecker and
i did i did a service to everyone i i yeah i i basically
tested the bond you know i tested i did a service now you
know
well there leave him to play with me oh well there how about
we test this out
we look all right look how about this i'll do one game with
each of you i'll do one game with each of you leave the
person who left all right no look nila think of it this way
if we lose because your duo is Celestial 2 they lose a 28
points think of it this way and I gain I gain 30 so think of
it this way if we lose throughout the game your duo will
have a harsh lesson in life
What a story.
It's crazy.
Look, guys.
You're eating a harsh lesson.
That's just evil.
Don't worry.
Whoa.
Wait, they canceled me.
Okay, I was gonna say why did they cancel?
finally figured it out they figured i'm min-maxing right now
guys thank god they're celestial too i'm fucking min-maxing
right now for those points this is like wild see guys aren't
you glad i kept streaming aren't aren't you fucking glad i
kept streaming guys look at that that's it's like actual
situation where you hire your best friend to like tempt to
tempt the man to be like to be like is he actually is he is
he loyal you're welcome I did it for free you didn't even
have to pay me I did it for free yeah is he loyal type shit
karma it's gonna what do you mean karma what do you she
knows by the way he added me first get up oh my god there's
nila there's nila by the way i need you guys to remember he
added me i wasn't even gonna do anything if he didn't add me
i was gonna let it out i was gonna do And I was like, whoa,
he added me.
I got P, guys.
This is a dead game right now.
So Q's are slow.
Oh, God, I just saw a wild comet.
Doki's not a home record.
That guy was going to cheat on his duo no matter what.
That is true.
That is so true.
I can't be an e-wrecker if he ain't wasn't he ain't loyal in
the first place
it's like everybody's best love anyway I enjoy the show max
cope but drag coach yeah
part of the problem guys guys it was a test remember i was
testing i break e-families i would never abandon my e-day i
was just being a homie and a testing out i was just testing
out i was testing out the loyalty
Leave them alone.
What did I do?
Evidence one.
Doki, can we play?
I submit evidence one.
I submit evidence two.
No, he's mine.
And then I submit.
Leave evidence three where he added me.
And then I submitted evidence four.
Leave your duel.
Zero hesitation.
This is going to the...
I tempted him.
No, no, no, no, no.
He added me first.
The trope!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Calm down.
Still need to get to Celestial.
God, I still...
Calm down, I had a rough night of games, guys.
Release the two keyboard files.
What files?!
It all happened on stream!
What even type of files are you looking for?
You can grab it right now on the stream.
Live!
30 seconds before you attack get ready all right here we go
boom even when you can't see me i'll still make you believe
i'm like literally lean back on my chair right now
everything is just redacted can i play it all right here we
go i actually don't me know if i should play sue i could
just play cloak you know what i think cloak is just better i
think cloak actually is now meta not gonna lie i think cloak
is just so broken as current state oh i sure went to how was
i supposed to know they would go angela we don't even have
an angela
right here oh man i didn't want to go okay
whoa i whoa okay guys calm down calm calm down here calm
down down oh my guys guys calm down guys guys guys i will i
will go i calm down i'm sorry i had to at one point like it
just i had to calm down all right i might have to i might
have to swap the suit but i also have oh guys oh my god this
is a full dive cop okay yeah this is a full dive cop it's
okay i lose a lot less it's like trust me train me for this
he trained me for this guys oh shit it's fine what
it's okay trust me guys guys guys guys no that's okay Don't
mess with the amazing.
Oh, man, I hope.
What are you aiming at?
Alright, it's fine.
We got point.
What are we aiming at?
Why didn't your duo say?
That's a good question.
Wait, Jokey.
I rushed your games in Bougar Bash.
That...
What?
Wait, what?
What did he say?
I couldn't hear him.
having my own conversation.
Okay, I got a little scared here.
Oh, you watched my game?
Oh, that's cool.
Let's go.
You watched my game, guys.
It's okay.
Oh my god, wait, this guy's smart.
Wait.
Yoink.
My duel now.
Wait, that's a go-to cleanse.
Wait,
this guy, this guy know- this guy's smart.
He knows what he's doing.
I should really swap off.
I will swap eventually.
Let's hope we live.
Look, it was a good effort.
All right, now, now, it was truly a very good effort when we
did there.
When we did there.
All right, now I'm playing in this.
I did live, like, a really long time.
It's kind of...
I
Think what's worse is that I'm not even real I'm virtual I
think that's worse for for her He he left for a virtual
woman Okay All right
Okay, guys, I don't know.
I'm fucking leaving That's the
frack Wait, what do you think?
Oh Son of a bitch Oh my god, jump that
Twisting that stuff
Maybe for a Virtual bro, yeah.
Cosmic rays didn't make me want to be fun.
Okay, I...
Wee-yang, that is true.
That the dude...
I'm not even real.
I'm a virtual bro.
I'm sorry, man.
And your duo still picked me.
She's real to me.
The battle starts in five, four, three, two, one.
All you need to do is capture the mission area.
Got it?
Yeah.
I prefer teams of four, but now I can make this work.
Also, I should have just all did that.
I legitimately thought that we were going to fucking cap
that, but I guess not.
there we go me cap port me point 24 style we're gonna me cap
port what the fuck am I playing against full dive I'll be
top left marking DD engage I'm gonna give you the heal
alright that moment they do any the moment they do anything
I fucking I'm gonna I'm gonna ink pd top right spidey top
left i'm ripping it i know he's trying to look for me
carrying the angie he's showing i'm gonna go chase
okay okay you're still backline what the are i'm so paranoid
Okay, sorry, I inked.
I did say the moment it happens, I'm going to start inking.
I did say that.
That is my bad.
I'm not used to a very smart gambit player.
I was not used to that.
I will have to say, now that I am, I will not ink anymore.
I'm not used to playing with a smart gambit player in rank.
They're the spidey in our walk-up.
Now I know.
Now I learn.
Stop saying that.
I think that's something.
He's staging topside.
DD topside as well.
All right.
All right, here we go.
We almost have up.
Oh my god, he's flying.
How did he know?
What the fuck?
What was that?
Well, I'm so confused what that was.
Oh my god.
Somebody.
So I, what's going on?
He did it.
Like, where did he come from?
We could probably win next fight with your starboard.
they swapped off spidey starboard now oh they're trying to
use the combo
what are you doing when angie goes i'm just gonna start it
off i'm gonna start it off when angie goes pd back right
behind tree i'm alting keep him out is he dead is he dead
what's going on i swear to god i can't i what is going on Oh
my god, he's so smart.
He's so smart!
I'm sorry.
But...
Wait,
this guy is so smart.
Naila, I'm sorry.
It's okay.
30 seconds before you attack, get ready.
Never punished.
Stand aside, let warriors and let Namur show you how a
battle is won.
Thank you for the 150s there.
Elle of Riz.
Alright.
See?
W.
W Riz.
Alright, so they're gonna have all the advantage going into
this fight.
You're gonna have to play as well.
I haven't visited.
Don't bug it out.
It is what it is.
I gave her a valuable life lesson today.
You just gotta remember
I gave her something very important to Can we like touch it?
Or no Oh my god Oh my You know what?
Fuck it Okay, that's fine I knew it, I fucking knew it Oh my
god, I fucking knew it I knew it, I felt it I was like, he's
gonna ult, isn't he?
He's gonna do it.
Wait, he's not even got the point?
Oh, we, we Gamba ulted too.
We Gamba ulted.
No!
Oh, no.
Is he gonna live?
Yes.
Don't worry.
I'm a hero today.
I'm a hero.
not a bad person
what the fuck
all right that's oh he's he's going for get out of here get
your app get out of here there you go
oh my god wait did he get anybody did he get anybody i can't
tell
He didn't know he didn't know I got him down Oh no
What I didn't get that Wait I didn't get that What about my
gap Oh wait he ulted okay What is that?
I done celebrity fast.
If it was...
If it was one celebrity...
Oh, no.
If it was one celebrity, who would it be?
I think you got all...
Oh, shit.
Why me?
Where am I, though?
That's right!
Uno reversal!
That's lucky, right?
Get Uno reversal.
Can we take early poke, get our end result up?
Or...
Oh.
I need to grab up.
Give me up!
He has up though.
really need up please he has up too i can tell we're so
close
i'm gonna say
please please no because the emma looked at me that's
unlucky why do we all left that's unfortunate
That's right!
I sold that duo!
I sold this duo!
Get away!
Oh shit.
Let's hope...
Oh shit, I'm a little...
Oh my god, there was no way I could live that.
That's okay.
I believe.
The stool that I stole.
I won't disappear so easily.
You got them all!
I truly...
Yeah!
You could steal him.
Someone else can take him from you too.
Come on.
Arma works in reverse for Stokey.
Now, alright, alright, let's see.
I'll test it out.
We'll test out which duo.
Which duo, which duo we are going to get.
Alright.
I'm testing out the duo now.
Alright, we're going to...
Alright.
Now.
Now, let's see.
Let's see Nala.
I'm switching.
I'm swapping them.
They're like accessories.
All right.
Let's test this out.
Musical chairs.
I'm like, all right, swap.
Swap seats.
Yes.
Swap seats now.
Now he has to watch.
Alright.
Sit on that chair, guys.
Yeah, you can't reel in Celestial.
I'm having a great time, everyone.
Oh, I see.
that oh my god you know what god it's like you know like um
you know that trope where like the older married couple
invites the the young third yeah that that trope you know
that trope yeah the swingers yeah they're swinging right now
i don't consume the stuff you too it's a fucking it's a
fucking popular trope in comedy what am i seeing it's a
popular trope in you in comedy guys
it's all right now now it should become a tv show look at
that now you have to wait
them for rigsy i'll be like rigsy cute let's play
jesus it's all right guys we're just having a normal a
normal day in rank i'm a good person i'm a good person i'm
adding spice back into their duo dual ship exactly
bump bump bump bump bump bump i think i'm just getting all
my rivals out and then like i'll be back to normal oh yeah
where's my where do i have to finish this sponsor for the
other oh i have i have three days that's enough time three
days to play arc nights i i can make it
I was thinking about doing it today, but now it's just that
I don't just want to play rivals.
I just want to game The thing is there's no other like
incoming tournaments and I you it just usually happens
whenever a tournament shows up Literally the biggest fucking
gap of rivals I know and then I get invited to a tournament
and then I have to play play rivals again Pretty awkward if
we don't know oh nice
person say how was I a horrible person all right give me
five reasons where I was a horrible person come on I bet you
can't you
stole I didn't steal anyone they invited themselves in how
is that stealing when they invited themselves to play with
me checkmate how am i throwing if anybody i'm just existing
you'll need a top-notch team to win this one all right i
play i don't know i don't want to play rocket i want to play
rock oh where's my supports okay I don't want to play I'll
play cloak all
right I me cloak you don't want to play me don't want to
play in this me cloak I don't know I don't know actually I
never like i didn't ask i just assume i just assume that
they play whatever i don't play
all right here we go
this is like a little rough in terms of like
whoa oh my god look guys it's moon night rocket Oh my god,
Ender's Black Panther?
What the fuck?
Is our Captain America?
Yeah, he's fine.
He's so fine.
He's so healthy.
Look at him.
I knew you were so healthy.
Look at him, girl.
I hear him.
Goodbye.
I mean I heard him like when was I gonna I used my ears
that's what my pros taught me they're like remember to you
oh no oh that's bad oh no we lost you we lost you I go back
oh no I should have I should have fucking I really should
have helped that shark That's my bad.
That really is a MB.
I wait.
Where could the panther be?
I'm scared.
Okay.
That's fine.
Alright.
It's alright.
Whoa!
Wow.
Oh,
wow.
Um, we're running triple support.
Wait a minute.
Come on.
Oh, oh, we're running.
Oh, oh, here I go.
Don't worry.
We won.
Oh my god, we won.
Let's go.
It's okay.
I'm here.
That was a little close because, like, I had a, I felt like
I was going to have a heart attack there, but
I do need...
It will be nice if they, you know.
Okay, let's hope that...
Why is he just walking to me?
Why?
What?
Okay, I would really like it if he's not just slowly, like,
walking towards me.
That would be very nice.
Oh my god, we're so close.
Let's go, let's go!
Oh, that's...
You know, he is very low.
Yes!
There you go.
Oh, that's not good.
Hey!
What if I'm up here now?
Come
to me.
okay that's fine guys guys we're gonna need oh my god yes
yes
yes oh my gosh wait they might both be gamers guys.
Guys, this is a hard choice.
I might have to test them both out again.
I might have to test the other one and we might have to do a
little test on both of them at which part.
God, we need more data, guys.
We need more data chat.
Alright.
Guys, we need more data to figure it out.
There's only the first interview, right?
Bro, we gotta have more data.
30 seconds before you attack.
The double tip.
All right, let's go.
Hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Remember.
Remember, I didn't start this.
I didn't start the...
What is it called?
I didn't start the fire.
But no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't start it.
Remember, I didn't start this.
I'm, like, so fucking concerned right now.
Since the world was...
turning but i did i might have poured the gas but like is
that really like is that really a bad thing if you think
about it is that truly bad yes
what is it okay wait nala's cues gave me an easy ass lobby
nala's cues gave me the thrower lobby oh Guys, write this
down.
We gotta, like, collect data.
Guys, we're collecting data.
Yeah, I just lit the match and walked, though.
We gotta collect the data.
Write it down to see which team is, which duo is better.
One, two, zero.
All right.
Now we test out ballet again.
We gotta compare we got we can't just have one we gotta
compare guys Have you guys are you guys writing it down are
you guys and then we'll have a vote we'll have a vote to see
who wins I'll have a vote after Doki please All right, all
right, let's let's try it.
All right, let's try it ballet again Guys, let's try ballet
again.
Doki the Green.
Alright.
Dahlia's win was faster.
I will admit.
Nailia's win.
Guys, write it down.
Write it down.
Nailia's win was faster.
Ballet, I have to try a little harder.
I actually have to try when I played...
When I played with Ballet, but I didn't have to try that
hard when I played with Nihila, though.
Nihila is a great tech and you won faster.
But Ballet's Gambit was pretty cracked.
That is true.
Ballet's Gambit was really cracked.
Which hero do you think you want to be today?
All right.
Unfortunately, we can't get both.
We have to make a choice.
Who am I going to banish from this match?
Wait, does Ballet not have a Twitch account?
Does he not want to speak for himself?
Does he not want to defend himself?
Does he not want to...
does he not want to give all try to convince chat why we
should pick ballet we're creating this like like oh he's
scared all right write that down guys you scared nila is
confident ballet is scared let the gameplay speak for them
yeah note it down he's scared he's shy Pallet is a bitch,
got it.
You'll need a top notch.
All right, let's see.
I will play.
All right, I will play.
Ah, choke time.
All
right, here we go.
We got this, guys.
As a reminder, I am a good person.
I don't know why I have to keep reminding people that.
I don't know why people are doubting that.
Also, this comp.
This, okay, note this out.
This is our comp for this game.
But they will.
They always do.
I think this will affect the data.
Just remember, his performance, you know.
You know, it might not be him.
You know, it might be, you know, whatever the fuck our comp
is right now.
It might be.
It might be whatever the fuck this comp is.
Some shit.
Oh, no.
I hear a hot guy.
What the fuck?
When did hot guy became, like, mega meta?
This is, like, the most hot guys I've ever fucking seen,
actually.
like what the fuck i'm so scared of going forward knowing
that they have a hawk got
like where is he where's the hawk got where is he where is
he where is he oh he's dead dead i can push up now wait it's
working okay oh okay that's our portal i look behind me all
right it's all right that worked
what i mean okay
it's five oh my god oh my god Note that down.
Note that down.
He died.
He did die there.
Oh my god.
We are stacking, right?
Note that down.
Ballet died.
Yeah, it's me.
No, no.
My minus 50.
So just note that down.
Yeah, he did that.
I'm gonna just wait honestly oh I'm fucking leaving that
whoa didn't get me though I'm scared though oh no what am I
aiming at Oh
Wow, okay, I had to study wanted to stay there though
All right
Well, I hope he all
Oh, I'm just gonna stay here.
Oh nice.
Oh not nice
Okay, not nice again Oh No Oh, no, I...
Oh, we leave now.
You think she lives?
Please don't...
Don't please don't Hawkeye me, please don't Hawkeye me,
please don't Hawkeye.
Whoa!
Okay.
I saw the Hawkeye.
He looked at me, and I was very scared.
What the fuck?
Okay, we should be fine, right?
It's new
Just don't get you
Oh nice we did it yeah There you go Where is he?
Where is he?
He and Mago!
Write that down!
We have to, we have to be a...
What is the objective?
Objective is like with data, right?
Subjective is like with your own opinion, right?
Ooh, was it me?
Oh, I lost it.
I lost it.
oh my god oh my god thank god the
okay wait write the fucking penny out bro okay you know what
bro maybe i should do with that penny whoa that penny was
you know what add the penny into it add sparky third third
contender third contender
Maybe.
Oh, he got solo ulted.
Oh no.
But he got solo ulted.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
It still hits me?
Sparky's the control.
A new challenger has appeared.
Oh my god.
Write that down.
Oh, write that down.
Do you think he's getting nervous?
Oh, you're right.
The invisible has been keeping me up too.
Write that down.
Oh no.
Guys, we're making him nervous.
Guys, we wrote too many things down.
We wrote too many things down.
He's nervous now.
His performance, he's nervous about his performance.
All right, nice.
He has performance anxiety.
I can do it, Mrs. Puppet.
Sonny, thank you for tier one, so they can thank you.
But it kept downer.
Swapping me.
Oh, no.
Now, now, I love.
What would you do in this situation?
If they keep counter-swapping you, what would you do?
It's okay.
No pressure.
No pressure, bro.
Don't worry.
They'll also go...
They'll get the same tree.
We're gonna know know her stuff down to and not die
Nyla has orange
We're gathering so much data guys
I The battle starts in five four three two one.
All right You have to stop them from securing the mission
area
Oh my god, you fucked up.
I didn't even know The more we got you we got you we got
your So healthy!
I don't know about him, no.
Okay.
Holy fuck.
That's a lot.
Oh my god!
Okay, you know what?
No, that shit, that shit looks fucking crazy.
What the fuck is going on?
I don't even know what's going on right now.
Like, he actually just got deleted.
What was he aiming at?
Like, he's actually...
Oh, my...
I cannot blame him.
He's getting fucking deleted, bro.
I really can't blame him.
Really?
I'm sorry.
I leave.
Alright.
Like, I don't blame him for what the fuck just happened.
and everybody was getting the lead in there.
Like, what the fuck?
There we go.
Alright.
Yeah, see, look at that.
Luna doesn't matter.
Look at that.
Alright, note that.
Write that down.
That Layna not comboed.
We comboed.
We had a combo together.
That's like a synergy plus one.
If you think about it.
Hi.
Oh, no.
He fucking, he got, he got dead.
That's very unlucky, that's very very...
What the fuck?
Oh my god, what's going on?
What's going on?
What?
I think we can stick to the dude.
I think we might need like...
I don't even know what we need.
We might need not double melee question mark
Oh my god Oh my god there's so much heals I have to do It's
okay okay now Now I let them build Oh my okay Now let them
build Okay three minutes of this Four technically four Okay
All right, I can all first, but I can all first
All right
Here we go
All right, here we go
All right, there we go
Wow, he's so healthy He's so healthy Let's see All right.
Here he goes.
All right Three more minutes three more minutes.
Oh Oh All right, we removed Sparky from the contenders list
we're We're gonna
We're gonna have to remove him We're
Oh my god, I was going to say he's one.
Okay, Sparky has been removed from the list.
Unfortunately, um...
Uh...
Unfortunately, I will have to remove Sparky from the list.
He has, um, disappointed me a little bit.
he has um i don't know just just a little little
questionable plays there just just a little you know
the rest of me is it was supposed to be the controller group
but in the end he just oh he just wasn't good enough to be
in a controller room oh no oh my god wait note that down
That was pretty cool.
Wait, note that down.
That was pretty sick what he just did.
You know that.
Alright.
Oh.
Remove him from the list as well.
We might have to remove some more.
No!
Okay, I got way too old.
Oh my god, let's...
Guys, Sparky is so far away from the list.
Um...
It removes Invis as well.
It removes Invis and Sparky from the list.
That could have been avoided, I will say.
I felt like that could have been avoided very easily.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
What did he up?
Snuggly, thank you for the prime.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
This does not look...
Remove everyone from the list.
Look, I said me next.
I said me next.
The Invis is now banned.
The Invis has now been banned from any list.
Chicken, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
I never invited again.
Thank you.
Yeah, I mean, I kind of only heard the goal after I ulted
because of my thing.
All right, here we go.
We got this, I believe.
Oh, 170p.
Well, now we're...
that I don't know that you should be maybe he should be
maybe he should all for okay look I didn't know he was 170
ping guys if I knew that maybe he should all first uh no I
already think you're the twitch proud me thank you all right
where is the where's that spotty man where is the mines
anyway
yeah oh hey guys i'm not very hopeful anymore
guys guys we got it guys
guys guys
Oh I might have to die
Oh no
Oh, no!
Okay, put me off the list.
Put me off the list, guys.
They literally...
I don't know if that was my group wall or their group wall,
but like, I could not do anything.
Oh, guys.
I think it's the winnable.
We don't have any wall buster except
I will say I'm going to play Loki.
I have to.
We need the chaos.
Like they should be fine, right?
I am ready to put on a show Don't mess with the amazing
Spider-Man
Guys, I don't think it's winnable no more No, I lamp, but
Spider-Man all deletes lamp.
There's nothing I can do about it.
It literally is just a deleter.
Um...
Oh, guys.
Oh, I'll take this.
I got this, too.
Please, please, please, please, please, I can't!
Oh!
my the current score is three two he can play wolverine all
along note this down note guys you'll need a top-notch team
to win this one i am loki goddess of me and the queen of
asgard note this down the guy could have played wolverine
the entire time
He was a wolverine player all along I
invented every trick Oh my god And then he Oh my god 30
seconds before you attack Get ready You know what fuck it
You know what I believe I believe in the shark nato I
believe...
Guys, just remember, I'm not throwing on Jeffel because I
just get transported into the story mode.
It'll be fine.
It's technically not throwing.
Oh...
Oh
Guys, we're just making him very nervous.
Okay, it's not him.
It's not him.
We're making him very he has performance anxiety right now
He just has performance anxiety guys
It's just performance anxiety guys
I don't know what the fucking...
Yeah,
we have up, Carva.
Oh, oh, he got me this time.
You know, I've been waiting.
I'm waiting for the storm.
How do I do the storm combo again?
Do I just press Q?
What do I do?
Oh, my God.
Oh.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
Doesn't matter now, though.
Man, I really wanted to do...
I'm sad.
I really wanted to do the combo.
It looked really cool.
High E though, the lances did work.
What if I eat you, though?
That's right.
I still got it.
I got it.
Three, two, six.
Thank you for the suggestion, bro.
It helped.
Still got it.
All right.
Naila time.
We go back to Naila.
All right.
Look.
This guy did have 21 deaths, too.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright, let's test.
Let's check the...
Alright, let's test out the other one.
Neither.
Or ballet.
Don't worry, don't worry.
We'll call you.
Don't worry.
Alright.
Wait.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
Now, you stressed them out.
Don't worry, we're gonna give the same...
Observation, the same observation and notes.
We are, we're doing, there's no biases here.
There's no, but check the history.
All right, all right, let's see this.
Oh, I do know three losses in a row, though.
I do know a couple of losses in a row, though.
There is that.
It's not a full.
Yellow Brick Road.
Oh!
Alright.
Note that down, guys.
Note that down.
Yeah, this was me.
I was in that game.
Alright.
Alright, Ballet.
Ballet, why don't you open your profile?
Let's see this.
all right plus 15 that was the one with me oh 363 all right
is there a deep oh three five in the loss all right all
right here we go do you think you want to be so rough it is
this is a little rough this is a little bit rough but like
we noted it down we we did quietly into the background who
am i gonna banish from this match
all right here we go oh no we didn't ban anything i'm
banning gambit i don't care i'll double triple ban gambit if
i have to bounce a good this season gambit Got that shit out
of my game.
For those who are asking.
Have I just been on Rivals this entire day?
Yes.
But don't worry.
Tomorrow's my rest day.
Today's my rest day.
Don't get it ready tomorrow.
Today's...
My rest is dead.
I'll blow my nose.
How come I can't control spiders?
Would you want to?
I mean, maybe?
I bet there's a million spiders in doosh time.
I can command them all.
Alright, here we go.
believe oh my god is it real that oh wait oh my god i just
noticed him flanking it
oh my i don't have another push i'm sorry oh my god i hate
that fuck where am i how do i get out of here wait how do i
actually get out of here.
I've never been down here before.
We eventually, where the fuck did I go?
I was like, where am I?
Alright, here.
Alright, here we go.
Nice, we did it.
We did it.
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
Oh my god, oh wait.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Let's go!
he got beat up we have a woman now that's not the let's go
part but like that's bad but like let's go he canceled the
uh that's bad that's bad don't do that that's bad
is she oh okay i was gonna say is he gonna bring it all
all right where should be
Not okay.
I was like, we should be a...
I exploded.
I really did.
Holy fuck.
Oh, I don't have a pull now, so let's hope that doesn't fuck
me over.
Alright, it's okay.
It's okay, it's okay.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
I got
the Loki red!
The Loki red!
I won't disappear so easily.
Guys, guys, how many notes have you wrote?
Guys, how many?
Oh no.
Guys, how many notes?
She did bubbled me.
I will note that down What the what I mean, okay She dashed
wrong we didn't kill it What happened to our Loki?
What happened to him?
I don't note that down note that down note that Did anyone
take the notes?
Did anyone take the notes?
Did anyone took notes?
Oh my I just got a where is my low key?
Oh my god, my low key was made
Oh, no, she's gonna explode.
She's gonna explode Oh, no guys
It ain't looking so good It ain't looking so good right now
for both of them
Guys Naila's games are fast-noded It's currently It's
currently still one so what we have to do more tests.
We have to do more tests We gotta do the third interview.
We lose Nihila games fast.
That is true.
Badly got fat.
Nihila either wins or lose fast.
Yes, you're right.
You're right.
No, because they also won with me.
Okay, to be fair, to be fair, I fucked up that one ult.
I exploded so fucking fast.
Oh, that guy left.
That guy ain't playing no more.
My other support ain't playing no more.
Alright, alright, alright.
Alright.
Alright, I did that.
I did.
Alright, note that down.
That was a sick-ass pull.
Note that down, guys.
Note that down.
down i just did a sick ass pull just now we lost our only
tank that's not good
oh that's also not that good
all right oh oh nila killed that oh nila got 2k now i got no
that no notes notes
Now I just got 2k right there
Wait, that's pretty impressive
Oh Alright, you know, things are Things are looking pretty
positive
Good old, good old too
Come on, do you see how hot they do I'll make sure I don't
I'm gonna say that, I'm gonna get locked, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay, guys.
I fucked that up twice.
Alright.
I threw that.
I'm throwing.
Note that down.
I'm throwing right now.
I...
I'm throwing.
I definitely threw that.
I definitely, I threw that.
You know what, Nyla?
You can, you can take, I definitely threw that one.
You get that from me.
That's all right.
We'll run Nyla again.
Because I, that test, for that test, I threw that one a
little bit.
So we get another one She did do really well on DPS I didn't
think I would explode I legitimately didn't think I was just
like I'll be fine
I fucked up that suit all leg twice I think it's also
because I've been streaming for hours I have this trip for
12 hours, so that's on me.
How this will do...
Oh, hey, there's T.
Bennett.
Isn't that the guy?
That was the...
That was the torch guy, right?
Let's fuck it.
Let's bring...
That number.
Let's bring him in, too.
No, we'll do one more test.
We'll run one more test between the two.
And I'll actually lock in.
We'll full lock in.
guys have to write the notes for me though if I'm full
locking in all right I'm gonna get water I'll get back up up
up all right I'm tapering look that's what I'm saying I'm
gonna full lock in but you guys have to keep notes you have
to keep tab of everything all
right before I lock in I gotta disassociate guys if I To
give you guys a...
Non-bias...
To give you guys a non-bias...
Objective...
Result.
I gotta do it.
To make it all fair...
I gotta fully lock in.
Performance always improves after disassociation.
That is true.
That is very true.
And I'm gonna play Rocket.
Now, who am I going to banish from this match?
All right.
This is going to work.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
We can do this.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay.
I have to lock in too.
I have to lock into this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Goddess of mischief and the queen of Asgard.
30 seconds before you attack.
Get ready.
So locked.
Alright.
Fully locked in.
We're gonna try.
As much as we can.
Oh my god, the gambit's healing you, not me.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay, locked.
Alright, you guys have to write the notes down.
I can't, I'm gonna do no calm, focus.
You gotta write the notes.
Oh my god, it's not a hot guy.
What?
I swear to god if that's a hot guy.
Oh my god it's a hot guy.
Oh
my god it's a hot guy.
Alright.
We're okay.
Probably the fattest one of her hit in this fucking game.
Oh it's okay.
It's okay.
I just did the mega one.
See there that.
Locked in.
hey i'm in the game too guys guys come out i'm in oh what
okay i'm locked in i know i'm really far but i am still
locked in
i told you i was locked in
running like great destruction here I'm everywhere like you
hit my wall no way you are a stone you're gonna open back
mine by the way your powers are mine we are oh you're gonna
have to your power is mine oh watch me start
Oh.
Everybody, I fucked up that.
I fucked that up.
I thought he meant me.
Look, he said you're gonna have to, you're gonna have to.
You're gonna have to.
Oh my god.
all right it's fine it's fine it is not fine you know when
he said you're gonna have to alt i thought he meant me
because the gambit didn't alt right away so i was so
confused the was he not saying me or or like all right i
don't even know was so confused i i was like what is it me
or who's gonna have to look because the other gambit did not
look you're low you're low you're supposed to be an
unkillable tank what the fuck i love you
Oh my god, he's still okay.
He's still okay.
There you go.
I locked in.
Oh, they didn't.
Oh, he chased you things.
I locked in.
I.
you guys see that you guys see that there we go not gonna
lie I don't know I want to pop my all but they have lamps
why would anyone want order when they can enjoy you know can
we force that if we can force out their lamps for them how
to go crazy well actually wait the low key has to copy the
all no because he's the one that's already he won't be able
to lamp he won't be able to lamp something's off i'm talking
don't do that whatever you do all right what do you mean i'm
ready what the guy was typing in chat i'm gonna use the
gamut on their spawn it's just we go there fast wait that's
kind of smart though no but the point doesn't oh my i'm
listening i'm listening to meta crafting right now the
battle starts in five four three i i'm locking in i i didn't
realize how much i have to lock in for valet but i'm locking
in now now we want an objective no biases result now
actually i'm gonna go for the for their gps not the so forth
they still have oh they still have a hawk i didn't get Shit
No, I did them I got mine Oh, I got mine Oh,
we are deleted I think win con is just gambling I don't want
to peek that hot guy though hot guy scares me oh they're
running us over they're running us over they're running us
over don't worry guys we have gambit all for next fight
God, right?
You're getting me, please get me in there.
If I'm not in there, let me know in a second.
Like, wait a minute.
That means these.
That means my crew don't.
Wait, are you?
Oh, they're so fucking fast.
They have, they have, they have Gandy.
Oh, holy shit.
Oh my god.
I can't be peaked for one fucking nanosecond.
Oh.
Where did my team go, man?
Where did y'all go, bro?
I walled off too.
I can't agree.
Oh shit.
Oh shit, I fucked up.
They are gonna have Hawkeye.
Oh, nope.
I like how our Punisher didn't say anything.
Oh No, don't use it.
I'm trying to touch I found touch this portal.
No one needs I have to I have touch
Oh We portal or no Oh, I didn't we gambit all that I just I
told this guy to not we didn't we didn't gambit all they did
Oh shit bro we have gambit off the next fight i like how the
punisher was very quiet about what was happened he was like
you're gonna play spidey on track bro now get pulled off
until the trick i'm not he's like i'm not gonna say anything
he might i don't know maybe he's gonna say on hawkeye but
like i do like how the punisher didn't say anything about
what happened
going on all right all right we got this we have we have alt
advantage right bro i would go back he would he would go
back i wouldn't i'll be in front of you all you need to do
is capture the mission area so why isn't he gonna go mag so
what he said like you said i would go mag so like no i don't
say i think
so i don't understand why wouldn't you go mag this is guys
i'm gonna die i'm gonna die i want i want to go mad like
thank you well i don't think he can die i want to go mad i
want to go mad i want to play i'm trying to swap to i see my
own i have many faces they want my holding i'm holding this
corner guys like we're down the tank so just chill just
chill please
get in there match i can kill the game i'm not here i'm not
here okay we have to point for you what's up jesus holy shit
bro no you're not fucking
hit the gambit
why did we all us there point already oh what the bro this
guy's not fucking here
i just all did because everybody else all did they can't
blame me for that literally literally everyone else all did
so i was like okay i guess i'll too oh
now you don't want to also now you don't want to fall
I swear to God, bro, if anyone's watching the game, I'll
make some instant bait.
Better safe.
Much harder.
Guys, I don't think he's happy, guys.
I...
Whatever, I give him.
Whatever.
Oh.
guys i i don't think he's happy you should all be i have
many forces all right please just any match they're all if
you match they're all we win the game don't go before don't
go don't win it before
your powers are mine your powers are mine
That's unlucky.
Oh my god!
Okay, it worked.
It worked out.
That was so stressful.
I was so locked in.
I was so locked in and I was so fucking stressed out as
well.
I'm gonna let him build up.
He needs to build Gambit up like right now.
All
right Luck mantis Good
luck good luck mantis
It worked I would write that down not I like how our gambit
came over and then the mantis was like peace and I was like
hey guys wait what wait when do we swap what I do I do think
that's very fucking funny all right now I love that was a
good interview That was a really good interview.
Now, wait, Ballet's gone.
Oh, wait.
Oh, wait, Ballet's in...
Wait, actually, wait.
No, Ballet's still there.
He's in the practice range.
That's good interview.
All right, what were the notes, guys?
What were your notes, chat, about Nyla?
All right.
What notes do you have?
It's currently...
was nvp nila got the starlord in bag
guys this was your one job i wasn't taking any notes i was
gaming i had to lock in i was just like
how was i removed on the list what did i do well actually i
did nothing but um I did Gambit never falls all right and
then with this last interview with this last interview we
will make the pull we will make the pull all right Naila got
Naila got a triple MVP great team fights nice team fight
engaged too oh oh those are some good notes those are some
good notes oh my god nila would never know how how they did
nila got a 4k too don't forget that is true that is true all
right our final test our final test oh and nila is heading
to bed i guess i guess they'll never know the result in the
end I think I would say Nail has an edge Has the edge
currently I think ballet needs to truly pop off this game
With a win to even it Oh you hear that ballet You have a lot
of pressure
Lots of pressure right now It's just you Alright
Disassociation time
Like they say This association will improve performance.
I agree.
Which hero do you think you need to?
I 100% agree with that statement.
I'm banning Loki.
I don't care.
I'm not doing that again.
I'm tired, boss.
too damn bad we have an exam we have an interview right now
very important interview guys I'm gonna I cannot wait to
sleep I cannot wait to sleep team
to win this one why did we ban fantastic
that's a good wait who banned that who who banned that
Wait, where the fuck is that?
What happened?
I looked away for one second.
I'll be like, it's eating pizza.
I'm pretty sure eating pizza is better than these people at
Mr. Fantastic.
Alright, here we go.
all right here we go
all right write notes for me guys do my homework locking in
so we can have a no bias no bias objective opinion
oh yeah the hot guy at least we could peek right
what though why are you okay
that is a lot of I will say that is indeed a lot of damage
right now.
It's okay.
Oh my, it's no longer okay.
Oh my god, I almost fucking just wanted the damage.
I almost just wanted the damage.
Oh shit!
It's okay, it's okay, I'm okay, I'm okay, I'm okay.
Wait, who the fuck did he eat?
Oh, him.
I was like, what?
I'll let her out here, he goes.
All right.
Oh, thanks, Jelly.
Thank you.
We are having games.
That's all I can describe it.
They are...
absolutely games that
should be fun right they should be fine right come on kill
them all right nice nobody went nobody went TP that's good
oh my god how really were outside oh thank you I am playing
like 20% right now I mean, I'm locked in, guys.
No biases.
Very objective.
Five percent.
Okay, maybe like...
Oh, my God.
I got it.
I got him, though.
Oh, my God.
That bunny hop, though.
That bunny hop's sick as hell.
I can appreciate a good bunny hop.
So these guys...
know how to bunny hop okay it's not me but okay he didn't
get me what the fuck there is a fucking opening there okay
so we lost three it's
okay you can't do that again and we're closer we have closer
spots what the fuck are we doing right now oh my oh i got
you i got you i hope my team is winning
we're not winning this neutral fight are we
okay we're definitely not all right it all right it ha ha ha
ha ha It's all right, I baited that up.
Oh my god, okay.
He didn't get any.
He doesn't know about the room, but I do.
Oh, I still know about the room.
Oh my god, I just...
Okay, okay.
He didn't know about the room.
He learned...
That's the best part about the new map.
brightness I learned that today you didn't know about the
fucking room the room of no damage there is a beautiful room
hey guys I'm a little worried about this guy oh and I'm a
little bit worried about you yeah wait a minute what are
these all but they but they Bale will we be okay?
Can we stop all things so far up in this?
That would be absolutely superb.
Oh no!
Alright, Doki has ace noted.
Doki has ace.
can't i i got bursted there there's i can't fucking
oh no oh oh yes i exploded there was no way to like feel to
like actually live from that just fall back fall back oh oh
nice my mag didn't know one v6 y'all
Oh my god, he is!
Where he is?
He is, technically?
He is technically gonna...
Oh no, not the room.
Guys, the room!
Oh no.
Wait, we stopped the portal?
Wait, did we portal?
Portal?
Oh, no.
Nobody...
Okay, we got...
I'm gonna...
mute this guy because I know he's gonna start saying shit
time to switch things up including which side you're on team
to win this one not the room was so close no I felt like he
was gonna say something bad so I got worried he was like
this close he was this close to see I I don't know.
But they don't have a high Eelopent.
I don't even know who banned.
Who banned the fantastic player, guys?
He was this close to saying something really bad.
And I was just like, ooh.
What's in the cards?
How come when we get a Hawkeye?
He doesn't do the shit that the enemy Hawkeye does.
all right note that he doesn't use cards and then they're
ready to start yep write that down write that down all
right all right write that down the the
hawk eye the hawk eye is a problem apparently oh my god
actually meephi yeah maybe yeah dude people don't see my
little dome and i to call it out but I'm a little concerned
about it oh
no oh
no number seven who the fuck is number seven guys the
longest runback of their lives all right we're portaling
we're portaling Muzzle does not want to keep playing this,
which is understandable.
It really is.
Oh my god.
Oh, what is going on?
What the fuck is going on?
Oh, our Hawk got.
Oh, the Emma.
The Emma doesn't want to play no more.
Guys, I don't, I have a feeling that, I have a feeling that
muzzle is talking a lot of shit right now.
I have a feeling that muzzle is talking a lot of shit right
now, guys.
Just, it's like they're having fun.
conversation with somebody but I don't know with who right
now I'll let my invis build up despite me thinking that I
don't know it doesn't seem very winnable but I'll still do
it I'll still do that trap oh
that's awkward that's so awkward oh hey who did he oh okay i
was gonna say who the fuck did he eat look at that look at
that come on was that not sick was that not a sick fade
let's go
I Feel like I should not be playing cloak though not gonna
lie
I don't know maybe for the fade I guess for the fade
Oh my god home Where I go I go That's right Boom Oh, I'm
fucked
I forgot about the will i i forgot about the whale i was
like oh hey there
guys i forgot about the whale i i forgot about the whale
that's awkward all right now that i know about the whale now
that i know i forgot the i legitimately not gonna lie i even
forgot we even had a name more like i i'm gonna let i
actually didn't realize the name more existed for the
longest time wait
i actually have to admit that like i that guy was so
non-existent in our game that i forgot that like they were a
person.
Okay, I'm going to let them build.
There you go.
Oh my god.
Here we go.
Holy shit, I'm trying so hard to focus right now.
You go, you go, you go!
Did he get anybody?
Oh my god, I'm so...
Oh my god, we won!
it oh my god write that down we won oh my god he won and he
finally he spoke he actually spoke all right what are your
notes guys what are your never doubted you in my i i oh man
i should have and i want to know what he said i should not
have mute all right all right guys what do you mean ddn all
right what are your notes on ballet what are the notes holy
you solo no i'm ruining an e-date
someone's e-date someone's duo and now I'm testing oh base
and now I'm testing both players out
base Rigsie gets it all right ballet did great heels mist
and all and clutch whiff and all great pull great team fight
at this gauge help a dying tank all right let's set up a
pull now let's set up a pull all right slash wait slash pull
all right nala versus ballet my god I can't type right now
guys I can waste my mod here can I abstain all right is any
of my mods here I can't type right now what if we no no you
can only pick one I was literally trying to type and I was
like don't keep it dude all right make a pull Nala versus
Versus a ballet.
Who was the better duo?
Nala or ballet?
Technically.
If I get 23, I'd be back to Celestia.
And then we stopped there.
Don't take you to blame us.
I am not destroying families.
It's an...
It's an e-family.
That's different.
Nala and ballet were the perfect duo, Turkey.
No!
No, no, no, no, no.
I think maybe I was the...
I think maybe I bring out the best of both, guys.
I bring the best of both duos.
I didn't think...
throw a game I just made a little oopsie I made a small
little mistake everyone makes mistakes guys it's just one
tiny mistake that might have lost this elo but but you know
you live and learn I learn from them they're all they're all
a learning experience and I learn from them
all right I'm waiting for the pull
isn't this oh okay it's okay i can make the pull guys i it's
okay guys i can make the pull all right who was the belly
duo nala ballet all right i'll give you five minutes
And I'll give you guys a show, too.
I ain't picking, make it balanced.
They had their mode.
They do.
It's technically both of them are 2-2 technically.
They're both technically 2-2.
Perfectly balanced as it should be.
Q what's up ballet while we do this pull because the other
one I will have to give you you know what there's another
note I'll give you another note on your report didn't quit
wasn't weak and kept playing
guys wasn't weak and still still up to credit bump
bottom 50
50 as it should be oh my god what the fuck wait what I just
processed it wait it is 50 50 holy
shit I like how all of you guys are like doing it one at a
time being like the coordinating that shit right now guys i
do need to sleep but guys it is one more game think about it
chat one more game guys guys
guys one more game we're this close Don't yeah, but I can
get it back See God has spoken God has spoken
Oh and Ballet winning By three Votes Now No!
They waited.
Scammed and ballet.
The one that initiated the e-recking.
Karma ain't real.
Guys.
Okay, me and what?
Me and four.
I have four, me and four alt accounts voted on the poll in
the last second.
Our paid voters by Katochi.
Three paid actors.
Look at that, guys.
Look at that.
In the end.
Ballet won.
To keep ballet in the mod.
It's ballet.
He voted for himself.
Doesn't even matter anymore.
Um.
I would never.
I would never jeopardize the vote.
I would never tamper with any votes.
Guys.
Release the flies.
How could you imply?
That I would tamper the votes guys.
I did not even vote
All right All right, we got this Just one more one more win
All right, here we go I did not expect to stream that much
today here we go here we go this has been a very long stream
i am sorry manager i'm sorry we have an iron bed oh no
oh no
oh no wait a minute why wait a minute I don't know where I
am right now are
we positioned okay because I don't think so I don't think we
are Okay, I pressed...
Alright.
That's right!
Alright, it's okay, let's see, I'm locked in.
I still want... somehow, somehow.
That's right, somebody took the Jeff from the Jeff guy.
Now he's on Strange and...
Well, you saw what happened.
Look, you go...
Go rocket no, he go rocket
Okay, I don't need all the first though I don't think I need
to do anything
Oh, it's bad.
I'll just stay here like what is he gonna do fucking walk up
into the the death point like bro this is the death point
right now oh my god that's a lot of votes yes i don't know
maybe we maybe it's all right we still have don't you do it
i'll choke you if you do it
guys i bet you i'm gonna get plus 20.
Oh.
Well, then.
Let us just...
Light doesn't dispel darkness.
It helps me see the darkness and face it.
Racist?
Also, how is that word not bad?
Wait, you're so right.
Net ease?
Not a bad word.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's Spanish?
Oh, I'm not a Spaniard.
I don't think he means Spanish, guys.
Guys.
I don't think he means it in a Spanish way.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
what the okay well we lost her only oh
we don't need it
where did he come what the okay that that was so fast holy
did you see that strange
guys did you see that did you see that fly That fly was
fucking crazy!
Oh shit, don't worry, it'll be fine, right?
Oh, that's unlucky.
We got the cloak, guys.
Oh, this is bad.
This is so bad for me.
Oh my god, guys.
uh you first okay me oh okay oh not that time
guys i i need a solo ulting punisher like what okay okay
yeah there he dc'd after that wait he left yeah after that
he just left wait wait the guy left he left wait what the he
left where did he go oh i'm good oh yeah there we go you
can't complain you can't start slurring again wait oh he's
back he's back guys he's back he's back again
I'm being watched all right um, you know for a guy whose
name is
I am so confused you know what I love dgen cues
Bye Yeah, me too me too
What is going on in there?
I hope good things I really do
Me too Me too Me too Me too
No see it Okay It's fine It's okay Punisher is just like I
guess see you He's like I've hurt pretty bad I'm looking at
the punishes like Are you Are you not Are you not Are you
not I'm like, excuse me, I'm getting beat up by a Spider-Man
right now.
Bro, it's a plus 18.
That felt like a plus 18 game.
There is no way.
That really felt like a plus 18 game.
Yeah!
Free.
Let's go.
We're all freed.
13 was it 12 hours and i just only d ranked one tier let's
go g oh wait ggs congratulations congratulations on winning
the vote you didn't get punished
GG.
Hey, the votes were out.
It was a Democratic vote.
There was no tampering.
Five stars.
That was fun, though.
That was fun.
That was a good stream.
I'm tired.
I didn't...
You know what's crazy?
I didn't I'm not hungry at all.
I did not eat dinner at all today.
I'm not even...
I think I just fed off of Rivals.
It's crazy.
The craziest thing is that I felt like when we got to
Monday, I had a lot of the curry, to be fair.
It was really good.
I felt like when we got to Monday, like when the hours
finally ticked to Monday, especially in the East Coast, the
lobbies...
Got a lot nicer.
Not the game quality, but the people.
Did that feel that way?
The moment the weekend ended.
People got a lot nicer.
I definitely did.
Yeah.
I was just like, I told you DJing Qs.
That's mob.
That's, that's mobless.
DJQs, where is that?
The people with jobs are all...
Thank you.
Jobs and school.
Yeah.
There was some...
Yeah, but like...
But like, that one...
I will say that we did have the one racist guy, though, on
our team.
But like, you know...
He was very racist, but like...
He wasn't toxic racist.
You know?
He wasn't using that as a way to be toxic.
To us, but like But like it was still pretty bad It was
still pretty bad, yeah It was not like a shouting match Of
slurs Yeah He was just a He was just a casual racist Yeah
But he was at But he was was at least playing the game.
Like the earlier cues, the earlier cues we had were like one
of the guy wanted to slur at this other guy and he was
throwing.
But at least like our racist didn't throw this time.
Our racist didn't, I still reported it because I was like,
bro, that's racist.
But at least he didn't throw our game.
yeah
it's not really that much better but it's actually crazy the
difference between weekend queues and um and like regular
queues and even the fact that dj queues are better than
weekend queues freaking kris kris kris anyway i'm never
going to be queuing on saturday and sunday again this is
and today this is a once in a lifetime opportunity for all
of you it was a psa never q at saturday and sunday i've
honestly one of the worst experiences in rank we've
encountered but at least we got to experience it together we
got to we got to feel the pain together um yeah anyway guys
next sad all right not six this saturday um we have our
anniversary stream Wednesday, Tuesday, we have Yap Yap with
Sloppy Sisters and Asan and Nimi Fries.
And then that's all I have planned.
I mean, obviously I want to do God Award as well.
So, God Award this week for sure.
Tomorrow, today, today, I passed out now.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys all had a fun time watching.
It was a very fun stream.
It was a very, very fun stream today.
We went through a whole journey, like a whole fucking arc
and everything.
And I always love streaming for you guys.
I don't know why.
Rivals just, I can stream Rivals for so long.
And it was a very fun experience.
And I mean, well, not the games, though.
I mean, the games were fun to play.
The games were fun to play.
But also, you know, we had, I swear to God, yesterday and
today.
Yesterday and today had to be the coolest.
craziest games we've ever had back to back to back and by
crazy i mean the most toxic thing i've ever encountered in
my history uh streaming this game i don't think we've ever
had so many games like in a row where uh where almost every
game was just someone throwing Someone's yelling at each
other.
Someone blaming somebody.
Someone's shouting.
Like, oh my god.
Yeah.
That was fucking crazy.
That weekend.
Like, that was wild.
Do we have...
I think the highest rate was two games where we had two
people...
Two games where people were...
Out of not talking or were nice to each other.
And that was...
Out of 13...
13 hours that is not a very good record anyway guys you guys
want to check me out for the new viewers out there i usually
stream on youtube so please check me out there um i'm trying
to get million subscribers by the end of this year so please
follow me there um that's where i do my mainstreams by the
way i do twitch streams very sporadically and you want to
know whenever i do twitch streams check me out twitter
because oh my voice is starting to die now oh good timing
i ever well now i'm sorry brain fried that's whenever i
tweet out that i go live on twitch uh i want to support me
the other means i do have codes i have like a fortnite code
a ea code and an apex code and all they're all jokie bear
they're all jokie bear and other than that that's really it
um there's nothing else for me to show right now because my
merch store is closed so that's really it oh gamer subs
gamer subs code dokeybird if you want to use any of my codes
for all of those games or gamerships hey guys as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
get that blood flowing if you stay up for me head to bed
guys you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye